foreign
thank you
all right I hope my screen is visible to
all the participants
yeah it is visible thank you
yes thank you so much let me also
quickly turn on my camera all right so
hello everyone a very warm greeting to
one and all my name is and I would like
to welcome you all to day two of omits
research
so for those of you who are joining with
us for the very first time let me
introduce you about the event the Omens
Risa Symposium is a two-day online event
that is aimed at bringing together
network of experts Educators and
students from all around the world to
learn from each other interact and
discuss advances in this field and
discussions will highlight challenges
involved in research using computational
tools for Big Data opportunities in this
outgoing field and applications for the
advances in various Fields such as
clinical Pharma biotech research
including agriculture the Symposium will
be accompanied by a poster presentation
competition awarding prices and giving a
stage to students faculty and research
teams to present their research work and
get expert feedback
so before we dive into the Symposium let
me take a moment to introduce you to the
organizing organization that is posting
this event that is omix logic we are
us-based by informatics company who is
working with multiple academic and
Commercial collaborators to develop easy
to use analytical tools and our mission
is to make bioinformatics more accessing
and this omics logic training has been
completed by over 24 000 participants
from 187 countries in over 300 workshops
and due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and Regional
coordinators that are helping refine
local program Logistics and adapting
them to the needs of students and
researchers around the world this
training has been completed by
participants in six different
specialization tracks that includes
oncology infectious diseases Precision
medicine Neuroscience data science and
even comprehensive training on omic's
data analysis
resources help Advance bindformatics
teaching
homing strategic is a portal for
practical and theoretical learning of
biological data analysis
composed of courses designed to take you
through the theoretical knowledge omic's
logic takes a combination of training
modules data analysis tools curated
project data sets and interactive
sessions with mentors to give the
students a clear part of the Bloom's
taxonomy experiment and no matter what
the user's initial experience with
analysis is omits logic is a useful tool
for gaining a baseline knowledge of the
theory behind biological data analysis
analysis of large data sets and
introduction to base supporting
languages like R and python or even
beginning a data analysis project
and these are the seven courses that
were taken from the core omics logic
curriculum that is available online
so this begins with an introduction to
Applications of biological data analysis
and overview of data types then the
students are able to learn terminology
and factual knowledge to build upon from
there genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics epigenomics data science
and chem informatic concepts are
introduced and each course starts with
important terms and Concepts and then
introduces case studies and pipelines
related to each one
this allows the student to gain the
conceptual knowledge in order to begin
their own research projects
logic it spans upon such curriculum with
specialization track projects as well
biological data analysis methods are
best known in the context of real case
studies prepared by our network of
mentors and collaborators that
illustrate how various biological data
analysis letters and omics data types
are used in current research in medicine
biotechnology Agriculture and even
astrobiology
the projects are prepared by taking
publicly available data sets and using
them to explore and understand both the
research challenged and the analysis
path to extract meaningful insights from
complex omics data
the omix logic portal gives students
options for analyzing achieving data
sets and these can be code dependent
path or code independent part
these data sets and Associated
Publications can be used in several ways
you can learn biological data analysis
without any coding at all for that in
each project we explain the analysis
pipelines on the user-friendly T by
input platform which I'll be introducing
you to you shortly in a while
for Big Data analysis and you can also
learn the scripts behind many of the
steps learning to Wrangle clean
visualize and analyze data in popular
languages like R and python in order to
create your own analysis finally you can
hear about the projects and the research
applications in our Mentor guided
programs where experts share their
expertise and support research projects
that are developed by
so here is an example of the code
independent pipeline that I was just
mentioning about the pipeline Builder
interface on the T by info platform is a
color-coded pipeline that helps
establish a logical connection between
the technical names of data analysis
methods and The Logical steps needed to
build the full pipeline
so this is how you will be carrying out
the pipeline data is first potent as an
input file and then analysis can be
chosen based off the type of research
that you wish to carry out each analysis
is separated into three colors blue for
pre-processing red for mapping and green
for quantification and each time you
click on a particular algorithm a pop-up
will show that will contain additional
information that will be useful for you
while building the private
the ease of the color-coded buttons
allows programs to be run without any
coding knowledge and interactive outputs
allow easy visualization of the data and
several demo pipelines with real data
sets are available for students
researchers to practice the workflow
including demos on genomic variant
calling of cancel deadlines 15s amplicon
analysis on diet and its effect on the
microbiome and a pipeline for examining
a phylogenetic analysis of Ebola virus
so after using the T by info platform to
visualize the pipelines and practice
analyzing students are then able to take
their theoretical knowledge and apply
that in a project
then they check their comprehension with
levels and badges certificates of
completion and tests similarly faculty
should be able to assign the omic
surgery portal to their students with
understanding that it will give them
holistic and comprehensive knowledge of
biological data analysis beginning with
bytes and molecules and on to designing
their own question based project
so if you are interested to get started
with omics logic learn portal it is very
easy and free for anyone to register
with many courses available at no cost
so to view the various courses example
projects and student projects you need
to first sign up on the orange logical
portal for that let me quickly stop
sharing my screen and take you to the
home search portal
so I'm pasting the link for signing up
on the portal in the chat box for those
participants who have not signed up yet
so there you go so that is the sign up
link or omics logic portal
so once you click on the link you will
be able to ask to sign into the omic so
if you do not have a prior account on
the portal please click on the create an
account option that you see here
and then you can provide a name email ID
and password and you can sign up or you
can also sign up using any of your
social media handles that would be your
Google account Facebook account Apple
account GitHub account or even Twitter
and if you already have an account on
the portal you can simply log in with
your existing email ID and password
so that is how you can sign up on the
portal with that I'll pause for a couple
of seconds since I can see that several
participants are joining with us for the
very first time I'll pause for a couple
of seconds for them to sign up on the
portal and then I'll show you how you
can aggregate the various courses and
research case studies that are displayed
on the book so let me know in the chat
once you have signed up and if you
already have a existing account on the
portal please put a done in the chat box
so that I can know
[Music]
I'm waiting for your responses and if
you want me to explain any of the steps
that I was mentioning about while
signing up please let me know that as
well and I'll be happy to guide you
and along the way if you are facing any
technical issues while signing up please
feel free to reach out to us as well and
we'll be happy to look into it
all right I can see that
few participants have signed up already
on the ported
all right meanwhile
um rest of them are signing up let me
quickly sign in and show you how you can
navigate through the coursework
all right so once you sign in you will
be able to see the courses page so how
do you navigate and uh try to understand
the various courses that the portal has
to offer so to be able to do that scroll
down below and when you scroll down
below you will see a search bar that
says looking for a specific course so
here if you want to enter any of your
key area of research entrance let's say
if someone wants to learn about buying
Fanatics for very first time so you can
simply enter the term mathematics
and that will show you the various
courses and example projects that are
associated with
so course one introduction to
bioinformatics as well as course to
bytes and molecules are introductory
coursework for those participants who do
not have a prior background of
bindmatics and omix data and these are
three courses with certification
available so please feel free to check
it out and another interesting
courseworks that I want to direct is uh
to those participants who are interested
in coding
so if I think course one getting started
with bi-informatics and our coding
course one getting started with Brian
schematics are two of the other three
courseworks that are available with free
certification so for those participants
who are interested to gain knowledge
about
reporting that is related to Python and
R please feel free to check it out so
that is all about how you can navigate
through the omen storage flow in Portal
and now you also have to set up your
account on the portal so how do you do
that so you can see a blue bar that says
welcome back with your email ID
so once you click on this you will be
directly taken to your account settings
so here you will be able to see a button
that says profile click on that and that
will able to edit all the features that
you are required to update on your
account so what are these features make
sure that your name is in proper
capitalization because your certificates
will be automatically generated so it is
important that your name has to be a
proper capitalization and add a brief
part about yourself so that we know your
background and your research interest so
in my case I have added about my
education background
research interest and add a profile
image for yourself as well and finally
you can add your link to your social
medias like for instance in my case I
have linked my LinkedIn account and my
the once that is done your profile will
be complete and then you will be also
seeing several tabs under your profile
so for instance you have the activity
tab wherein the program mentor and the
community manager they will be able to
track your learning progress right
and under the courses tab you will be
able to keep a track of all the courses
that you are currently enrolled in and
it will also display the progress that
you are making
and finally you will be able to receive
all of the certificates after the
required coursework lesson completion
quizzes assignments and the certificates
will appear under the certificates
so that is all about and another
interesting tag that I want to show you
is the project stack wherein all of the
student research projects that have been
carried out so far from various training
programs have been displayed and
compiled together on this section so
these student research projects
um range from topics on oncology in
Texas disease Precision medicine
Neuroscience data science machine
learning astrobiology and so take a look
at it and explore at your own pace so
let me quickly check to check all right
Peter has also signed up thank you so
much Victor
so let me go back to my presentation
all right so I can see that several of
the participants are joining us for the
very first time so let me quickly
summarize the events that happened on
day one
so to begin with Dr Mohit mazungar
introduced us to omix logic Asia and how
the team is working to provide a
platform for Learning and skill
development in biological data analysis
then we were joined by Dr Andrew Lin who
discussed the modeling of sequence
evolution in the SARS opening Spike
protein and its implication for immune
escape and vaccine design which is
especially relevant given the current
pandemic situation
then we were joined by Dr Mukesh Gupta
Who provided us with insights into the
omics of spermatozoa and its relevance
to male fertility which has important
implications for Reproductive health
then we were then we had an exciting
academic panel discussion on the future
of bioinformatics and data science in
India that provided us with diverse
perspectives on challenges and
opportunities that the field has
protected then we were had an exciting
poster presentation competition that
showcased Innovative research by
students in the field of bioinformatics
and data clients the next session will
focus on homework storage in Africa
wherein Mr adequately introduced us to
women's logic Africa and how the team is
working to provide a platform for skill
development in biological data
management
then we had another exciting session by
Mr Ashraf who highlighted the need for
more bioinformations in Africa this was
followed by Dr Phil UK who discussed the
importance of Pines merits in livestock
movement which has significant
implications for agriculture sector in
Africa finally the day one concluded by
a panel discussion on bioinformatics
education training and research in
Africa that provided valuable insight
into the challenges and opportunities in
the field and how the team is working
towards building a stronger biomatic
community in Africa so overall yesterday
was an incredibly informative and
exciting day filled with fascinating
discussions and presentation today
promises to be just as engaging with the
lineup of renowned speakers who will
share their insights and expertise on
the latest Trend in this field so
without further delay please join me in
welcoming our first Speaker Dr Mohit
marumdar Dr malvindar has over 12 years
of research and Industry experience he
completed Masters in mind marriage from
Jamia islamia and a PhD in computational
biology and chemistry from jawaharlal
nehru University he is an expert in
machine learning and application to
biomedical and chemical data he is
currently heading the global business
development for fine biotech USA and
contributing to biological data fines
research and education by collaborating
with universities yeah and Africa
mentoring partitions from various
program by providing research and today
he will be giving you a review of day
one and a brief introduction today so
with that the stage is all yours
thank you srivari and uh welcome to all
the participants who have joined today
so let me just share my screen
okay
so um as this as sugar is said
um today we will start with a detailed
review of what we did yesterday and
understanding and summarizing some of
the things that would help us gain and
extract information and knowledge from
these sessions by speakers who have the
immense experience in their field so it
was a great day one and we are excited
to start our day two for This research
Symposium and for in this presentation
I think uh there are some things that we
have already discussed and as many of
you are joining and will be joining
throughout the day uh we will be also uh
available on on live on YouTube and also
uh you can reach out to us via chat in
the chat box feel uh feel free to reach
out to our team or any assistance uh
with that I'll start what we have
planned for day two and also review day
one and uh we have some exciting things
happening during the day we have a
workshop coming up so I think uh we are
all looking forward to that to that as
well which will be a great learning
experience for those who interested to
you know dive to dive deeper into some
of these type of data analysis and
methods that we have been discussing and
showcasing
so
um yesterday it was a great opportunity
for all of us to learn from Professor
Andrew Lin who is a very renowned
Professor from jawahar nehru University
uh School of Integrative Sciences
and it was great to learn from him about
his research which is mostly about
modeling sequence evolution in South
scope 2 proteins so in that in that talk
we learned several things from him and
the research and also a lot about what
people have already done uh in the sky
Spike proteins and its Evolution
predicting potentially immune Escape
variants and researchers using
computational models to analyze the
genetic data of the virus so one of the
approach he was discussed he discussed
and was very common for most biologists
and bioinformaticians which is multiple
sequence alignment
so how can you predict uh you know
mutations and predict their effect like
whether they will be stabilizing or not
and their binding properties of the uh
Skype Spike protein to its cellular
receptor which is the as2 receptor so he
also elucidated a significant volume of
research that has focused on monitoring
and analyzing existing Skype Spike
proteins protein data in order to track
the evolution of the virus and make
predictions about the future sequences
that would be coming that we could uh
you know
C so interpretation of these substrate
specificity and determining residue and
then understanding which enzyme subclass
and sub families are there is an
important way to understand the entire
um entire virus and its family and its
functional characteristics so there was
a lot of focus on that during the talk
and uh
Professor Lynn also discussed
about the receptor binding domain and
its structure and showed us different uh
locations of these residues on the
x-axis and the structural fold and the
function so understanding how these data
are put together and how the protein
sequence of each segment like the Alpha
Delta beta beta Omicron are put are
looking so through nucleotide alignment
and annotation they try to map the
differences and understand what how and
understand by comparing with the wild
type so these are some of the things
that we learned from the session and
um and soon we will be also
making the session available on our
YouTube channel so I think you can look
forward to that and learn more
by going through the session again
because some of these talks were very
technical and uh I think going again and
going again would definitely be helpful
to understand in a deeper sense that how
some of these methods have been used and
why these methods have been used for a
specific type of problem so uh next talk
was by Dr mukeshki Gupta Professor
Mukesh Gupta and his title was something
that a lot a very less number of people
have been working upon using technology
such as Next Generation sequencing
Technologies and has a huge role in
in market for people who are looking for
such help in terms of conceiving so one
of uh one of the things that uh Dr Gupta
was able to discuss is about the
infertility rate that it has like
globally there is a 60 to 80 million
couples uh and in India there are 20
million couples who have these types of
disorders and characterizing the
different types of infertilities and
then uh showing that what his research
and how his research has helped in this
entire area and the different ways they
have collected the
the data and how they have
designed the experiments and uh
collected different types of data and
and in the end integrating them for
understanding specific types of uh
problems that these uh different cases
have shown in different regions so that
was a great talk and we have learned a
lot about depletion of the spermatology
with uh relationship with the RNA and
then
the use of IVF and the embryo
development and specific functions that
you discovered for the uh
for the RNA function so that was a good
talk if someone is interested in
understanding and doing more research in
this area because there's a lot of
opportunities in for business
opportunities as well as research
opportunities and the translational
research opportunities so um that's what
we were discussing during the academic
panel discussion which was really very
enlightening because it actually paves
way for institutions for companies for
for governments to best utilize and what
is the way forward for students uh to
take up these different types of skill
sets and based on and expect what in
terms of you know opportunities or uh
the kind of career one would imagine so
these were very important points that we
were discussed that were discussed
during the entire academic panel and
covering and telling the way forward and
uh for specifically for students coming
from a non-bioinformatics background to
bioinformatics background and data
analysis background more more about the
biological data analysis capabilities
and finding the ways using these type of
coursework
online coursework certification or
diploma course for
um deeper understanding and then
understanding uh about the principles
and open source tools and using the
graphical user interface for beginners
and classifying the the
uh students into several categories
about you know engineering technicians
and scientists and you know people who
are
working as an application scientist and
the way forward to do internships and in
the field of data science and how many
companies are planning to use Ai and use
this data and how this is growing in
specific countries around India and also
in Africa so this was a very uh good
session and I think if you would want to
go through it and you would want to gain
some in insights that would be something
that I would really recommend for those
who are who are investigating more into
how to build capacity and how to address
the gaps so followed by that we had the
exciting session where we had the
student presentations from
uh from our own Miss logic programs
research fellowship program and as well
as students who have done their own
research or at their own labs and pis so
um we had the session where we got the
presentations from the students from
specifically talking about different
types of research areas and what they
have been able to contribute so I think
one of the key presentation that we
started off with was about uh the role
of you know crop interventions and diet
supplements to combat food insecurity in
sub-sahara regions and then
understanding the microbiome in animals
like cats understanding their role in
microbial community in health and
disease then we learned from Ariana
which was the first talk perhaps about
the
use of deep learning Noble deep learning
predictor for post therapeutic breast
cancer reoccurrence risk people who have
developed a breast cancer many times
there has been cases that there is a
reoccurrence and she used multiomics
data integration framework to find out
the biomarkers and specific genes uh the
those were responsible and could be
identified and towards said to be
biomarkers for the diagnosis so that was
a very good presentation and then we had
a presentation by tanmai exploring the
role of
intestinal microbiota and how it
regulates the high fiber and high
fermented diet and there were questions
by
by the experts who are listed here Dr
Julia panov and Dr Priyanka narath for
Amity University and Dr Ramesh from
River University and uh they were very
satisfied with uh with the with many of
these projects and gave their feedback
and uh there were also some projects
which were not we were not been able to
Showcase but uh um those will be
available as well
um as short videos for those who are
interested in understanding uh like
projects which are related to
Parkinson's diseases and the crop in
intervention and diet supplements
project uh which were not shown uh
during the presentation but are
available so uh also uh as SRI Guri said
once you start exploring on the learn or
Miss logic you will find there is a
section on projects where all these
projects have been published and it's a
great resource to develop new ideas from
what uh seeing how these projects are
done and using public repositories
publicly publicly available data which
are repurposed and reused to look into
some different types of analysis
so we will do a short glimpse of that
and then as said uh adekunle our
director from
um the omics logic Africa team discussed
about the valuable initiatives and the
much needed training and capacity
building environmentics and data science
for life science researchers in Africa
and building local expertise and skills
programs which are aimed to support
research and innovation in the region uh
focused on local problems and we have
been working on several of these
research projects on malaria
on different types of immune immune
related diseases which are prevalent in
Africa and also important challenges in
health and agriculture so there were
discussions about how a student can be
associated with umislagic Africa
initiative our researcher can be
Associated and our professional can be
associated with the with the initiative
and we are looking for uh for
participation from our African Community
and help local problems such as local
problems and also participate in global
Problems by working as a team working as
a community utilizing the homeless logic
as a community a network of researchers
from all around the globe trying to
understand and trying to utilize the
data so after that we had this amazing
talk by Mr rastroph
recently showed also his publication
that talks about the need for more
bioinformatics bioinformaticians in
Africa he explained the bioinformatics
definition and the components like I.T
computer science databases molecular
biology problems in Africa so how there
is a lag in IIT sector and expertise
lack of basic problems such as
electricity government what are the
different government interventions and
lack of you know High throughput
machines and practical implementation
and because of that the data generation
is not very specific to African
population and what are the ways one
could be utilizing the resources such as
public repositories and do their
research
um because it's challenging to do data
generation but it is still possible to
do this data analysis and interpretation
using platforms such as ours and many
other which are available so we also had
this session followed by
followed by the session about the
education in Africa and the current need
to the role of bioinformatics and
livestock a livestock Improvement so it
was a session where we where the where
the expert uh feluke who is an
Associated Professor Dr faluke Who is an
Associated professor at the department
of animal production molecular Evolution
and genetic diversity unit so these type
of sessions I think are very very
helpful and it's it's very enlightening
for many of us to understand that how
these uh not only like how these
biological Technologies are being
utilized in different types of areas
like you name it and you will be able to
find that there is an application and
many of these applications are are still
to be explored and still to be you know
properly executed and hence There's an
opportunity for all of you for all of
those who are new to this field or for
all of those who are excited about this
week to contribute and do something
meaningful which could be startups it
could be you know research projects it
could be just an Initiative for you to
start your journey and in the end you
will be able to find those opportunities
and that's what's something that we've
discussed in the panel discussions and
understanding from these exports so as I
was saying that
Dr faluke was uh talked about how
bioinformatics is an important aspect of
in thrilling genomic data to enhance uh
you know breeding programs increase
productivity and understand like how we
can unlock the homics data such as
genomics proteomics transcriptomics
lipidomics Like Comics and use this for
uh for a better understanding and
interventions that could just change the
way things are right now making it much
more efficient process much more
productive and also much more scientific
and in the end
um
uh also in the in the end we have to
think about the sustainability in terms
of uh how it is affecting the
environment so um we uh here learned
about different types of databases uh
basic bioinformatics and computational
statistical techniques that one need to
have to be able to go through the data
and also have those Basics that are
required for you to get a deeper
understanding of different types of data
so I think um it was followed by the
panel discussion which SRI gauri just
explained you in much more detail but
yeah in conclusion I think uh we are all
at that stage where we would want to do
this in a way that would make uh make
the Next Generation and make the next
set of people in life easier by uh
collecting right kind of data by doing
meaningful research and not just by full
feeling you know the requirements of a
degree or anything like that but to gain
real knowledge and then participate
because otherwise it's not something
that would be able to you know sustain
and do long term so that's why I think
we had the small case study uh that I
quickly wanted to go through uh but
before that I would just want to tell
you that
um what the sessions are looking like so
we will be having our next session in
couple of minutes and I want to show you
about the industrial partnership and the
industry focused uh talks that we are
having in the next uh next uh a few uh
in the next few hours and also
throughout the day so
now we are really fortunate to have a
lot of Industry
um Partners who have collaborated with
us in several different ways and are
utilizing and have utilized the Learned
omics logic or the server for research
for training and uh for providing career
guidance and opportunities as well as
job opportunities and internships so we
have been constantly reaching out to
Industry and we are inviting industry
for their expertise and letting students
know their need and provide uh work with
us to provide them provide the student
community and the research Community the
right kind of tools right kind of
guidance to be able to excel in their
careers so we recently collaborated and
we are starting
um student career Based training
incorporated into the homixlogic
training which would help any student to
you know connect their skill sets with
the kind of job opportunities that are
there but as we realized while working
with thousands of students that there
are major gaps in that area as well so
that's why this collaboration is to help
those students develop a strength
assessment job searching strategies
personal branding networking resume CV
cover letters Sops so for higher
education for job opportunities
communication skills these are very
important skill sets that are also
required in addition to the hard skills
that you're learning the projects that
you're doing so that's that's how I
think it would be a complete journey and
you will be Market ready so that's where
we have these initiatives and
collaborations to help students learn
from collaborative resources and experts
from the industry similarly
for research we have collaborations with
NGS industry Partners such as Primus
Life Sciences who are really
um doing a lot of research with a lot of
research labs in India providing
Technologies such as Elimina uh tennis
genomics twist biosciences working on
clinical genomics omics research and
different types of cool Fields such as
synthetic biology genetic engineering
and they're also working on different
types of research projects and providing
these these instruments and support So
to the labs so we are collaborating and
we are working together to be able to
provide right kind of data analysis
tools and skill sets and capacity as
well as research support and end-to-end
data analysis support so that uh based
on the requirements of the of the
participant or of the institutions out
of the lab or of the universities or of
the company
we can provide all of those requirements
in this sequencing
the sequencing areas and similarly we
have our other partners uh who are
working on different Technologies for
sequencing such as Oxford nano4
technology which is a very uh upcoming
technology that provides a high accuracy
based calling at very low cost and uh
alignments on methylation and all of
that so uh one of the technology is also
the nanopore mini IAM so it's uh it's a
very portable and also it's a very
affordable sequencing technology I think
which many of uh of uh many of the
researchers are aware of and also are
not aware of so it helps in acquiring uh
you know different types of
sequence uh any anything anywhere
actually and it's real time and also
like uh Technologies such as Promethean
which is which generates uh you know up
to 11 terabytes of data in 48 hours so
these are the technologies that are the
future technologies that many labs and
institutions and and uh research
institutions and
um and companies are readily using these
Technologies so
um we also collaborated with the AI
based or academic healthcare companies
to be able to provide such Services as
well as to be able to provide
opportunities for the students and uh we
are really uh
happy to be able to collaborate with uh
with Faba so Federation of Asian biotech
Association
um we have been collaborating uh we have
been collaborated for last three years
and working and developing different
types of programs for Bio biomedical
data science chem informatics and Drug
Discovery as well as working and helping
different institutions to develop such
capacity with the help of Professor
radana Dr kamath Dr saxena and their
experienced
Pharma leaders and they understand where
the industry is heading and where the
drug Discovery industry is heading so
together we have developed several
curriculums just to help students
understand chem informatics drug
Discovery from an industry perspective
and now this has been taken up by the
CEO Dr jagadish and other respected
members so we will be hearing from them
as well very soon so as I was telling
you that uh for a life science student
or professional uh I think we we quite
hear about drug Discovery all the time
and the problems with drug Discovery so
this actually addresses that so we have
the upcoming session coming up
um and I think we are
over time so without any further delay
I'd like to ask srigori to invite the
next speaker and the opportunity for all
of us to learn from Dr jagadisha and his
uh
his insights into the industry and from
his experience thank you
all right thank you so much uh Dr Mohit
for giving us an overview about the day
one and with that uh we'll be passing on
to the next session so we all know that
advancements in healthcare and
biotechnology have enabled us to better
understand and treat diseases develop
new therapies and medicine and make
significant strides towards personalized
medicine
but what are the latest trends in
healthcare and biotechnology and what
are the various potential that the field
has to offer so for all of that and more
we'll be discussing about that in our
upcoming fashion by Dr jagbish kandla Dr
Jadis grandler is a seasoned
entrepreneur with a strong background in
science and passion for driving
innovation in healthcare
as an accomplished scientist or an
entrepreneur he has successfully built
and led startups in the Life Sciences
and Healthcare space his expertise lies
in community building and mentoring and
having worked with prominent
International organizations like the
European Union EIT Health to establish
mentoring and alumni networks he also
founded his own startups including dare
to start and Global Life Sciences and
Healthcare network with a focus on
helping others establish their own
startups and fostering bilateral price
between Europe and India currently he is
serving as the chief operating officer
at the Federation of Asian biotech
associations in India where he is
leveraging his experience and expertise
to build robust entrepreneurship
entrepreneurial ecosystem in the
biotechnology and the life science space
so with that brief introduction please
join me in welcoming Dr
I'm stopping my sharing and the screen
is all you
thank you and thank you Mohit for
inviting me I think my five minutes is
gone in the introduction next time you
can skip it
no problem because this Trends topic is
quite quite uh broad one right so I
would really like to talk and inspire
people about what where where they can
their career can lead to
okay so uh SRI Gallery may know what
what is the background of uh people
we do have several participants who are
beginner in bioinformatics and their
research interests mainly lies in plant
biotechnology and agriculture
okay okay so so everyone like please
keep it interactive like you don't need
to wait until I finish because we also
don't have much time it's only half an
hour so let me try to share my screen
so okay
okay so let's talk about Trends in
biotechnology and Healthcare
so we will basically understand what is
a trend and then then where you know
opportunity lies so I mean it's
fortunate that you're already connected
with omics logic because they are
they're one of the best companies who
are training the next generation of
scientists especially in this data
science and artificial intelligence so
firstly let me introduce myself who am I
so I'm a BSC biotech I did my BSC in
India MSC also in India at University of
Hyderabad and PhD in Germany
and then worked with several healthcare
companies in India and our serve as a
chief operating officer at Federation
operation biotechnology Association have
mentored several Healthcare startups and
students built several communities and
startups and and and also I used to work
at a Technical University of Munich in
Africa for Africa on global Health
projects so I think since we have lots
of African students here so my topic is
a bit related to Global Health where I
mean I think one of the burning issue
Global Health let's say this pandemic or
anything of malaria leishmania
tuberculosis and all these things how
you can apply this Cutting Edge
Technologies to our own problems like
you know India or Africa
so let's say first so my topic is Trends
in healthcare and biotechnology so
before we move into uh looking into what
are the trends first understand what is
a trend so a trend is a general
direction in which something is
developing or changing okay so when you
when you talk about biotechnological
Healthcare sense Trends so why should we
know about it and what what exactly is
it Trend so here
the biotech or Healthcare Trends serve
as a compass for the biotechnology or
healthcare industry indicating where it
is headed
and highlighting the disruptive
Technologies bound to reshape it these
Trends also help industry leaders to get
a greater sense of end user needs and
how they can modernize their business
models to meet them for example I mean
you know if if you have been using Nokia
phone long time back they did not
understand the technology of smartphones
they didn't understand the trend so they
failed in the business so that's how
basically you know some Consultants they
set the trends and based on that whole
industry will follow
so what is biotechnology I mean let's
let's keep it interactive may know what
is biotechnology if somebody can type a
definition in the chat
what is biotechnology so there's also a
test that if you are alert or not
come on should not shy away
what is biotechnology so who is you can
also open your microphone and talk
who is the hero first one to send me the
answer
foreign
we need to find a way how to install
people
surely
yeah
okay this is not good so people you need
to be open up and speaking these are the
Fantastic opportunities that that you
get to know okay I see it's a it's
basically it basically involves using
biological systems and mechanisms which
is so aim of developing enhanced product
fantastic sir that's amazing that's what
is by technology so biotechnology is a
technology that utilizes biological
systems living organisms are parts of
this to develop or create different
products it could be vaccines it could
be enzymes it could be anything where
biological organs are used biological
material is used it would be animals
cells anything
okay so how about Healthcare or biotech
Trends being set
so usually it's always about money you
know funding like let's say in the
research based on the funding research
or innovation educational businesses
will be set then afterwards you know
Trends put forth by institutions like
World Health Organization or some
consulting firms so because they have
the data and they understand where we
need more resources that's where the
trends are being said so we'll talk
about them today
I'll try to share a few things because
we don't have much time so I mean when I
started my career in biotechnology I
think in in 2000s people were saying
biotech boom is happening now at that
time but actually there was never
biotech boom I didn't really it was even
difficult to find a job after Masters or
PhD but now after the covet pandemic
there's this different kind of
Revolution happening in terms of
vaccines or in terms of uh you know car
T cell therapy and all these things so I
think the biotech boom is happening now
and we have to capitalize on it so
before jumping onto it since we we have
a lot of participants from Africa let's
look into one major problem that we are
we have to address one is one Health
so one Health represents an integrated
approach to advancing multi-species
Health at the human animal environment
interface so basically we are not living
alone on this planet we have animals we
have plants we have microbiota so lot of
things are there we basically live along
with everybody this is where you know we
need to take care of Everybody's Health
so that's where this one health concept
comes so basically I have told you what
are Trends I told you what is
biotechnology what is Healthcare slowly
I have diverted you into different
concept of one Health where where what I
want to highlight here is that human is
not alone and and as a researcher or
somebody who's in the industry we have
to think everything is as one and then
you know you can use your trends for
that
so one Health if you have seen you know
I mean birds are caged very wrongly you
see how the pollution and and the global
warming Mining and all these things are
happening so it's really difficult I
think we will the global warming is
happening I think we are not headed in
the right direction
so as I said you know humans environment
animals we are all living together and
one health comes in place there
so sixty percent of all our diseases are
zoonotic so that means they come through
animals and 70 of all the emerging human
infectious disease in the past decades
originated in animals like kovid all
these things they came from animals and
65 65 percent of all the neglected
capitalism or zoonotic
so the population is projected to grow
from 7 billion in 2011 to 9.8 billion by
2050. so that means the no number more
number of people we are there'll be more
interaction with animals and environment
and and that interaction is going to
increase so that's where we need to look
into this communication where everybody
are all their needs are taken care like
sectors and disciplines Society one
Health everything has to come together
that's where I think you know that's
that's the idea where I was working at
Global Health in the Technical
University of Munich in Germany and we
used to do a lot of projects about
neglected tropical disease solid project
systematic project assistant project is
about 10 years olium
and we worked on antimicrobial
assistance and neglected uh and
neglected tropical disease drug
development and the helm about helmets
we did lots of projects we also did some
clinical trials of prosequental per you
know helmet disease
so I mean this is one of the projects
that I have worked about 10 years Solium
where you know in Africa and India and
couple of Asian countries Latin America
where pigs are eaten that's where this
disease used to come actually it still
exists and there are so many people who
struggles and uh this life cycle is it
starts from animal then uh so first
human it will the tapeworm will be in
the human then when he sheds his feces
eggs will come out that will be taken up
by Pig and then when you pig when you
eat like a raw pig meat it comes again
and this is deadly and usually people
develop epilepsy
and the many people who are struggling
with it I'm just trying to give an
example like how this kind of disease
are neglected and how people like you
with the strengths and with this omix
logic's help I think you have to address
these things so you know there is not
even a proper test that is available for
the disease so we developed a kit so
simple like uh you know lateral protest
we developed one kid with the help of
many many uh Institute in collaboration
with
we are also doing clinical trials with a
small drug called prosequental
so okay so that's like a background now
let's really look into Trends so uh I
don't have trends for 2023 I'm giving
Trends from 2022 and I also have some
data from 2021 so I still I don't think
we are ready yet for 2023 so let's let's
take example of 2022. so if you look at
top 10 Trends in biotechnology
so artificial intelligence so biotech
and health will go hand in handy
somebody can I mute them
oh correct
so
so these are the trends like artificial
intelligence Big Data Gene editing
Precision medicine Gene sequencing
biomanufacturing synthetic biology
bioprinting microfluidic tissue
engineering these are the top 10 Trends
these are couple of companies that we
used to work with they work in this
Trends so let's look into each Trend so
what is artificial intelligence I mean I
think Mohit was beautiful explaining
when I joined
so artificial intelligence refers to the
simulation or approximation of human
intelligence in machines
so this artificial intelligence I think
we we is is going to change a lot of our
lives in many things especially in the
drug Discovery and other processes so
biopharma can biopharma startups can
leverage artificial intelligence to
speed up drug Discovery as I mentioned
uh we are also doing a workshop on it
screening biomarkers scraping through
scientific literature to discover novel
products now image classification
algorithms allowing rapid detection of
different traits such as cancer cells
from medical scans or crop science
systems from leaf leaf images leveraging
deep learning to analyze microbiome
screen phenotypes and develop rapid
Diagnostics so one can use in
Diagnostics one can use in Discovery one
could use in in many things wherever
there is you know Big Data like really
lot of data one could automate it
through artificial intelligence that's
one of the trend so why understanding
this trend will help you is that you
know you could you could do next big
company in this field or you can start
your career in the screen or you can do
research in this field so it will help
you in every aspect of wherever you are
aiming it so the next one
next one is Big Data and of course
mohit's company Pine bio is is helping
you so the definition of big data is
that is is data that contains greater
variety arriving in increasing volumes
with more velocity so I don't want to
read everything so you could you could
basically it's like omics Technologies
so recruitment of patients for clinical
trials finding effective drug candidates
so you could basically use drug Big Data
Lots I have lots of friends who are
working in big Pharma companies they
they are basically collecting big data
and analyzing it analyzing big data is
not so easy so big data comes it can
come from anywhere it could be in the
healthcare it could be in the Cosmetic
space it could be in any any of the
space like wherever you collect data you
need to analyze it and and that is one
of the trend and there are lots of jobs
in this field
okay yeah so that's like the second
Trend and the third trend is Gene
editing so Gene editing I mean I'm not
sure if you guys know recently there was
a Nobel Prize for Christopher uh
Emmanuel charpentier and Jennifer doudna
who invented crispr who discovered
crispr so they basically opened up a new
field in genome editing there are lots
of diseases like thalassemia
where it can be written only through
genes because these are genetic defects
and one can also increase crop yield so
this is one of the field that is really
flourishing and there are lots of
companies that are budding and there are
also a lot of problems that has to be
addressed so please look into it you
will learn quite a lot especially look
into that uh technique called crispr
and the Precision medicine so I mean
Precision medicine or personal medicine
is something where you know which is
very very specific to one individual so
my the drug that works on me may not be
working on you so you this this kind of
field is really evolving because you
know most of the drugs whatever work in
some people may not work so this
Precision medicine will help to identify
new drug targets it's called novel drugs
offered Gene therapies develop new drug
delivery technology so this field is
rapidly evolving there's lots of
Investments coming in please look into
it okay
another one is microfluidics so
microfluidics I mean the beauty of
microfluidics you know these are very
very small channels and when you put any
drop of liquid here it could be blood or
water any liquid the properties are
completely different what you see
outside so this is where a new
technology opened up this in this micro
channels you know one could basically
build a lever here a kidney here a brain
here these things are fantastic I mean
they they will I think they are already
in the market but once they come in they
will revolutionize holds diagnostic
space or or Discovery Space all
experimental cells most of the clinical
trials can be done on this lab as a dish
you know
so I can I think I kind of briefed about
five runs that are really interesting
but there are also many others so just
because of time I'm not focusing more uh
on every technique so another one is
Gene sequencing where you have
illuminous all other sequencing machines
which are you know the technology we
think we are we are already in Rapid
space but actually there is much more
you know using this technology you could
sequence microbiome genome there are
many things to to still figure out we
could already you know predict this is
what we get in next 20 or 30 years bio
manufacturing like large scale
fermenters like you are you're producing
organic meat in the lab vegetarian meat
so all these things are coming up
synthetic biology where you produce
bacteria or anything that could let's
say biofuels and all these things bio
printing so my teacher used to say like
once once a biotechnology flourishes at
one point we'll be printing liver
kidneys and all these things when we
want it we go just go to supermarket and
buy it so that's where this technology
is growing tissue engineering so these
are all the trends and these are all the
trends set by you know based on how
Investments and everything is coming so
I'll try to share based on funding
so Global health and biotech investment
update I took this report from a company
called deal room Co so where they do
analysis based on investments so let's
look into some valuation figures like
how to how these companies like you know
biotech companies and Healthcare
companies have projected the numbers
so the global VC funding if you look
into the Venture Capital funding so
Venture Capital so uh
if you don't understand what I am
talking don't worry about it so this is
all startup language that we use it's
all about companies what they raise
money and everything so here if you look
into 2010 the funding that VCS used to
invest in the healthcare companies was
around only 10 billion but when when it
increased to 2021 it increased to 79
billion so there is a tech scale 8X
increased or 800x increase within 10
years so this kind of shows that this is
where is the trends are happening this
is where the Investments are happening
so this is a real real kind of reality
where we can expect that there will be
more money there will be more research
happening
and also when you look at the unicorns
unicorns are the number of the startups
that have one billion valuation are
called as unicorns so in biotech and
health Tech if you see in 2014 there
were only four then slowly slowly slowly
they increase now 84 and they will
increase day by day after the pandemic
you know the the people started to
believe in healthcare and people started
to invest in healthcare so they will
grow and combine Enterprise value of
both Health Tech and biotech was was few
now it increased to trillions it used to
be in billions now it's in trillions so
the number is increasing like anything
and people like us has to play a big
role
so
as I said you know the the health tech
companies globally have reached a
combined value of around 1.7 trillion F
5.5 X increase since 2016. so there are
a lot of companies like you know the
Illumina which is the major sequencing
company the valuation is quite a lot 64
billion and there are many other
companies there was also one company
Indian company that I was looking into
it I'll try to tell you it's in the
different slide deck but what I'm here
what do you need to look in here what
I'm trying to show is the valuation of
the companies got increased when the
valuation increases that shows that the
field is really increasing
and the second one is glucose the
diabetes Market diabetes Market is
increasing like anything and it will it
is not going to slow down it will
increase the so Dexcom is one of the
major companies who is you know
providing insulin pumps and other things
so that if you look into these things
like you know what this Farm is Farm is
one of the Indian companies that I was
looking into it they recently read a
series of funding of around 500 million
so this really shows that you know
people are now interested to invest in
healthcare and biotech and and this is
where you know the biotech boom is
happening and people I can find whoever
works hard their careers are not so
difficult now it could be easily made
okay so those are so those those one
thing so I try to tell you uh like what
are the trends that are happening
through fields and then I showed you the
the investment landscape now let's going
into different field like a like how
Consultants or otherwise somebody who
are big bodies like who they basically
see there are lots of health challenges
that are very urgent and we need to
address of course kovid is one thing I
think it is not finished yet we will it
will come back again so couple of other
challenges you know
elevating Health in the climate debate
like air pollution
malnutrition spreading of malaria this
is one of the major problem that we have
to address and and uh this is I think
they have set around 13th I picked up
only six which which is relevant to us
delivering Health in conflict in crisis
for example ukrain and Russia war is
happening how could we give Health to
them okay making Health Care fairer
social economic gaps let's say people
who have money they have better health
as well because they have access to good
health care but how can we make it
fairer that everybody is equal in terms
of healthcare
then expanding access expanding access
to medicines like falsified medicines
vaccine Supply so there are lots of uh
you know falsified medicines have come
into the market but how can we attack
how can we tackle it vaccine Supply like
vaccine is not supplied properly in many
places of the world
stopping infectious diseases especially
like declare tropical diseases and
tuberculosis Etc how could we stop it
and preparing for pandemics endemics
like covid-19 is kind of example like we
were not at all prepared or we were
underprepared and then how can we in the
future how could we prepare so finally
you know I want to close with the
sustainable development goals set by un
United Nations although there are lots
of 17 goals that we have been said like
you know no poverty zero hunger good
health and well-being quality education
generic quality a lot of other things I
think you might be aware of it so just
take this as an example there are so
many things to be solved and there are
Trends so you once you are passionate
about things especially in healthcare
and biotechnology I think that the
revolution is happening and you have to
participate in it so that's all today
for today for my talk and I would be
happy to take any questions or feedback
I have three more minutes
thank you so much Dr gandla so I have
been receiving few queries so let me ask
that one by one so we have one query uh
can you share your perspectives on the
potential of wearable digital devices in
healthcare and
how could they enable Healthcare
Providers to provide highly personalized
care
so the wearable technology is basically
right so wearable Technologies itself is
a is a big field so I mean if you follow
the Apple watch trend
so they they basically projected
themselves not as a medical device but
but when you look into it it still shows
that when you have heart attack or when
you are not when you are not having
proper energy how is your temperature I
think these things will play a very big
role already playing a big role
and glucose monitoring is one big
example there are sensors that you can
just put it on your hand it will measure
for next 14 days and tells you like what
when you eat something what will happen
next like when do you need when you are
fit for energy or fit for exercise when
you are not fit for exercise how good is
your sleep I think these things right
now people are collecting data people
are not into personalized medicine yet
they're collecting data but once data is
pulled I think next big giants like
Facebook is already investing in it
Google is investing in it Amazon
investing in it so the personalized
medicine is already happening in this
space but it will happen quite a lot
thank you so much I hope uh that's
awesome provided since ready and then
the second is the biotech Industries
drug research segment is exhibiting
great potential uh I would appreciate
hearing your perspective on this matter
and uh
he is interested in smart technology
the biotechnology of smart technology
it's he's a smart technology yeah okay
so
I think smart in the sense you were
talking about smart proteins if I'm not
wrong
smart proteins in this people call Smart
proteins when you are making you know
alternative meat or producing
plant-based meat uh something where you
would like to reduce Global footprint of
animals so that's where smart proteins
are playing role Smart Technologies are
playing role right now there's a lot of
investment hype in it and I think we
need to focus on it otherwise you know
just relying on animals growing lots of
animals and killing them it's not good
for the planet also not good for our
health so I think that the technology I
have seen couple of companies raising
big amount of money in this space
and the next question that we have is I
recently completed my masters in
biotechnology from Kolkata please sir
how do I get opportunities in healthcare
data science domain
contact Dr Mohit majumdar
I think Mohit will be the right person
to tell you because his company is built
to help you people like you
but the question has been directed at
you so I guess your Insight will be
helpful as well
so the question is like how how to
establish skeleton technology like this
right the person has a background in
biotechnology but it looks like he wants
to transition to healthcare data science
room
exactly so Healthcare data Sciences is a
very big field and that that could be in
many things you could look into clinical
trials or you could look into
Big Data analysis for example one of my
friend works for boringa ringleheim in
in Austria Vienna so he works on cancer
big data so it's all Healthcare data
analytics so he does it and he predicts
like what kind of mutation will lead to
what kind of cancer and I'm talking
mostly cancer but there are many many
diseases one could look into Data so the
future is bright in this space but the
thing is you need to be well equipped
with certain type of techniques and that
techniques is usually not taught at your
college in biotechnology and that's
where you know Mohit can help
yeah
thank you thank you so much I mean this
was such a motivating presentation for
us seeing the numbers and all
but I think it has been truly uh I mean
uh throughout the session we understood
every aspect and uh learned about the
different things and opportunities and
where all of us are heading because some
of us have no idea being a student and
uh like such presentations are of a
great great help to get that direction
and get that motivation to do something
which is going to be useful for all of
us thank you
thanks for inviting me I think we don't
have much time maybe we need to move to
the next talk right
we do have a couple of
okay please email me I'll I'll drop off
now
thank you so much
thank you thank you so much
okay so with that let us move on
we want today's Symposium so let me ask
why asking you a question have you ever
wondered how bioinformatics is used in
the field of industry and Academia what
are the similarities and differences
the satellite on this topic please thank
me in welcoming our next speaker Dr
prasanna kuti has a background in
genomics client-mile and interfind and
comes from extensive experience in
analyzing following generation sequence
data is tenure as scientists and
educator Dr prasanna is fueled by his
passion core analytics in biology
informatics and data kind
also reads enjoying reading jogging
meditation and gardening
and with that brief introduction please
join me in welcoming Dr koti to start
with message
thank you thank you very much for the
introduction thank you
so I'll just share my screen and
so I hope you can see my presentation
yes we can see your screen
yeah right so um yeah thank you very
much and yeah so um the topic is role of
bioinformatics and Academia versus
industry right so today I'm not going to
be speaking too much into the science of
bioinformatics but uh rather
uh I'll be uh speaking more into the
contribution of bioinformatics as a
domain in Academia versus industry right
so I had the experience of
you know being both in Industry as well
as in Academia I started my career in
uh industry then I moved to
um
Academia I finished like four to five
years there and then I came back to
Industry right so now I'm the associate
principal scientist in genotypic
Technologies private Limited in
Bangalore okay
so um
just the motivation right so we would
like to know what is bioinformatics
right so bioinformatics as a domain it's
a huge vastric domain I would say when
it's it's not only supporting a lot of
knowledge systems but it is also being
supported by a lot of technological
domains right so if you can see on the
right we have very important domains
that are supporting bioinformatics let's
say for example computer science right
so people are sitting and writing
softwares right just to you know make
sense of the data that is being
generated by bioinformatics and then
at the other end we have a lot of ID
infrastructure or you know people who
are involved in building just the the
resources to run the Big Data nature of
bioinformatics right so we need a lot of
ram we need a lot of storage space and
yeah nowadays I think people might have
also you know heard about this GPU
machines running a lot of processing
processes in parallel right so
so there is a lot of scope for you know
even the infrastructure here and um yeah
once we have a lot of information
uh there is this another domain the data
database management domain which is
trying to structure this data right so
it's putting all the information into a
specific you know structure where people
can you know query it you know for
useful information right so these are
some of the domains that are supporting
bioinformatics
the other side bioinformatics as a
domain
it's supporting many life science
domains right so for example it's you
know it's looking at agricultural data
it's looking at you know Health Science
data it's looking at you know structural
you know protein structural data
genomics
biochemistry biology and you know let's
say in mathematical Sciences it's
responsible for forwarding the science
in mathematics right so the demand from
bioinformatics is helping to develop new
algorithms with a lot of mathematics
so that is a kind of motivation right so
bioinformatics is a huge vast science
that is you know coming up and
in India bioinformatics is one of the
first areas of biotechnology let's say
for example you know biotechnology in
itself is a huge market right so for
example uh it was about 80 billion
dollars worth of Market in 2022 and it
is forecasted to grow to about 150
billion dollars by 2025 in India right
and it is also going to you know you
know increase our footprint in the world
biotechnology market so it's gonna
increase from four to five percent to
almost 19 percent by 2025 and yeah so
the market is just known to be growing
and growing right so it's a huge market
and um majority of the the biotechnology
Market is being contributed by uh
Pharmaceuticals as you might be knowing
that you know India is the
pharmaceutical you know pharmaceutical
House of the world right so you get or
you you are you know getting more and
more let's say on vaccinations right so
recently we had so much of vaccinations
that were you know produced in India
they were shocked I mean shipped to all
parts of the world right so
followed by uh Pharmaceuticals we have
Agriculture and so on right so what we
can understand is that biotechnology in
itself is a huge Market
in India and uh that you know keeping
all these things into consideration the
department of biotechnology I mean let's
say for example Department of
biotechnology during 1987 they
considered bioinformatics as one of the
thrust areas of biotechnology and uh you
know they
um put in a lot of support and you know
infrastructure was given for the
development of you know bioinformatics
resources in the in the country right so
for example two best examples are in
front of you one is the ibdc that is
Indian biological data center so it's a
single point access you know resource
location where you can you know put all
your data you can you know uh let's say
for example curate the data you can you
know quality control the data and you
can add the metadata for example you can
store the data for long times you can
share that data so it's it's kind of a
data archive which is related to all
domains of biology right let's say for
example agriculture livestock microbes
and humans right so that's one of the
best examples it's going on and it has a
lot of you know subsidiary web servers
which are giving you a lot of
information right so
it's one of the best examples and
another one was a manner initiative so
it was one of the the uh a comprehensive
initiatives to build uh or construct a
Human Atlas
one of the first of its kind in India
and see for example here you know all
kinds of data right so it might be data
it might be information all could be you
know put into this specific location
where you could you know include macro
level to micro level information right
so you could probably annotate them it
might be genomic information it might be
you know information from the
Publications
a lot of things right so you could
probably put in all the data with
respect to humans in this specific
resource right so once you have this
resource it's a huge
resource right so what you're doing is
you're also uh you know structuring this
information for people to understand it
you know when the when there is a lot of
information it can be very difficult for
us to understand so we are structuring
it in such a way that you know people
could understand it right so once you
have a lot of information what you're
doing is you are using machine learning
you know languages to just to find out
some Trends in the data right so you are
trying to find what are these Trends you
know do we have any Trend in this
specific disease do we have any specific
Trend in this you know heritability
related issues or whatever you know and
then finally uh one of a kind you know
where people who are being you know
being uh teach right so there was a lot
of extension work which was also being
you know taken on by this uh you know uh
man of human at last initiative so what
I would rather want to conclude from
this slide is that you know
bioinformatics in itself is a huge
Market let's say for example right now I
think it should be around 15 to 20
billion dollars but uh by the end of
this decade it could easily reach to
about 50 billion dollars
meaning that it's it's also going to
become a lucrative Market
and
this bioinformatics Market is going to
attract a lot of human resources that is
what I wanted to conclude from this
specific you know slide okay and then
coming to the the context of today right
so bioinformatics Academia versus
industry right so in Academia what are
we doing right so Academia is a place
where we focus on Research education
training and
extension over right so you do research
you do propagate what you are doing to a
lot of people and you're also publishing
a lot of papers right so for example my
informatics research can lead to some
important findings or even rules that
can be used by the industry so that is
the most important thing so a lot of
things can be
you know uh found out or can be you know
generated or constructed in Academia
which can be easily used by the industry
right so at the same time in Industry
bioinformatics applications are more
involved or you know more used to solve
the Practical problems right so the
Practical problems that are of immediate
requirement right so let it be you know
Health Science let it be you know
agriculture or even you know
you you can ask whatever kind of you
know biological field right so here
Innovation or research is designed for
the requirement of the industry right so
the immediate needs so Innovation or
research is only pointed towards the
immediate needs so we are not going to
forward the knowledge here we are always
sticking in the boundary here right so
so there are Industries which are
working on developing a lot of tools
they are going a bit outside the the
boundary but for most of the the
research in Industry they are always
trying to specifically solve it
immediate you know
and then um
understand some of the basic
accomplishments right so in Academia you
can see that one of the biggest
accomplishments was a Human Genome
Project you know it took a lot of time
it took a lot of money and you know once
the Human Genome Project was completed
we were obviously interested in you know
a lot of diseases right so we were
thinking at a point to you know you know
sequence individual genomes right so
what happened is that it opened the
floodgates right so you could see that
you know in Industry there were a lot of
sequencing you know machines that were
coming up which were giving us uh you
know a lot of data at a very less time
right so these newer generations of
sequencing
are you know forwarding the knowledge
right so forwarding the science at a
very best Pace right so now we have a
lot of data that is already there and
very few people to analyze this data
that is the most important thing right
so uh you know uh what we are thinking
right now is uh we want to uh sequence
uh humans you know at uh probably 100 or
even less than that so that is
the point where we are sitting right now
right so in Academia you know
individually many people are you know
interested in uh doing a specific task
maybe somebody is interested in
assembling the reads to the genome some
of them are interested in mapping the
reads to the the reference genome or you
know assembling the genome some of them
are trying to you know predict the
variance of them are trying to you know
annotate their variants so uh specific
research interests are being you know
chased and specific genomic tools are
being published by Academia right so a
lot of things are coming out of Academia
at the same time in Industry we are need
based approach right so what we can do
is we we combine probably the tools that
are being you know
uh discovered or you know constructed by
the Academia and we are making it a
workflow to to change or to find
solution to a specific
right so
basically we are we are need based you
know institutes right so we are only
showing you the problems at hand and we
are constructing workflows to you know
perform those charts right so for
example in our own
we have a tool called as a commander
which uh you know um removes I mean a
lot of hurdles right so for example you
don't have to be a programmer you don't
have to have knowledge in you know Linux
based systems it's a graphical user
interface you just have to point where
the input files are and you just have a
point where you want the output files to
be located and you click on the Run
button and it's gonna you know execute
the workflows so we have a lot of
workflows like you know wgs workflows or
genome sequencing workflows variant
analysis workflows you know meta
genomics workflows a lot of workflows
that are integrated into this specific
tool called Commander so what are we
trying to do in industry is you know
more
oriented towards problem solving which
are immediately required right so in
Academia it's it's like you know it you
can take some time and you can you know
increase or decrease the level of you
know uh
in the tool or you know the information
that you are trying to you know
accomplish to the larger audience okay
so
coming to working environment right so
working environment in Academia is much
more relaxed
so for example uh you might be working
on one to two projects you know spanning
over a defined period of time you know
so it's not that you know you'll be
super busy here but you have a defined
period of time where you need to uh
execute a project and you know you need
to send out a report yeah Publications
are always welcome during this process
right
whereas industry it's highly Dynamic
right so you are working working on
multiple projects and they are always
always time bound right so you're you're
looking at a specific you know you you
get the sample you get the sequencing
done you get the data and you have this
you know turnaround time so you need to
always stick to the specific turnaround
ions so it's highly Dynamic and you are
not really interested in publishing
papers here right so it's it's up to the
clients
um who wants to publish the data or you
know who wants to forward the signs but
for you you are just analyzing the data
and you're just reporting the data to
the clients okay so for example in
Academia the goal might be just to
assemble hundred genomes predict the
genes annotate the genes do some kind of
comparative genomics in about three
years right so the project might be
running for about
three years
whereas in industry
you might be working on the same 100
genomes you're assembling them you are
protecting the genes you are annotating
and you are doing comparative genomics
plus you're also doing some 20
transcriptomic analysis or even
metagenomic analysis in way less time
period compared to the Academia right so
I'm telling you in 30 days so this is
just the number but it can be less or a
little bit more than that right so
industry is always time bound so you are
analyzing and you are supposed to report
it within a specific time pound so that
is the most important thing in Industry
whereas in Academia you can be a little
bit relaxed and relaxed in the sense
you're also involved in teaching you're
also involved in you know extending the
the work in Academia
University
it doesn't mean that you know we were
next but we were involved in teaching we
were involved in taking this you know
research to uh audience we were trying
to collaborate and doing a lot of works
are also taking place at Academy
and coming to funding right so in
Academia
funding is provided by government
agencies right so uh you are writing a
lot of uh you know proposals uh it might
be to uh Central institutes it might be
to State institutes or even the uh the
ngos right so we are constantly on the
edge of the seed to write the proposals
and get the funding here right so as an
industry company itself or investors are
putting the money right so it's not that
you know too tough in in Industry to get
some funding right so
in Academia researchers needs to
constantly apply for our grants that's
what I told you know you need to be on
the edge of the series
to constantly look for you know grants
right so you need to write the grants
you need to get the money just to keep
the lag or you know whatever resources
running right so
industry there is a fairly constant
supply of funds right so there's a lot
of money which is coming from the uh the
tasks that are being done by the
industry and you know a fairly constant
supply of wants to support the resources
right
in Academia
benefits can be
Consolidated right so it means that you
know you have a fixed salary and apart
from that you're not getting any much
more whereas in Industry benefits can be
variable right so you do um you know get
bonuses right so depending on the work
done or probably uh you know if you can
contribute a little bit more in getting
the profits you are going to be
providing the bonuses in
industry so the benefits can be variable
right so
and then um
going to the Job Hierarchy right so for
example in Academia you can always start
from a PhD right so nowadays uh phds are
also being funded by the institutes and
you get uh you get very little
let's say for example support and you
also get some you know contingency for
performing some kind of research every
year and once you have this PhD done you
can go into the postdoctoral research
where you are a little bit more
experienced you are capable of handling
your own you know experiments design
your own experiments you you can write
you know with
proposals yourself and help your you
know immediate senior right so for
example you might be a assistant
professor so you can come you know for
example sit with assistant professors
and write the proposals for you know
submitting to the institutes right once
you have done with the assistant
postdoctoral researchers you go into
this assistant professors so here people
are you know doing research as well as
teaching right so you are not only doing
research you're also teaching to a lot
of people I mean a lot of students and
you're also constantly writing the the
proposals right so to get the funding
and once you are done with also
assistant you are going to the associate
professor so you are basically the the
uh the responsibility is increasing
right so you still have a lot of you
know people to delegate your job but
yeah so the number of responsibilities
will be increasing right as an associate
professor and finally um Professor who
is probably the kind of a head of a
department you know we can probably be
looking into uh people's jobs he's also
teaching he's also looking at peoples
who are writing proposals are they you
know getting accepted
all kinds of roles is being done by
professors right so this is with respect
to Academia when you come to Industry
yeah so for example in bioinformatics
let's say for example in a service based
industry right so you can probably start
with a junior scientific analyst
and um after a certain period of time
you can become senior I mean scientific
analyst and yeah similarly you can
become a bioinformatics scientist right
so here all these three people right so
junior senior and bioinformatics
scientists are more or less sitting and
you know executing the workflows right
so they are you know following certain
protocols they are trying to you know
generate the
yeah analyze the data and generate the
reports
and when it comes to bioinformatics team
leaders
um they are the ones who are you know
planning the workflows right so they are
you know
sitting and you know preparing a new
workflows they are looking into you know
whether there are new tools which are
being released are they you know giving
us more information compared to the old
tools so they are constantly Reviving
the workforce right so team leaders are
sitting and you know looking at the
workflows and
um finally we have the bioinformatic
group leader who is looking at every
aspect of all the people belonging right
so being sitting with you know team
leaders he's you know
uh removing the workflows you know the
ease once the the workflow is fixed is
probably sitting and training all the
people in the team so these are some of
the the things that you know
bioinformatics group leaders uh you know
does and yeah similarly
um you know there is uh an increase from
the beginning position to the last
position there is always an increase in
the amount of money that you are going
to be getting here right so it can be
Academia or industry Okay so
irrespective of Academy or industry
right so if you are joining uh um let's
say for example a lab in in Academia or
uh industry you know
some of the basic requirements that we
need is at least a master's degree in
bioinformatics right so it's a
prerequisite requirement and we always
look for a basic biostatistics knowledge
and uh yeah so
um we also look for people who can uh do
some kind of coding let's say for
example uh Python and R can be very
beneficial right so people with
knowledge of python and have can be
can be very beneficial for the candidate
itself and yeah so since um
bioinformatics in itself is dealing with
data and structured information so we
have the pieces of data which are
scattered around we put all this data
together make it a nice information for
this we need a lot of visualizations
right so when your visualization between
graph so summaries of visualization and
graph summaries can be a very good
value addition right so people who can
you know create some very nice measures
yeah of course you know if you know r or
you know even python there are a lot of
packages a lot of you know libraries
that can be used to create some very
interesting you know graphs and
yeah images so
visualization and graphical summaries
can be a good value addition okay so um
I think with this uh I would probably uh
give you uh some kind of a
recommendation uh see for example we
have uh you know charted out you know
papers that are already there if you
guys are interested you know please um
you know take a snap at this slide 10
simple rules for landing on the right
job after your PhD is right so 10 Simple
Rules who are approaching a new job
10 simple rules for getting ahead as
computational biologist and Academia
and finally 10 simple rules for choosing
the industry and economy okay so these
are some of the recommendations that I
would highly recommend you to
have a look you know for
probably taking the right direction okay
so with this I have probably
um end my talk
and yeah thank you very much
thank you so much
investigation so we do have couple of
queries that I wish to ask you so let me
quickly share my screen
all right so up first um the query that
the participle has shared is can you
tell us about the role of machine
learning in bioinformatics how they are
being used in Industrial Research versus
a premium
yeah I'm in machine learning in
bioinformatics yeah of course yeah so
for example you know we have a Dominion
by informatics called as natural
language processing where we are looking
at you know tons of Publications that
are already there in the data level
right so we are looking at specifically
Gene names so these genomes may be
associated with a certain phenotype it
might be you know variations in this
Gene which might be leading to a
specific disease it might be cancer it
might be Alzheimer's it might be
whatever it might be so there are
certain relationships that are already
present in these Publications right so
using natural language processing and a
lot of machine learning you know
algorithms they are already trying to
build these kinds of models which can go
into the database and it can bring all
these relationships on the table right
with a certain level of accuracy right
so it's always percentage so let's say
70 accurate or 80 accurate so machine
learning models can always be
accuracy
whereas uh um yeah I mean in industry
yeah of course machine learning is used
in large uh you know let's say for
example
uh you know you you are um
looking at lot of variations in cancer
and you are trying to just find a
relationship between a certain snip to a
certain cancer so this can only be done
by you know machine learning which
algorithm right so
you can write a script which can take
ages to complete but you know machine
learning algorithms can do this thing
for I mean within a
lesser time that is what is being done
right so industry and Academia so
exactly so Academia we are building the
algorithms in Industry we are using the
same algorithm to find you know new
relationships
right yeah
and the next question is
um How Can An undergraduate student
prepare themselves for a career in
buying marriage in Industrial Research
yeah I mean that's a it's a very good
question right so
first thing is that you know start early
right so start preparing early right so
you need to uh yeah so what I can say
about bioinformatics is that you need to
have a little bit of knowledge in
mathematics and statistics so it's it's
a preliminary I mean prerequisite that
we need to learn
[Music]
you can probably you know initially you
can start looking at some uh you know
online courses right
so from undergraduate you can easily go
into Masters in bioinformatics but if
you are at the undergraduate level you
can already start you know there are a
lot of you know databases there are embl
is offering a lot of free courses okay
so just the free courses embl let's go
into that have a look at the the uh you
know
let's say subject headings
take something which is interesting and
you know you can build upon that right
and it might be you know genomics it
might be building algorithms it might be
you know proteomics I mean I mean by
informatics in itself is a vast domain
right so it's dealing with all kinds of
biological knowledge right so it might
be protein structure analysis so
find your interest start early that is
what I want to say
thank you so much
and there are a couple of questions but
one final question that I want to ask
you is how do collaborations between
Academia and Industry in bi-informatics
work and what are some benefits and
challenges to such collaboration
yeah so um in Academia right so for
example if you are an expert by
informatician so you are kind of a loner
right so you have a lot of biologists
who are you know revolving around you
and you are kind of you know trying to
understand what a biologist wants to do
right and then uh the challenge is that
you know uh it's more monotonous in in
Academia right so you are kind of you
know looking into let's say a whole
genome sequence assembly right so you
doing doing this for a lot I mean a lot
of times right so you become expert in
all genome assembly whereas in industry
it's not the case right so you are
handling multiple projects you might be
doing assembly you might be doing
reference based where you're calling you
might be doing you know transcriptomics
similarly your collaborations is also so
Dynamic right so your your people are
asking for you to do some assembly
process
people are asking you to find some
variations so
in Industry I would say it's a much more
Dynamic right so collaborations can be
much more Dynamic and the the thing is
that in the industry you learn a lot
more compared to academics right so
academics you have more monotonous your
more specialist into one specific domain
or something like that
little time limitation I'll be emailing
them to you okay sure
with that
and with that let us move on to the next
part of today's session
um which is a practically handful
session that focuses on into the omics
world understanding omics data
and to start with the session we'll be
passing on the stage to Mr sonalika Ray
who have completed a mastiff in buying
married from Punjab University her
entrance life is an area of performance
research data assigned computer-aid
product Discovery and Pharma future
presently she is also responsible for
developing the curriculum of the
training programs and oversees the
participants progress while working
together on their research Quest so with
that being from the introduction to the
stage tutorial
foreign
so today I wanted to discuss about
different omics fields which includes
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
first we'll discuss about the fields
what it is all about and then what
different types of analysis can we
perform on it and then we'll do some
Hands-On where we'll extract some data
from the public repositories and then
run some pipelines on the day bioinfo
platform to see what type of results we
get and how we can interpret the results
but before we do that I would just take
you through some of the videos so that
we can learn more about the fields and
before starting with omics
let's discuss about bioinformatics
because some of you were also new to the
field bioinformatics so we'll first
discuss about what the field
bioinformatics is all about and then
dive into genomics transcriptomics and
Metal genomics so at omics logic we
follow a hybrid approach where we tend
to share some session recordings that
the participants can watch because we
understand that the participants are
preoccupied with their already going
tasks in hand if they are professors or
researchers or students so I just wanted
to give you a taste of what these
pre-recorded sessions look like that you
can watch though what I'm going to show
you today is just a very brief overview
of what this session could look like
that's just a very brief overview of
five to ten minutes about the field
though the training session it's um
around an hour or so so let's get
started we'll begin with the fee in
bioinformatics and then we look at some
resources that we can leverage on the
Onyx logic learn portrait to learn about
the field bioinformatics and then we'll
take up the honestly
can you just confirm if uh the voice is
audible or not from the video I'll just
start the video let me know in the chat
please okay thank you
biological data it's an online community
for top researchers and Professionals in
bioinformatics to supply universities
and other organizations with online
courses certifications and practical
case studies in biomedical data analysis
spanning the Journey of a novice to
develop skills and stand out from the
crowd we provide access to asynchronous
resources specialized training
mentorship and Big Data infrastructure
as a result students learn about
meaningful application of computational
skills to relevant data sets in their
chosen domain in this way we address the
pressing challenge that slows down the
effective analysis of large data sets
produced in research and biotechnology
industry
we address the topic of software
complexity the need for big data
processing power access to tested
methods by experts in the field exposure
to real world challenges and training
for faculty to stay updated even beyond
their area of expertise
to do so we first address the topic of
materials for courses that are usually
developed in-house taught sporadically
in a rarely updated
so we opened up the omics logic portal
to a dynamic community that will
introduce new materials and keep them up
to date with the newest technology all
the time
secondly these courses have to be
organized and because the challenge is
to combine several different topics
together the flow and transitions
between subjects has to be improved this
is addressed at omic's logic through
introductory materials being woven
throughout the courses
finally let's talk about systematization
these topics are extremely complex so
there's a need to know that someone is
stuck and needs help or allow another
one to run forward and so to address
this omixlogic uses standardized modules
and interactive sessions that begin with
mastering terminology and Concepts to
then implementing these concepts with
real data sets in a case study approach
so the portal brings Community Driven
experience to anyone to learn how to
analyze biological data build up their
profile to be ready for research
industry or entrepreneurship using
biotechnology and Big Data the features
are designed to make this process
seamless for individual users a class or
a whole Institution
the Onyx logic portal gives students
options for analyzing any data
codependent or independent paths these
data sets and Associated Publications
can be used in several ways you can
learn bioinformatics without any coding
at all for that in each project we
explain the analysis pipelines on the
user-friendly t-buy info platform for
Big Data analysis you can also learn the
scripts behind many of the steps
learning to Wrangle clean visualize and
analyze data in popular languages like R
and python in order to create your own
analyzes
finally you can hear about the projects
and the research applications in our
Mentor guided programs where experts
share their experience and support
research projects developed by you
so this is not just a portal with online
courses or moocs
this is a community where you can see
achievements progress certification and
explore projects developed by students
having access to Big Data analysis tools
with interactive outputs in a logical
flow helps students master and
understand complex bioinformatics
processes designed by experts and
produce outputs that are both intuitive
and biologically interpretable
in addition students can learn practice
solve computational problems and
discover opportunities as they go
through intuitive learning using or
coding console with predefined answers
that can be obtained by manipulating the
code having expert designed training
opportunities students can design job
ready skills and find job opportunities
in the Academia industry as an intern or
even by finding a short-term project
this approach allows any student to
develop a profile that stands out
Onyx logic was designed in collaboration
with top universities and as a result we
have a team of experts that are guiding
the development of the necessary
resources managed by a team that is
distributed across several locations
like North America India and Africa
in each one of these locations we have
established Partnerships with top
institutions that represent community
colleges universities
high schools and organizations that
support biomedical research
all right so that was about the theme
bioinformatics and how can the portal be
helpful to you to learn those skills
there so as you all know the speed is an
interesting interdisciplinary field that
combines biology computer science maths
and statistics to develop and also apply
the tools and the algorithms to process
analyze and interpret biological data
so the goal of bioinformatics is to
extract the useful information and the
knowledge from the massive amount of
biological data that is generated
through different High throughput
experimental Technologies now to get
started with this understanding of
bioinformatics the best course that you
can pick up is the introduction to
bioinformatics so all you need to do is
just go to the courses Tab and type here
bioinformatics or an introduction to
bioinformatics this is the first course
that I want to showcase to you and the
second one is a course that we have
designed with the RN that is for
biomolecular data analysis
yeah so in the first course that is
Introduction to bioinformatics this
course includes lessons several
different lessons in all of the courses
that I'll show you today in every course
you have different lessons different
number of lessons in which you have a
mix of Concepts in the form of texts
videos and also we have Linked UP
important research Publications that you
can refer to and a mix of assignments
and quizzes to ensure that you have gone
through the concepts well and understand
them to proceed ahead so in this first
lesson you will you would be introduced
to Big Data what are the opportunities
and limitations of working with big data
what is data driven Discovery and also a
real life example in healthcare followed
by awkwards
and in the second lesson you will learn
about the role of bioinformatics in
healthcare so we all know that
bioinformatics is an emerging Fields
because of the exponential growth of the
data in these recent years and the
development of these Technologies High
throughput experimental Technologies has
enabled the scientists to generate vast
amounts of data and really short amount
of time so it becomes very important for
us to understand how we can explore this
data and what the role of bioinformatics
could be in healthcare so this specific
lesson would help you understand the
power of personalized Health Care
through uh bioinformatics tools and then
learn more about molecular Diagnostics
and also the treatment development so
the understanding that you get through
exploring the different types of data
how you can use that data to design a
better therapeutic approach
and in the third lesson you will learn
about translational bioinformatics
so with an understanding of
bioinformatics that plays a very
critical role in many areas of
biological research which includes
genomics proteomics metabolomics and
also systems biology it is very
important to understand how the tools
could be used to analyze DNA sequences
identify genes and predict their
functions it also it could also be used
to compare different genomes and then
identify genetic variations and then
contribute to disease susceptibility or
drug resistance the applications are
diverse and also a lot to mention so in
this specific lesson you will learn
about the role of bioinformatics and
environmental science and Agriculture
and in several other areas
so that was about how you can get
started with an introduction to the
field bioinformatics with that I wanted
to know how many of you are from a
different field than bioinformatics it
could be biotechnology microbiology or
biochemistry and how many of you are
really from the field of bioinformatics
if you are from a different Queen and
you want to get started and if you have
any questions please feel free to put in
the chat you can also unmute yourself
let's try to make this session more
interactive so that we can address your
questions and guide you how you can get
started with the learning of
bioinformatics
I'm waiting for for answers you can put
in the chat or maybe animate yourself
you can also raise your account
oh are the messages going directly to
the co-host
yes I can see one raised hand hi Michael
you can unmute yourself uh regarding uh
the participants have the yeah they have
the permission
yes hello yes hello oh I mean
microbiology graduates from covenants
University in Nigeria so I'm looking
into getting a graduate degree in
bioinformatics and uh I have some
programming experience in different
program languages and I feel I'll be
able to kind of explore this trade
variable but my question is most of the
application portal I've checked I think
uh bioinformatics are requirements are
mainly requires uh I think a couple of
degree in uh a background in computer
science and maybe mathematics or
something like that so I'm not sure if I
could go into that field because of some
requirements uh I can meet
oh
yes so you basically want to know about
uh the different types of things that
are important for you to have the
knowledge about to proceed ahead right
in your career
yep
yes all right so uh as uh Dr prasanna
also mentioned in the previous session
that uh to advance in the field of
bioinformatics it's very important for
you to have the knowledge about uh
different tools about of Bio informatics
statistical methodologies and also a
programming language like either r or
python so I would showcase you some
resources that you can go through and
also when you say data science it
includes learning about machine learning
how machine learning could be used where
you have different types of analysis and
supervisor supervised analysis that you
can use for exploring data correct so as
you come from a non-bioinformatics field
you can definitely get started with the
first course introduction to
bioinformatics and then pick up one of
the rna-c
um things to learn the analysis it could
be genomics or it could be
transcriptomics or it could be
metagenomic so it would be good if you
have an expertise in one of these omics
uh themes and right it's not important
to have an expertise in all of the omic
streams analysis it's good to have the
expertise of one of the fields as well
and then I think you would be a very
um good package a power packed resource
for the companies where you proceed
ahead with
all right thanks so much
yes so uh for Alice I will take you
through uh the programming in data
science course that you can go through
one of the questions that I uh hear a
lot from a different participants uh
either students bachelor's Masters or
also college students and sometimes
Pages Scholars is that when they have to
begin with data science or data
analytics or let's say programming
languages like R in Python you will get
various resources to learn about the
basic Computing languages like what are
data structures or what are classes
functions and like the basic Computing
language uh path that the person should
know about what a class is functions in
different libraries and packages but
when it comes to bioinformatics there
are some specific sets of libraries and
packages that are very required for you
to know about there are specific
statistical tests for different types of
analysis that you should know about and
uh your understanding gets limited to
these different resources because you
don't really know what resources you can
leverage so right after bioinformatics
I'll just show you some RN python
coursework for biomedical data research
RN python specific for biomedical data
research that you can get your hands on
all right so Alice uh just uh hold on
and uh I'll just take you through these
resources that you can learn from
so the second course that I wanted to
take you through uh along with
introduction to bioinformatics is the
biomedical biomolecular data analysis
course where we have put together four
different modules these four different
modules are specifically Hands-On based
modules where we are trying to make you
understand how you can use what are the
different types of databases
repositories first of all so there are
uh two different types of databases
primary or secondary databases what type
of information is stored there how you
can extract that how you can work with
it and then you have a lot of exercises
as well that you have to practice and
answer to to proceed ahead so going
through these four modules will really
help you get a good understanding of the
field by informatics and at least give
you a good start
you can go ahead if you don't have the
link say let's say uh sometime later you
want to explore these courses it's very
easy to just go to the courses Tab and
type in the search to get this specific
course
okay so that was about introduction to
bioinformatics and uh the biomolecular
data analysis course that I showed you
now there are many people who get
introduced to the field bioinformatics
and also know about the different home
experience real genomics transcriptomics
proteomics metal genomics in our
academics we are mostly introduced to
the fields genomics and proteomics uh
the degrees I have heard about in gone
through the syllabus of I've seen
genomics and proteomics integrated there
but what lacks is that you definitely
get a good conceptual understanding of
genomics and proteinomics but when it
comes to practical Hands-On like how you
have to deal with genomic data what type
of genome like what the genomic data
looks like and then how do you have to
clean the data or process or pre-process
the data and then analyze different
types of possible analysis and then
interpret the results that specific
understanding is missing you would be
taught about different tools or
databases that hey you have different
fields that you can explore data from it
how do we do that that understanding is
missing and to fill that Gap I want to
take you through this introductory
coursework where you can get an
understanding of what these different
omics uh field includes
and when I uh say omics I'm collectively
referring to genomics transcriptomics
and metagenomics so don't get confused
now this is the first thing to get
started on how different types of data
looks like for all these different Army
screens you can go through bytes and
molecules also this course will help you
understand which specific field do you
want to focus on
so one of the questions is that you know
about these different fields but you're
confused which field you want to
specialize in so you can go through
bytes and molecules where you will learn
about these different types of fields
obviously not an advanced learning or an
in-depth knowledge but
an introduction to an extent that you
are able to understand which field you
would like to specialize in all right so
you have these introductory lessons on
different omics fields that is one thing
that you that you can go through and
learn from and uh the second set of
lessons that you'll find in bytes and
molecules include research
specialization tracks now what are these
research specialization tracks so there
are different research areas in which
you can apply the skill set or the
knowledge that you gain for a specific
type of data analysis
now these resource specialization tracks
could be uh infectious diseases or
oncology or Precision medicine or space
omics or metabolic disorders right so
there are different tracks where you can
explore these different types of data
and carry out your research now what are
these tracks and what type of research
is possible uh we have also added some
introductory lessons for you to
understand about these different
specialization tracks like Precision
medicine or infectious diseases a space
omics is one of the most emerging Fields
so you can go through and explore that
all right and uh for those who are new
to the field bioinformatics or new to
the field of computing languages like R
and python you can again go through the
lessons here to just get an
understanding of what both of these
Computing languages look like and one uh
suggestion for those who are uh newbies
pick one language at a time don't try to
gain expertise in RN python
simultaneously because many of you do
that and then you face some problems so
it's better to pick up one language get
an expertise in one language first and
then take up the other one
all right so now we discussed about uh
bioinformatics and how you can go
through these different omics fields and
research specialization tracks and pick
the one that you want to work on now let
us try to understand what the faint
genomics is all about and what type of
analysis uh could be done in this week
welcome back to Amex logic where we
simplify bioinformatics and help make
Onyx data analysis logical
in this short video we will discuss
genomics what is genomic data how is it
organized analyzed and interpreted to be
such a powerful resource in the hands of
clinicians researchers and entrepreneurs
that are reading the DNA code to battle
cancer fight off infectious diseases and
even solve crimes let's start by
reviewing some of the fundamentals of
genomics
just like a book the DNA code is
organized letters form sentences
sentences form paragraphs paragraphs are
organized into chapters knowing how to
read this code can help us decipher the
full story about who we are and look
into our history understanding how we
are connected to other living things
around us what makes us who we are and
how can we explain some of the
differences as well as diseases that we
experience DNA contains instructions for
various functions a cell must perform to
grow and maintain life therefore DNA
contains both actively needed recipes
and all kinds of other instructions that
need to be stored but not necessarily
used all the time today there are
several competing human gene databases
with many thousands of differences among
them and although the number of protein
coding genes has gradually converged the
number of other Gene types has excluded
the Onyx Technologies are used to
explore the roles relationships and
actions of the various types of
molecules that make up the cell of an
organisms together these are referred to
as systems biology
many types of Onyx data can be generated
using various Technologies one of them
is called Next Generation sequencing or
high throughput sequencing the data from
high throughput sequencing can be used
to characterize detailed genomic
variants epigenomic regulation as well
as Gene and isoform expression
in this part we are going to be talking
about genomics genomics refers to the
structure function Evolution and the
sequence of DNA a specific type of
variation can lead to harmful results
for example a change in function that is
harmful this is called a mutation most
single nucleotide changes are found
outside of the coding regions so these
are non-coding variants
and have no impact on the biological
function of a protein or called Silent
though they may affect gene expression
or splicing however variants found
within the coding region May code for
functional changes in amino acid
structure called Miss sense or predict
premature protein truncation nonsense
and thus may have a possible direct
association with disease one example of
a non-synonymous mutation that is
associated with a phenotype change but
not disease is a mutation in the fgfs
gene that causes extremely long hair
eyebrows and eyelashes in people
depending on the type of sequencing
method fastq files can be quite large
sometimes over several gigabytes in size
per file to analyze such raw data many
different tools for genomic data
analysis are used these include sequence
alignment of reads and full sequences
analysis of relationships between
sequences and their evolutionary
Divergence measurement of gene
expression relationships between
sequences and structures as well as
somatic and germline variant calling
methods the t-bound info is an example
of a big data platform developed for
analysis and integration of such data it
can be used to perform all of these
analyzes and many others using an
intuitive and user-friendly interface
one of the major objectives of genomics
is linked to sequence alignment sequence
alignment can refer to two types of
alignment to learn more about these
analysis methods and their applications
in various project examples you can
complete the genomics course Series this
series will include a more expanded
overview of key Concepts principles and
examples of genomic data analysis
all right so that was about the field
genomics a very brief overview of what
the field is all about
now I would like to show you the course
on genomics that we take you through uh
the Intensive uh training program and
also the T bio info platform where we
would perform different types of areas
of analysis and we will try to learn
what type of analysis is possible okay
so we'll now type in the search bar
genomics and when we do that we would
get this hit of course three genomics
and there are several lessons
now what is the series of these lessons
like what will you learn in them so the
first thing is that uh you need to
understand is what are the different
types of platforms Technologies and
methodologies that could be used to
sequence genomic data all right and then
how you can extract the data from public
repositories if you are you are a
researcher who has the data mint
generated in your own lab then you
obviously have the access to the data
but if you are one of those who want to
learn what type of uh data is available
and what type of analysis would be
possible then there are several
different repositories that you can
refer to one of them is by project
so you go to buy a project ncbi bio
project where you can type in about a
particular type of condition that you
are interested to explore so let me
write breast cancer and tp50s me Gene
now we have a case study on the portal
where we have tried to understand what
other different types
also mutations that are present in the
tp53 gene that cause breast cancer and
that could be pathogenic or harmful so
when you look at these specific variants
or that could be present in a gene for
causing the disease
the next step after that is once you
have the variance in hand you want to
understand if they are pathogenic benign
harmful harmless so we'll get to that in
just
um through the Hands-On in just a minute
all right so apps is written a specific
query in the search bar and I get
specific hits that I could go through
and then see what type of form analysis
I would like to do so just opening up
the first head just for an idea if I do
that what I can see here is about the
specific data that is available
and how was it collected what groups
does it have I can click on the total
SRA experiments here we have 355 samples
and you will get the information about
each one of these samples here again all
right now if you click on one of these
samples you'll then know uh what the
sample information is all about there is
a problem with my uh browser I'll open
this in Microsoft Edge so that it is
cleared to you
okay now when you open this you can
learn more about the specific type of
sample that you have clicked on you will
get to know about uh the sample source
and how where through which specific
study was it submitted and then you get
to know if it was single and or parent
and then if you want to download the
fastq files or the faster files directly
you can simply click on the sample and
then get the access to the faster or the
password files and also look at the read
left all right so
now going back to
Chrome okay so that was about how you
can look at a specific type of sample
now the best thing about the server is
on the server you have these different
areas of analysis
transcriptomics genomics metagenomics
single cell and then uh you also have
epigenomics here and you can also
perform machine learning analysis now
when you want to process a genomic data
analysis pipeline all you need to do is
just put this session number list of the
SRA files that you have here and the
server will automatically pick up the
faster or the faster price of other
analysis all right so you go here you
just take up the Run info file and then
you can proceed with the pipeline I'll
just proceed one of the pipelines right
now to show you what type of uh results
do you get and first of all what a
pipeline looks like so this is a run
info file that you can download
from here and here you have the session
list and More in information about each
one of these release what is the release
date load dates Parts number of Paces
average length size all the details
about that specific read okay
so let's go to the T bioinfo platform
now there are two main pipelines for
genomic data analysis one is this
mutation variant calling pipeline where
you can
um
process your password files or run info
file and get a VCF file and annotate
that so this specific Vari variant
calling python will help you look at
specific variance and then annotate them
to understand it favor pathogenic or not
and the second type of pipeline that you
have is the phylogenetic analysis
pipeline where you can take the faster
files or the fastq files of different
organisms and try to understand the
evolutionary Trends maybe or carry out a
heart attack analysis or look at these
variants and try to understand which
organisms are close enough to evolution
all right so giving you uh a brief
overview of one of these pipelines I'll
take you through the breast cancer
mutation vegan calling pipeline I
clicked on the drop down button and then
I get these demo pipelines that I can
run
so uh you can go through these demo
pipelines if you have an account on the
server to get an account on the server
you just need to sign up on the omics
logic loan portal and within 24 hours
you will get your credentials for the
server as well you can log in and see uh
what type of pipelines are there and
then run these demo pipelines to explode
so in a pipeline you have these
different algorithms for different steps
of analysis in you can select these
different algorithm sets of different
algorithms to process something so
pipeline is where you just select these
different types of tools and you have
your raw file and you want to have your
results which you can analyze all right
so here I would be following these steps
where I start the pipeline I use an
algorithm as trimomatic so if you're
aware that in the sequence you process
adapters are generally added so to
remove those adapters we use trimomatic
and once we have the reach without
adapters I'll map those reads on the
reference genome using uh type 2
algorithm I also have other algorithm
options that I can use here I'll use
putai 2 and then I'll select
visualization
so this is basically to visualize the
results on J browse that is integrated
on the t-bioinfo platform and to call
the variants I have a lot of options
here I'll use new text too and then
click on annotation to annotate my
results and then simply in the pipeline
so you see how easy it is you just need
to upload the data and while uploading
the data you have to select what type of
data it is single enter pair and what
type of data you are uploading faster
file password file or Sam or band file
or a VCF file directly and then choose a
variant calling algorithm and then
finally annotate your results
so because of this time constraint I
have processor demo pipeline so that I
get the the results when I process the
pipeline but if you process your own
pipeline it would take few minutes to
few hours based on the file size and
obviously the sample numbers
now I'll click on J browse meanwhile it
opens let's see what the mapping stats
file has for us and you also get the VCR
file here that you can download and use
the CCI file for further analysis on
other tools and uh databases too now in
the mapping stats you'll get to know how
well the read aligned to the reference
render with a overall alignment rate
that is approximately mainly 99 percent
98 for one of them though two of them so
approximately 99 for all of the reads
and that is a good alignment rate
now if I go to J browse uh this is a
very interesting interface where I will
first of all select the reference genome
that I want to
map my reads on and I have these samples
here with different reads that I can map
on my reference journal and then I have
the GFF file that will help me annotate
the genomic regions
and the vcl file now I am interested in
tv53g so
I'll just type dp53
and you might get errors no worries you
can simply reload the session
right because this now I can see the
tp53 gene here and I get a list of
variants here that I can look at now if
I click on a specific variant I can see
I can get the information of the reading
too I'll close this
is taking a little bit time to load no
problem
so this is how the reads align on the
reference genome here in the reference
genome you have both the Strand
information
to three prime
and zoom out a bit
and if I click on a specific reading I
get to know the chromosome position and
what type of variation it is and uh
what the specific variant or what the
specific changes
right so that is about the way way in
calling Pipeline and now let's go back
to understand what the field
transcriptomics is all about
get solving in the cloud with the Google
Cloud free program as a new user you'll
get 300 in free credits for the first
the central dogma of molecular biology
dictates the flow of genetic information
from DNA to RNA and then to protein
in order to create proteins from these
genes RNA copies are made in the nucleus
and will be subsequently transported
into the cytosol where proteins are
built based on their sequences
in other words for protein coding genes
RNA is made from DNA during a process
called transcription and protein is made
from RMA during translation
there are different methods available
for detecting and quantifying gene
expression
reverse transcription PCR or RT PCR
amplifies DNA based on two primer
sequences framing the section of
Interest
since PCR amplifies DNA and not RNA RNA
is first converted back to DNA prior to
amplification
this is done via a process called
reverse transcription
in nature this process is carried out by
retroviruses in Northern blotting an RNA
sample is digested into fragments that
are separated by size in a gel using
electrophoresis
they are then transferred to a membrane
that can be probe to test for the
presence of a hypothesized RNA
transcript
microarrays like Northern blots a
hybridization based but in contrast to a
northern blot a microarray yields highly
detailed information about the
individual genes that have been
transcribed
these signals are then detected
Quantified and used to create a digital
image of the array
finally the digital image is used to
identify the transcribed genes
protein coding genes in genomic DNA
contain large stretches of non-coding
sequences called introns that are
spliced out of the RNA transcript by an
enzymatic complex called the spliceosome
before it is passed to the ribosome for
translation
the parts of the gene that remain in the
mature processed mRNA transcript are
called exons
these are the parts that encode the
amino acid sequences and will be used in
protein production
thank you
Next Generation sequencing technology
allows for advanced studies of gene
expression because it captures a
snapshot of the whole transcriptome
rather than a predetermined subset of
genes okay so we'll be starting in a
couple of minutes
do we have any specific research
interests within bioinformatics
Discovery methods
genomics
isn't the screen visible with the audio
uh right now the screen just stops
was it uh on Audible before
yes it is Audible
all right converted into C DNA that is
then sheared and placed into a flow cell
inside the flow cell cdna fragments are
Amplified using Bridge PCR amplification
and the flow cell is then inserted into
the sequencer
this machine uses image analysis to
capture each letter in the flow cell
fragments by analyzing visual patterns
and then converting them into a sequence
of letters
typically NGS reads are between 30 and
300 base pairs long they consist of a
series of letters t c g and a
recall that a typical rna-seq pipeline
includes three main steps pre-processing
mapping and quantification
pre-processing is needed to clean up our
data by removing the adapters trimming
some of the Reeds and removing the PCR
duplicates
this is important because PCR
amplification is not uniform across all
reads
then we take the cleaned up read
sequences to map them onto a reference
using a fasta file for sequences of the
genome and gtf files for annotation
based on the quality of annotation we
can use various strategies for mapping
once the step is complete we have to
quantify expression levels and give each
expressed element a number
okay so when we talk about a
transcriptomic uh study there are three
major steps that are involved in the
study the first one is pre-processing
and then you have mapping and then you
have quantification of the reads that
align to a specific region on the
reference genome and after that you
might want to look at the differentially
expressed chains by comparing the
expression levels between two groups of
interests and auditory let me know what
are your research
okay sorry
all right so
once you have the reads aligned on the
reference genome and then you quantify
the expression levels after that you can
perform differential expression to
understand uh what the differential
Express genes could look like and then
know in which Pathways these genes are
involved or which Pathways these genes
if there and which further other genes
uh are in the network
all right so I'll take you to the
transatomic section now I have 10
minutes with me so I'll take you to the
transcript promise section we will
quickly and maybe we can uh look at the
uh resources that you can refer to for
transfer plumbing and metagenomics so
here is the transcriptomics bulk RNA
seek section where you can pre-process
the reads and then get a Quantified gene
expression table on which you can
perform differential expression and
pathway annotation but if you have a
gene expression table on on which you
want to further carry out analysis or
differential expression and annotation
of the pathways you can further uh go
through or process this pipeline here on
differential expression
all right now let's click on the bulk
RNC section and here let's go to the PDX
project press cancel pipeline
so to get started I'll click on the
start button
and then Primo mate to trim off the
adapters PCR clean I'll use to remove
the duplicate reads that
um get added during the PCR process now
for mapping I have two options either to
map on a genome using these tools or map
on transcripts using these tools I'll
map it up on transcript using but I to D
which will map the reads on the
reference uh translate and then I'll
quantify the gene expression table I
have different options to that sailfish
HTC or RSM I use RSM and then I'll click
on B set 2 because I also want to look
at the set of differential expressed
genes and then end the pipeline so just
to give you a brief overview of what
this pipeline is all about what type of
data I uploaded here so I have uh two
different types of groups here two
different types of breast cancer one
group is uh estrogen receptor positive
type of breast cancer another one is
triple negative breast cancer samples
and I want to understand that what are
the differential Express genes and what
are their levels uh the genes with
abnormal expression levels when I
compare the expression levels of both of
these two groups of genes and then get a
list of these genes for this pipeline
just get to know what the differential
Express genes are now I get uh several
results here
in the visualization option I just
quickly open them up meanwhile it loads
I'll show you what a gene expression
table looks like
so I get here different uh files
expression ISO form expression genes now
one gene could
um
have different variants of genes one
gene could splice out through the
alternative splicing process and could
form different parts of genes that could
further Express right so if you want to
look at the isoforms that are formed
from one set of Gene then the expression
table that you get is the isoform
expression table and the gene expression
table would have the information of all
the exonic regions uh included in that
specific Gene now if I click on the
expression genes txt I'll get the gene
expression table here I'll I prefer to
open it up on Excel
you can take this time out and go
through some of the demo pipelines and
see what is also get and also explore
the results yourself
so in the gene expression table in the
First Column you have a list of Gene IDs
in Sample IDs you could also have Gene
symbols in some of the results and in
the First Column you have the samples so
in the first group you have the ER uh
positive samples that I mentioned and in
the second group you have the detonative
samples
okay now in this specific gene
expression table you get you get to know
if this is one of the samples then in
this sample what was the expression
level for these different genes and uh
in total we have
4244 genes here
4243 rather the First Column is the
information of the samples and from this
set of genes you want to exclude the
genes with the zero or less expression
levels and then want to just consider or
look at the genes with abnormal
expression levels so you get the result
that specific result from the algorithm
of D SEC that is used for differential
expression and if I open the
differential expression pipeline here
then pipeline result here then you can
see what information do we have inside
the call
now if I open the desert file here
I can see that now every Gene uh every
Gene ID has a gene symbol and the gene
name and also some statistical tests
were evaluated for the specific
um types of genes here all right so I
then have to put some filter on these
specific types of genes and then after
putting up that filter I'll get to know
what the differential Express genes look
like okay so I won't be overwhelming you
a lot right now
so let's quick quickly see what type of
results do we get in the dashboard and
the visualization here so we can look at
a volcano plot here and in the volcano
plot we again have the statistical test
what are the statistical tests why am I
so much interested to look at the lot to
full change and P existed value and how
can we infer or interpret which uh is
what with specific genius Difference
by filtering out
um
the genes through these different
statistical tests so this is a volcano
plot and here this is a gene egfr that
has 12 times more its expression level
than the normal expression level and is
differentially expressed here all right
so like this from the volcano plot you
can get to know which genes are
differentially expressed and a heat map
has a range here and shows you with
genes
um have what type of expression levels
and you have single uh volcano plot and
heat map so that you can explore a box
plot for the gene expression level of
all the samples and a box plot for
individual uh example expression here
and a multi-qc report that is actually
towards the very beginning in the
visualization where you can know what is
the read quality
of the reads in your samples okay so
that was about transcriptomics now very
quickly taking you through the resources
for transcriptomics and metagenomics I
think we uh have reached the time of the
next session so for metagenomics I'll
definitely share some resources with you
that you can go through uh with the
Symposium recording and for
transcriptomics you can explore course
fine on transcriptomics and then for
metagenomics you have a specific course
the conceptual understanding here
Remains the Same about the sequencing
Technologies what type of data you get
what date what are the different data
formats how do you um
clean this data how do you pre-process
the pipelines and then clean this data
and then how do you uh perform different
types of analysis what are the different
statistical tests that you can
um use and what these tests mean what
filters or what parameters to apply then
how do you interpret your result so in
that sequence you will learn everything
about a specific type of study and then
here comes the metagenomics coursework
and for those who want to get started
with r and python specifically for
biomedical data research you can type in
the chart R and python here you will
find two courses for rn2 for python the
first one is for high schoolers uh with
just a winner level sort of
understanding so I'll prefer you go
through uh the second courseworks if
you're not from high school and it would
help you understand
from the very Basics how to uh install R
and then how to import data what are the
different libraries and packages why are
they used what type of visualization or
uh what type of plots can you create box
plots heat Maps CG plots all kind of
plots different types of visualizations
that you that you can create to uh
extract out or visualize the patterns
from your data and then how to perform
dimensionality reduction visualize your
data using different techniques how to
perform different statistical tests and
some analysis differential expression or
clustering classification that is
unsupervised and supervised analysis and
in Python we have
more machine learning methods machine
learning lessons that you can explore so
that was about RN python resources that
you can explore and with that now as we
have reached the next session time I'll
just uh stop sharing and pass over this
stage to Sri gauri thank you everyone I
can see some uh questions in the chat I
will just take up those questions thank
you
thank you so much Malika for that
wonderful detection and with that we
have the next session that is focused on
medical genetics and genomics and I'm
sure that several participants are there
who are interested in the team and we'll
be finding this session so to start with
the session please join me in inviting
Miss Anuja Mishra she is a bank
specialist at Primark life sciences and
she will be discussing on the topic
overview of American College of medical
genetic and genomics
with that I would like to back on the
stage to miss Anuja
yes so thank you thank you for the
invitation I'm just sharing my screen
yes thanks yes
[Music]
so can you confirm if my slides are
visible
uh yes yes it is Whispering okay
[Music]
so first of all good evening everyone my
name is Anuja Mishra and I'm currently
working as bioinformatics specialist in
Prima slide Sciences so thanks for the
given chance and without wasting any
time we'll move ahead so as you see here
is our today's agenda where we'll be
looking overview of the hcmg
classification some terminologies and
nomenclature some classification rules
and one of the case study
so when we talk about acmg what exactly
acmg is
so in 2015 acmg that is American College
of medical genetics and genomics along
with the association for the molecular
pathology has published some guidelines
which has an important resource for
doing the radiant classification so
basically they have developed some
primary guidelines and after that there
have been multiple clarifications in the
interpretations and there are multiple
papers also published which says how do
we use these rules
so just to set a background in 2015 a
workbook setup which included clinical
lab directors some clinicians members of
acmg amp and cap members so they had a
goal to develop some terminology which
can be used for classifying the variance
so that all the labs can use those
terminology and Report the variance in a
particular and similar way
so for that what they did they have sent
service to around hundreds of sequencing
Laboratories and after multiple rounds
of discussion they arrived at some
points basically there were two major
points involved in that
so the first point was that the variant
should be reported in a five Tire
terminology system so that the terms
included for variant reporting will be a
pathogenic a likely pathogenic uncertain
significance that is viewers there will
be a likely B9 and B9 and in the first
go the work group will be only focusing
on the mendelian and mitochondrial
variants
so these were the basic two points which
was covered in that uh discussion and
collaborations
so when we talk about pathogenic and
likely pathogenic what these terms
actually mean so basically the
pathogenic variants are those variants
which are responsible for causing any
kind of disease and also there is an
emperor scientific researches and
evidences behind that which supports an
association between the disease and the
gene variant but in case of likely
pathogenic if you see the likely it
doesn't have any definite definition
involved but when we say likely
pathogenic that means it is giving
around 90 percent certainty that a
variant is probably causing a disease
but yet there is no sufficient evidences
available
when we say vus that is variant of
Uncertain significance that means there
are not enough evidences available so
that the variant can be classified as a
pathogenic or the B9 and that's why it
is falling into criteria of us and in
that cases we are not definite and we do
not know that the variant is responsible
for causing any particular disease or is
involved in any development of that
disease
as there is a likely pathogenic with 90
certainty there is a likely behind
whichever 90 certainty that the variant
is probably not responsible for causing
any disease but again there are not
enough evidences available so hence we
are giving it a term as a likely benign
and when we say benign that means it is
very definite that the variant is not
going to cause any disease and behind
that there are multiple researchers
literatures and evidences available
which are showing this kind of things
so when actually these rules are applied
for if you see there are multiple
different levels or ways to classify any
kind of variant and these rules are
basically designed for mendelian
diseases or maybe germline variants or
if you consider a variance with high
penetrance and also for small smbs and
the intels there are separately all
together different guidelines for cnbs
and large insertions and deletions so
these are the four which you need to
focus more on
with respect to nomenclature acmg has
also designed a kind of standardized
criterias or set of rules in the way a
variant can be reported and that is
maintained by this group which is called
as lgbs the full form is human genome
variation Society so one of the example
is if we are reporting any variant
either it is present in a genomic
location or at the you are reporting its
cdna change or if you are going to
report the protein change it should
contain some suffixes before that so
example if you are going to report a
genomic sequence it should start with g
dot if you are going to report a cdna
change it should be starting with C dot
if it is a protein change then it will
be a p Dot and for the mitochondrial
variance it should be m dot
so this is the link which I have given
for hgbs and this is one of the example
taken from that site so if you are
reporting this variant you see there is
a nomenclature being followed here g dot
123 a2g so g dot is representing the
genomic location 123 is the nucleotide
position a is the reference allele the
greater than symbol say that it is a
substitution and finally the G is the
substituted nucleotide
so you can go back to the link and you
can explore more on these things
then with respect to literature and
databases uh again acmg has also given
some important points when considering
the databases because you are going to
use these databases on literature
information for providing more evidences
and further classifying the variance in
that cases acmg says that whenever you
are going to use any kind of information
you have to use with some caution and
you have to take into consideration some
points in that case if you are using a
database then you have to understand
whether the database is having enough of
control set or not or if there was any
family related details involved or not
and also it is uh emphasizing on
understanding the points whether the
database is frequently updated or not if
you are going to use any database then
definitely you need to check what
version you are currently using and how
frequently the database is used and
updated in the background and also you
can see whether the database and the
information which you are going to use
contains some of the genomic information
or not are they giving any transcript
based information and the variant which
is already reported in the database have
they given any kind of quality stats
which they have used for assessing the
variant quality and what was the source
being used for the variant to be
reported into that databases so all
these points when you consider and then
you take a literature and databases
into your as an evidence for reporting
the variant then only you can say that
okay with uh higher confidence you can
report that variant
so in the paper if you go back to the
acmg they have given a list of some of
the databases that can be used for doing
the population based studies or maybe to
understand the gene Disease Association
or for performing The genome sequence
analysis and to download some of the
genomes so there is a big list which you
can go and explore this is just the name
of the databases and the functions which
is it is going to do
foreign
so basically it is a NIH funded resource
that defines the clinical relevance of
the genes and the variants uh so it is
mostly using the Precision medicine and
research purposes so they contains all
the original guidelines with some of the
adjustments and clarifications done
based on the original guidelines which
was which were given by the acmg and
they maintain it very nicely so that it
is very handy and very useful for all
the clinical laboratories to follow and
so that all the labs can use it in the
same way the rules were intended to use
so this is just an example in that cases
if you have a particular gene or if you
have a particular variant and if you
don't know what is your basically jinto
phenotype Association is going to be
then you can come back to this site and
if you type the gene name in that case
you can see whether the gene or the
protein or the variant is being curated
or reviewed by the group or not and what
kind of classification they are giving
what level of evidences they are
providing so considering all that
information you can consider while
reporting those variant in the clinical
sector
and also if you talk about cleansing
they have their own expert panels which
provide different kinds of ratings and
the quality for a quality for basically
uh linking those Gene related details or
variant related distance to a particular
phenotype
so talking about the four rules
uh if you again go back to the paper
2015 ACMC guidelines there is a big
table which is describing all the
classification rules and regulations so
in this rows you will be seeing the
variant evidence categories and the
columns contain the strength of the
evidences
so this is the table which I am talking
about so the if you see the
classification is based mainly on the
population data or maybe predictive data
there is some functional data involved
there is some inheritance data and this
all the data which is there all these
evidences are basically considered in
the direction from the B9 to pathogenic
and it is going from strong supporting
from moderate strong and in some cases
very strong so in cases when you are
going to do a variant classification you
have to come back to this table and then
you try to understand that in which
category your variant is falling and
accordingly you will be assigning those
criterias and those categories to your
variant
and if you see there is one more
information a second piece of
information along with that table which
is already shared in the paper and this
is how so these are the criteria which
is already defined and using those
criterias you can assign some of the
criterias and to get it at a big picture
level and to reach at the proper variant
classification you can use this
information uh and basically this will
be helping you for the reference
purposes also and if you actually see
how how do you go for it in that cases
they have given a very complete
guidelines and clear guidelines where it
will be saying that if you want to say a
variant is very very strong pathogenic
then in that cases you need to have a
very strong evidences plus you need to
have more than one strong evidences or
at least you need to have two moderate
evidences or either you can have one
moderate and one supporting or either
you can have greater than two supporting
evidences so if you have any one of
these things and combine things then you
will be saying okay the these are the
criterias which my variant is belonging
to and these are the numbers which I am
assigning to my variant and finally I am
going to classify my variant as a
pathogenic variant so similarly for
likely pathogenic for benign likely
benign they have given a complete list
of details and rules
So based on the population data there
are some rules given so first of the
rule is if any variant or we can say
minor relative frequencies from the
public databases having the human Z
sequencing data or maybe genome ad in
that cases if the frequency is greater
than 5 percent then it is considered as
a benign variant and then you can
classify it as a ba1
because if you see if the frequency is
greater than five percent then it is
going to be more common in the
population and it is not likely to cause
any diseases but again there is some
exceptions given but there is a very
short list which you can go and explore
in the next set if you see that the
population frequency is greater than
what was expected for a particular
disorder then we will be classifying it
in a criteria called as bs1 but here in
this cases you have to set your own
thresholds
on the other hand if you see that the
variant is completely absent from any
kind of population databases then there
is some kind of moderate evidences for
pathogenicity and then you can classify
it in a criteria called as pm2
but if you see a variant present only in
the case sample that means the affected
individuals and you do not find that
variant present in the controls then
there is a strong evidence that it is a
pathogenic variant and you will be
classifying it in a criteria called as
PS4
so the another set of rules is based on
the effect prediction where you will be
actually using the computational tools
and scores for understanding the impact
of that variant on the protein change so
if a computational algorithm says that
it is having some impact on the way if
it is having some impact on the protein
level or maybe some impact on the
causing the disease then you will be
classifying into the pathogenic criteria
that means it is having a deleterious
effect so in that cases you'll be seeing
it in a pp3 group but if the
computational algorithm says that it has
it doesn't have any impact then you will
be classifying it in a criteria called
as BP food
but if you have any kind of Silent
mutation or maybe synonymous mutations
which aren't predicted to have any kind
of splice side effects or impacts in
that cases it will be a completely
benign variant because there is no
evidence of the pathogenicity that's why
you will be classifying intimate
criteria called as bp7
so these are some basic things but if
you go at the higher rate then you can
use the moderative senses are strong or
very strong evidences based on what kind
of things you are seeing example if you
have any uh say missions mutation
present at some position where other
mutation is known to have a pathogenic
effect in that case is taking that into
consideration you will be assigning it
into a group of pm5 which is the
moderate evidence for pathogenicity
and if you have any protein which is
having a lens changing effect or maybe
there is a frame shift mutation either a
in-frame insertion or an in-frame
deletion or either there is a stop
mutation which is not leading to a null
effect or that means it is not going to
be a null variant in that case you will
be seeing it as a PM for evidences and
you will be putting into criteria of pm4
again if the if you have a different
nucleotide change but the amino acid
change is similar where some pathogenic
effect is already known that will be a
strongest level for giving the PS1
criteria and a very strong level will be
where you have a loss of function and
the mechanism of disease is known in
that cases you will be saying PV S1 that
is very strong evidences
again uh whenever you are considering
any kind of classification you need to
be uh very careful because there are
always a pitfalls and especially when
you are going to assign a criteria for
the pathogenicity and when you are going
to use any friendship mutation or you
are dealing with any kind of stop gain
mutation then you have to be double sure
that whatever you are giving is highly
accurate because a gene can have a
multiple isoforms present right so in
that cases if you see that this is just
an example you consider if any kind of
mutation is happening in this Exon and
if this Gene is having multiple isoforms
then all the isoforms are going to get
affected but if any mutation is
happening in this alternatively sliced
isoform this alternatively spiced Exon
then only one of the two product is
getting affected so you cannot assign a
pathogenic case until you are very sure
that it is going to have a very strong
effect on the biological system so this
kind of thing you need to consider and
take it uh keep it in your mind when you
are giving any pathogenicity effect for
the variant
foreign
set of rules based on the functional
studies so if you have sequenced any
patient samples and if you find any
novel mutations then this rule is not
going to be applicable however if you
look at previously reported or studied
variant where there might be some
functional studies being already done
then you can use this kind of criterias
so the basic rules will be to identify a
very good functional study and when I
say good functional study what do I mean
you have to see whether the functional
study was done using how many types of
acids because there should be at least a
greater than one way for assessing the
function also when you are considering
any study there should be positive and
negative controls also present for doing
the validation so that you have a higher
rate and higher level of confidence when
you are going to report anything
so if that considering the previously
done functional studies if you consider
that and if they say that okay it has a
deleterious effect then it will be
getting categorized into a PS3 domain
and if not then it will be a bs3
and there are actually very few
computational rules or algorithms which
says about the pathogenicity effect
because if you know a gene which can
tolerate the benign mutations that means
it has a very low rate of benign
mutations but have a multiple pathogenic
mutations present in the gene then it
will be a part of pp2 Criterium but if
you know there is a some Gene in which
there are some mutational hotspot
presence but there is no tolerance at
all for a benign mutation in that case
is water will be classifying it you will
be saying it is a PM one criteria
again there are some cohorts based on
the inheritance pattern so in
inheritance they consider the proband
they consider the maternal and paternal
samples so proband is basically the
first affected member in the family and
if you happen to see any kind of Deno
mutations then it can be classified into
a PS3 or pm6 depending upon the
confirmation of the paternity or
maternity samples and if it it is in the
case of recessive disorder and it is
present in the trance with any kind of
pathogenic variant then you will be
classifying it into a pm3 criteria
and if you see a variant present in
either CIS or trans having a dominant or
a pathogenic variant then it will be a
classified into a bp2 criteria
and if it is present in some alternate
causes then it will be a part of bp5
criteria
and again if you have a more than one
family members in your study and if you
are able to establish some kind of you
know correlation or co-segregation with
that disease and the affected persons in
that cases you will and if you were
successfully able to establish also in
that cases you can initially assign the
pp1 but again this can get changed based
upon the number and the distance of
relation
and finally if you have a family member
but they do not have they do not
actually segregate the variant that is
in question then there is a strong
evidence that the variant is the benign
variant and that's why you will be
categorizing it into a bs4 level
and again there are some other
categories and other set of rules for
defining the variant list so you can
consider in this way that if is if there
is any database you are referring as
someone has entered that uh there that
they believe this variant case of
pathogenic variant but they have not
provided any evidences use that they
have used for establishing the
classification details in that case is
what uh it will be mostly falling into
either a bp6 or bp5 criterias but if you
see again this is not recommended
because if there are not evidences in
the first hand if you find then you can
try to get as much as information you
can get and then you can go for more uh
you know holistic classification
and finally if you know that some
patients phenotype is highly specific
for a gene and if you feel that it is
not enough for any kind of disease then
it will be categorized into a pp4
criteria
again there will be a pitfall which you
have to consider because you don't have
to consider all the criterias and you
don't have to go for double counting
because if you say that a variant is
having a loss of function and if you
have already assigned a PV S1 category
then you cannot go again for Lane
changing effect that is pm4 or predicted
deleterious pp3 because see if it is
having a loss of function then
definitely it is going to meet all the
rest of the criterias so you just have
to use the strongest level that is going
to apply and you need to pick only one
item from the row again with the caution
and you have to make sure that you are
not going to double count on anything
so this is one of the example which is
from the Iowa Institute where they were
studying some of the patients and that
patient was having osteopenia and the
rickets which is basically the loss of
calcium in bones and not having enough
of bone strain and some of the kidney
problems and the pain and in that case
they had a negative family history and
when they sequence the patient samples
and they analyze the data they found
that there were two variants in this
Gene that is ATP 6b0a4 so one was the
Friendship deletion now the deletion of
four nucleotides and another was the
substitution mutation basically this was
a mission variant so initially when they
started to classify the variant they
found that the this Gene has multiple
isoform but the variant which was
falling into the Exon that exam was the
part of all the isoforms and that's why
they classified it into a pvs1 criteria
and this variant was found in the
nomadic database that is the population
database with around frequency of
0.075 percent that's why it was
categorized as pm2
so at that time they had only one very
strong and one moderate effect and
that's why they classified into a likely
pathogenic group and they were waiting
for more evidences to come by so that
they can reclassify this variant
and in case of missense variant again
the variant was found in the population
Database The Nomad database with the
frequency of 0.0 27 percent so it was
getting classified into pm2 and from the
computational tools like shift polyphen
and some other tools they predicted it
to have a damaging and a deleterious
effect that's why this was classified
into a pp3 criteria and they knew that
they had the information that only few
Gene that is only three genes are
responsible for cost causing this
disease and it is an important part
that's why they uh classified into a pp4
but still they did not have enough of
evidences to say it as a pathogenic and
they couldn't classify it into a benign
sector also
but fortunately when they went to the
literature surveys and papers they could
understand that this variant was already
classified this when it was already
classified into the pathogenic and
likely pathogenic and that's why
combining the evidences found in the
paper and combining their own evidences
finally they were able to classify their
variant having one strong to moderate
and three supporting evidences from
papers to a pathogenic group
and in the similar way from the
Friendship mutation
uh they already had classified into a
likely pathogenic again going from some
literature service and databases they
found that this variant was already
reported to have a pathogenic effect and
considering those evidences also as a
supporting material they were able to
classify this variant as a pathogenic
variant
so basically these are the rules which I
was talking about this is the list which
is given by acmg guideline they've
clearly state that what are criterias
and how many criterias or strength of
evidences you need to have so that you
can say whether your variant is going to
be having which kind of effect whether
it will be falling into a pathogenic
criteria or likely pathogenic Benigno
likely benign so you can go back to the
paper and you can try to understand all
these criterias one by one and classify
the variants accordingly
and one more thing I wanted to mention
is about the variant tree analysis that
is the variant tree classification so
sometimes what happens is when you are
trying to classify a variant there might
be chances that at that particular point
of time there are not enough evidences
available so example if you have a
variant from the population database and
in that case you could only assign a
variant as having a view as one that is
variant of Uncertain significance but
after a certain point of time there were
multiple literature service done there
are multiple evidences involved then
that was reported in the databases there
were additional family members also
tested So based on all the evidences
classified now you are able to
reclassify the variant from a viewers to
either pathogenic or B9 effect so this
is a very important thing if you talk it
up in the clinical sector and this is
something which clinical labs are
required to do on the quarterly basis so
every quarter they have to take all the
viewers being studied and then they have
to understand the viewers variants are
again getting reclassified into any of
the other criterias or not
and then these are some of the resources
which you can go through to have more
in-depth knowledge on the ACMC
classification the nomenclatures and
then you can go through the Clinton
website also for more details and try to
understand how actually the
classification is being done and the
clinical sectors
and I guess I am done with my
presentation so if there are any
questions I can take that
okay thank you so much Miss Mishra for a
wonderful presentation uh we do have
couple of queries in the chat that I
wish to share with you but after an
email since uh we are out of time right
now so I'll be sharing with you the
participate queries to email and the
participants will be shared with us
yes you can share us on the email and I
will try to revert back to all the
questions no issues
thank you so much
so with that let me invite all the
participants to the next action uh so if
anyone is interested in pursuing a
career environment so economics but I'm
sure of where to start or how to gain
the necessary skills and experience then
this is the best session for you which
is taken by Mr Emmanuel Adam Luke he is
fellow with Helix Biogen Institute
Nigeria a research organization that is
focused on accelerating research in life
through in-depth technical skills
training and capacity living and in
today's session he will be discussing on
find marriage capacity building
opportunity for students and young
professionals with Helix Biogen
Institute as a cane Tech so that brief
introduction now I'd like to pass on the
stage to Mr enactment
um Mr Emmanuel could you please unmute
yourself
thank you
Mr Emmanuel
please let me know
um
if you are in the meeting
I have given you co-host access
hello
yes
yeah I I I guess you just right now so
you're just trying to meet me yeah
so in the meantime
let me quickly give an introduction to
the speaker while he's joining
all right I hope my screen is visible at
the moment
okay all right so Mr Emmanuel he's a
research fellow at Helix Biogen
Institute Nigeria which is a research
organization that is focused on
accelerating research in life through
in-depth technical skills training and
capacity building environments
Emmanuel graduated with a bachelor's
degree in medical laboratory is fine
from the prestigious
University of Technology in IIT
he is currently a member of the
education and internship Committee of
the international Society for
computational biology student council he
is also a fellow of the open Life
Sciences mentorship program where he is
designing a biomatic Outreach for
University students and high schoolers
Inc
so that is all about Mr Emmanuel that I
wanted to interview all the party
systems so if Mr Emmanuel is here
please uh annuit yourself
all right and meanwhile he is getting
ready with this presentation I would
like to ask the participant how have you
been enjoying the session so far are
there any particular session that you
were able to enjoy
let me know in the chat
[Music]
I am also sharing with you a feedback
form
that you can fill it out and let us know
your thoughts about the session so far
and you can also let us know about any
queries that you might be having while
attending the sessions and we'll be
happy to pass on to the judges
all right uh now I guess we would like
to pass on stage to sonalika Meanwhile
we are waiting so over to you
thank you so much
let me share my screen
can you confirm if my screen is visible
yes it is loading up just a moment
yes we can see the bioinformatics and
data files for everyone
Perfect all right
so uh I would not like to discuss about
uh the bioin informatics Research
Services that we provide and you can
leverage as a scientist or a researcher
who is generating data in your own lab
or is interested to carry out for the
analysis with your research question or
your data and uh also I will discuss
about the training programs and the
research projects that we have uh
conducted successfully in United States
so a brief overview about myself as you
all know I'm sonarika the project
manager at um find biotech and our
vision is to enhance human health and
well-being by enabling biological
research and Discovery with relevant
Data Solutions and support and our
mission is to simplify bioinformatics
and advanced research through our
modular and intuitive multi-ohomics
analysis platform that is powered by
human experience and artificial
intelligence
so
so we have had the privilege to work
with our professors and researchers from
from very reputed institutions to name a
few NIH
ucsf.pa Roswell Park Georgetown
University LSU Health New Order lens we
have also worked with researchers from
Tulane University and many more
now we are an international team of
entrepreneurs researchers and clinicians
and led by accomplished bioinformatics
experts with clinical academic and
Pharma expertise and most of our team
members have advanced degrees in
biotechnology bioinformatics and
computational biology from Top
International universities and we are
doing this with a relationship with the
topper Research Center
so the platform the T bioinfo platform
is built to help prepare the biologists
and the clinicians for the large
multi-omage data sets that they have to
deal with uh on their own without
relying on technical support to set up
the computational environments and
pipelines for processing and the simple
to use solution can help train as well
as prepare anyone with the biological
data set but Advanced computational
analysis visualization and annotation
and most of such data types are
generated randomly and high speed
through high speed require requiring
complex computation data processing and
as a procedure to generate a structured
data set that could be visualized and
analyzed statistically we provide the
platform that the researchers can go
through seamlessly and support research
I would like to briefly discuss about
the T bioinfo platform which provides
user-friendly and intuitive access to
multiple standard and custom data
analysis methods the platform offers a
single interface to access various
processing capabilities like
phylogenetic trick reconstruction
multiple sequence alignment variant
calling from NGS genomic data
transcriptomic analysis of rmsc data 3D
structural analysis and screening of
small molecules as well as specialized
pipelines for oncology virology
neuroscience and agrobiological
applications
and what are those Services what it
includes and to begin with I would now
like to take you through these Services
where the researchers can use the AI
built platform to analyze their data
with expert guidance and free
consultation
here we have some costs mentioned for
standard Services long-term projects and
collaborations and this we can take
towards an analysis towards the end of
the presentation
the T bio info pipeline Builder offers a
color-coded logical and easy to follow
interface that works for multiple
structured data outputs which offers
intuitive visual outputs and creates
reproducible workflows for fair data
analysis on a simple and intuitive user
interface for processing analysis and
machine learning methods for multi-omix
data
I would like to take a pause here as I
think the speaker uh Mr Emmanuel is here
so let's take a pause and let's catch up
soon to discuss about the different
types of analysis that a researcher can
perform on the platform and also then we
discuss about few interesting projects
that we have worked on and what results
did we get foreign
it looks like he got disconnected once
again
[Music]
perhaps you can continue with your
presentation I'm unable to find him
in the participant list
[Music]
all right I think there could be a
connectivity problem maybe that a manual
is facing again take his time out to
resolve it I'll continue with the
various years of analysis in the
meantime and you can let me know once
he's here all right
so let's have this interesting
discussion about these analysis that as
a researcher we get a picture
okay so I mentioned the last time that
we would be discussing about these
different uh areas of analysis and what
analysis is possible on the platform and
to talk more about the platform over 70
percent of graduate students researchers
PhD Scholars and faculty working with
the T5 info platform have found it to be
extremely useful for Big Data analysis
tasks where you'll find the sections by
data type which includes NGS Mass Spec
structural data and others you can run
analysis or play around with demo
pipelines learn about visualization
statistical analysis and machine
learning as well and find previous
pipelines that you have run or by
logging into your account information
anytime so the users get an allotted
space that is around five terabytes are
making use
now from processing to statistical
analysis methods the T bioinfo platform
offers a user-friendly interface that is
ready for advanced bioinformatics
analysis where Modern biologists rely on
high performance computational
infrastructure to be able to run complex
bioinformatics pipelines in the cloud
and to understand this process the
training programs offered by omics Logic
will be helpful for the researchers to
use the research bioinformatics analysis
platform for Big Data to help you
develop a logical understanding of the
key methods involved in such data
preparation now let's look at each one
of these areas of analysis on the T
bioinfo Platform One by One
so to begin with let us discuss about
transcriptomics which allows users to
run quantification of gene expression
differential expression and pathway
analysis pipelines on the server and as
a result you get insightful plots
including heat map volcano plot Gene
enrichment plot gsea plot and a rich
plot highlighting differentially
expressed genes and pathways
next is the Single Cell transcriptomic
analysis or single cell rmsync data
analysis section on the server which
uses barcodes Gene file Matrix file and
metadata that is obtained by sequencing
reads from single cells and this
pipeline lists out marker genes umap and
reasoning plots feature plots wine and
plots Rich plots and also science
clusters to cells based on observed
differential Express genes these plots
ain't just useful to understand what the
Single Cell expression is but also adds
weightage to a researcher's findings and
thus a publication
now let's look what the metagenomic
section has for us this section unvees
the microbial abundance in the samples
the two popular methods used for the
analysis includes data to inclined to
analysis of amplicon sequencing whole
metagenomics long read and functional
analysis and the output includes Alpha
diversity beta diversity nmds and
taxonomic abundance plots also it helps
understand the evolutionary Trends
through phytogenetic analysis
next we have the genomics area of
analysis which provides researchers a
list of variants observed in the samples
we just also looked at some of them in a
previous session and these variants are
called upon by align the samples on the
reference genome and then visualizing
the variance in an interactive platform
like jbrowse which are detected through
powerful variant colors like Freebase
and muted tool next these variants could
be annotated to check if they are novel
or already reported and present in
databases like clinvar cost main dbsnp
are a researchers manually prepared fine
last but not the least we have the data
mining and the Machine learning section
where a researcher can perform
supervised and unsupervised analysis to
analyze Patterns group data objects by
feature similarity and trained machine
learning models for predictive analysis
under supervised area of analysis you
have the classification and the
regression algorithms that you can
explore industry analysis and under
unsupervised analysis you have
clustering algorithms like Edge Plus
k-means CB scan that you can use for
your analysis
in order to find these meaningful
associations in heterogeneous
multi-ohomish data sets this t-bioinfo
platform was put together that helps you
or offers a mix of supervised and the
unsupervised multi-ohomish integration
approaches like SNF tools I cluster plus
and by clustering and if you are
interested to learn more about what type
of data is required to run the pipelines
or how to process the data what should
be the flow of the pipeline what outputs
to expect and how to interpret the
results to gain biological insights you
can contact us and then we can further
discuss about the analysis required for
your research question
and here is what some researchers who
have used our platform for their
research projects have to say for us
now I would also like to discuss about
some of the projects that we have worked
upon but before I do that I would like
to talk briefly about the portal which
will be your guide to do wonders on the
platform as I showed showed you that
there are various resources that you can
go through and learn from so this portal
gives students options to analyze a
given data set follow code dependent
paths or code independent parts and
these data sets and Associated
Publications can be used in several ways
where you can learn bioinformatics
without any coding at all for that in
each project we explain the analysis
pipelines on the user-friendly P bioinfo
platform for Big Data analysis so under
the courses tab along with the courses
what you can see is a a list of case
studies you have a lot of case studies
on different types of omics data
analysis so once you have a skill set or
once you have an expertise for a
specific Comics analysis how do you
really apply that skill set or that
knowledge to a research question in hand
so to learn that you can go through
these different case studies to learn
how a research question could be
answered step by step which tools to use
and how to interpret your results now
you can also learn this scripts behind
many of these steps learn to Wrangle
clean visualize and also analyze data in
popular languages like R and python in
order to create your own analysis and
finally you can hear about the projects
and the research applications as well in
our mental guided training programs
where experts share their experience and
support research projects that could be
developed by you so there are people who
um frankly saying run away from both so
for the ones who are not from a
bioinformatics background but are really
entrusted to apply or use these tools
for their data analysis this is the guru
platform that you can go through and
learn more about or you could also use
it to validate the results that you get
through your steps
all right so to discuss about some of
the uh projects that the researchers
have worked on with us one of them was
pathway annotation from rainbow zebra
fashion omic and because of some uh
obvious reasons I won't be going into
much depth of the projects right now but
just to give you a brief overview of
what type of projects can you work on as
a researcher our we have also worked on
RNC data analysis of embryonic stem cell
uh that had two major groups mutant
cells and control cells and this project
was mainly for a researcher and a
professor in The lbrn Institute that is
Louisiana biomedical research Network
and we have also worked on pregnancy uh
screening of the cell free RNA from the
plasma of two patient cohorts and this
was a pretty interesting study that I
was a part of as well and we also worked
on uh to understand the effect of
retinoic acid where we performed the
rna-seq analysis on retinoic acid
treated encapsulated and embroid bodies
again this project was um for a
professor and a scientist in the
Louisiana biomedical research Network
and we did an interesting you know
assembly of herpes virus you know where
the project aims to perform denovo
transcriptome assembly of herpes virus
which has a large double standard DNA
Genome of approximately 152 kilobase per
length I wear two sets of paired and
first few files were obtained from
transcription sequencing or viral
isolates from the host green African
monkey
so that was just a brief of what type of
projects we have worked on and with that
I would like to pass on the stage to our
uh next speaker
so just would like to confirm yes we
have a next speaker amongst us hello Dr
Niza let me share my screen and
introduce you
trying to share my screen
yes I
all right so we have uh
Dr Lisa with us I would like to
introduce her uh Dr Lisa traninko
finished her Bachelor's in biophysics
and Masters in genomics and
bioinformatics as Siberian Federal
University and she's currently a PhD
student at the same place her PhD thesis
is about plant genomics where she's
performing the study on epigenetics and
genome annotation of the oil pump and
she's interested in all kinds of areas
of research while she loves working on
mammals and studying genomics and
transfer problems
it's a pleasure to have you with us I
would not like to pass on the stage to
you
thank you very much for having me I'm
excited to present her research
here
um
can you see my screen all right
yes
okay okay thank you
um so
are representing the research done in a
double Center on integrating multiple
single cell data sets
um as an example we took prostate
tissues in health and disease and our
story really started
um on only benign prostate hyperplasia
it's a disease when the prostate is
enlarged and
the difference is that it's not to
cancerous disease and it should not you
shouldn't have the prostate radically
removed by surgery as in cancer of
course
so in our case we had four donors
um
Pro for BPH each donor had samples taken
from two different areas of prostate the
stroma and granular areas and three this
is the stromal area and this is the
granule area and we also had three uh
healthy donors that the samples were
taken also from two different areas the
transitional area and peripheral area
so we started with only a banaya
prostate hyperplasia and healthy con
donors
and when we analyzed our data with Syrah
package
um on the platform that Tiba platform
we ended up with a separate analysis for
healthy donors and for BPH and we see
here that in healthy donors the majority
of the cells are epithelial cells in the
yellow and we have very small clusters
for myeloid cells and lymphoid and um
for smooth muscle and fibroblasts
we will look at BPH it's actually very
different situation here where the
Clusters are similar in size somewhat we
don't have as many epithelial cells and
they are even separated into two
separate clusters here
we have a lot more lymphoid cells and
neoloid cells
but when we decided to look a bit more
closely at BPH
we saw that some clusters were actually
sample or
um donor specific for example this small
cluster that is a part of amnesty
ethelial tissue
um it is entirely comprised of the cells
from one donor
who received Alpha blocker treatment for
nine months
um we think this suggests that this
um
treatment
uh affected somehow the expression of
genes in this tissue and that's why we
have it separate from the rest of the
endothelial cells from these two donors
another thing that we can see here is
this purple clusters that we see in each
cell type that are slightly separated
from the rest
they are also from single donor who is
actually the youngest of them all and
they have the highest PSA which is the
prostate cancer marker
and highest glucose levels but they
don't have any additional medical
conditions like diabetes or
hyperlipidemia or hypertension something
that these two donors actually have
reported to have these conditions so
um
we hypothesize that this cluster
separation can be a result of this
confounding medical diseases or
treatments that these donors
um went through
so
um next we we're also interested to see
some differences between benite prostate
hyperplasia and frosted cancer
um and we integrated two data sets each
of them had their own control samples
inside but apart from obvious technical
noise that we were expecting to see
because well these are obviously two
badges that were they were done in two
different laboratories on two different
dates by different teams so they're
bound to be batch effects but
um also we have to keep in mind that the
way these samples were taken was also
different for BPH data set this was
taken by biopsy and for cancer data
these paired samples were taken from the
porosity itself after radical surgery so
the prostate was removed
and then the
doctors or scientists histologically
studied the prostate and took samples
from the area that was cancerous and the
area that was histologically
healthy but the thing is what we know
about cancer that uh
the changes in gene expression that can
be in this process before the cancer
actually overtake the whole organ they
still can be different from the true
healthy organ so
we
um we will vary of the control that was
in cancer because it might not be a true
control
and the technical part of this was how
to integrate this data here you can see
this separate badge that has its own
epithelial cells it has its own
endothelial cells smooth muscle cells
lymphoid cells that are separate from
these clusters from BPH
um this is the picture after surah's
anchor integration and obviously it did
not work on our data for some reason we
still have very uh evident batch effect
so another approach uh for badge effect
correction
um is harmony uh what it does it looks
at uh clusters in each batch and uh well
you saw here that although they are
different they are still classified as
the same cell type so here as well we
have them they are different but they
are still classified classified as parts
of the similar cell type
um and then for these clusters uh the
centroids are found for example this one
and this one
um and then they correct the factors for
clusters so they can merge them and we
have this
mixed cluster in our case it's very you
can see it very well on the PCA this is
before correction where we can see a
clear shift of our data on pc1
and after Harmony corrected uh the PCS
um this shift is gone
uh then the umap was built on this
corrected PCS and
um these smaller clusters that
correspond to smooth muscle cells
lymphoid tissue melodic tissue they
mixed very well but this big cluster
that is epithelial cells we see that
this teal is differentiation between BPH
dataset BPH batch and cancer badge
um
but this might not be actual technical
noise that we wanted to remove this can
be a legit biological difference between
these two batches or between
sub samples between them so we
this might be very meaningful finding
for us
so first of all we wanted to see
how these cell types and the integrated
data set are different in terms of cell
composition
uh to normalize for different Library
sizes we only took 1000 genes uh sorry
1000 cells from each sample and
um
we separated them by our state States so
this is the BPH control something that
we consider as true control taken from
healthy donors then we have BPH and then
we have a cancer control
we don't consider it true control
because it's it's taken from the organ
that already has cancer at some part of
it it might have differences that are
not uh you can't see histologically but
in terms of expression there already can
be some differences there
so and and cancer and um
we can place it as a tree so from our
true control there is a difference in
terms of in BPH that we see a reduction
in epithelial cells like this is in
control although yellow is epithelial
cells there's not many in BPH but there
are a lot more lymphoid cells in green
and Miller itself in blue and also a lot
more smooth muscle cells
these differences tested by t-tests were
significant for
BPH compared to control and compared to
cancer in lymphoid meoloid and smooth
muscle cells
um we'll go from our true control to
cancer to cancer control there is not
many differences in miloid or lymphoid
clusters but there is
difference in um
the composition of epithelial cells we
see that the cluster that was enriched
in BP in true control is actually absent
in our cancer data but another clusters
of epithelial cells are present in
cancer control and in cancer data
um and again about BPH what we actually
see here the increase in lymphoid and
myeloid cells makes sense because what
we know about BPH is that it is an
inflammatory process and
many numbers of T cells and B cells from
lymphoid and neutrophils from myeloid
cells are expected to be elevated in BPH
but also we had higher numbers of smooth
muscle cells so I wanted to show you
what BPH looks like on cellular level
and in case of normal process this is
the prosthetic duct it is lined up with
different types of epithelial cells so
the luminal cells basal cells they're
sometimes
neuroendocrine cells and and other of
course and in BPH we see a lot more
stromal cells and stromal cells are
normally
uh present represented by fiberbra blast
myofibroblasts and smooth muscle cells
they are enriched in hyperplasia and
that's exactly what we see
um interestingly uh we don't see a
significant increase in fiberglass there
is some increase but it's not
significant
um so yeah based on cell composition uh
we see very good difference in BPH but
we don't really see any difference in
cancer compared to control
um and
when I was talking about epithelial
cells how our one cluster changed for
another cluster this is actually due to
different subtypes of epithelial cells
that we have so this
yeah this is the picture with a
different uh types of female cells some
are more specific for peripheral Zone
like luminal cells and basal cells some
are more specific for
um transition zone like hillcock cells
and for example Club cells they are
basically everywhere in in both tissues
there sometimes present in
uh this lining
and we can see that club cells are
separated from the rest of the
epithelial cells this is exactly this
separate cluster of epithelial cell that
I was talking about in the very
beginning they're so different they are
separated from the rest of the
epithelial cells in the pH
um so let's look at
the epithelial salsa populations in our
four stages States
in BPH and in control we have this basal
epithelial cells
abundant in our sample and a bit of
luminal cells
and in BPH we have many Club cells I did
not find anything in literature about
this phenomena at the at the moment but
our study is ongoing so maybe we will
understand why it's like that
and in cancer and then cancer control we
have a lot more
neuroendocrine cells Hill cells and
luminal cells
so this is about
um how
we not only have technical noise that we
were fighting um during our integration
of data but there is bound to be some
biological differences especially since
our sampling for these two batches was
quite different
um
but well
it's nice that we
overcame our batch effect with Harmony
but one problem with Harmony is that it
doesn't really change your expression
table so
um it's good it's perfect technique for
visualization but when it comes to
differential expression what what do you
do with your expression table how how to
actually overcome batch effect and there
are several ways to do it
um first of all there are ways to
correct batch effects so that it will
um change your expression table but in
our case those methods didn't really
work very well
so there are
two more approaches first is you can
regress uh use regression to remove the
effect of your batches on expression
table prior to differential expression
or another way is to use built-in server
functions
for differential expression that also
have tests that can remove
these factors by regression themselves
without this prior changes to expression
table
those are logical regression tests and
must that can change that can remove
batch effect during differential
expression and we used Mass with this
batch effect removal
um so
we had a lot of genes that were
differentially expressed between
cancer and BPH and for myeloid tissue
we wanted to um it it's impossible to
just go through all these genes so we
came up with a way to
um group them into Pathways using gene
set enrichment analysis something also
um available on the t-bar info platform
so how it works in a few words is that
we have several genes from this pathway
and we have all our genes set so we
align uh sorry we order our Gene set
from the one from the genes that have
the biggest log fault change and to the
ones that have the lowest negative log
flow change
um all our genes and then we look at the
genes that are present in specific
pathway like cytokine activity and here
they are highlighted the length of this
bar
shows the value of this log flow change
all of them are negative in our case
and ginsen enrichment analysis works
that you go buy each gene
um like yours like steps and if there is
no Gene in this position uh the
enrichment score
uh is reduced if there is a gene it
actually Rises so you add some value and
the more genes are there like here we
can see an increase in this enrichment
score
um
what did what it's designed to show it
designed to show if we have a an
enrichment in one of the like areas of
our Gene set for example if they're only
here we have a pretty big enrichment
score at the very end it will be
negative if our genes are enriched here
we will have a pretty big enrichment
score and it will be positive because it
will all be at the very beginning
when our genes are
distributed everywhere evenly the
enrichment score will very low because
it doesn't really tell us anything about
this pathway it only tells that like
there is no pattern for this specific
pathway and we are interested in the
pathways that are either
enhanced or inhibited in our comparison
so
um this is the distribution of logful
changes and uh
in comparison for cancer versus BPH all
our Pathways were inhibited means that
they were increased in BPH and inhibited
in cancer
and uh some of
here all the pathways are somehow
connected with immune response
like chemotaxis of leukocytes
granulocytes neutrophils
cytokine receptor binding cytokine
activity response to chemical so
everything about
immune response is enriched and
increased in BPH and or it can be viewed
as reduced in cancer
I did not show the pictures here but we
did the same for BPH versus control and
we also saw something that we expected
the immune Pathways that were
enriched in BBH the MHC functionality
The antigene Binding and vesicle
transport
when we checked cancer versus their own
control the cancer control we did not
find any Pathways that were significant
but we did find a few several genes and
two of them were parts of heat shock
family genes and there they were were
significantly overexpressed in cancer
and these genes are known to be
essential for cancer survival in
prostate cancer
and another Celta that we are looking
here at is epithelial cells and good for
us well it just makes it more
interesting that we not only have
Pathways that are inhibited in cancer
but also the ones that are
enriched in cancer
and these are iron transport
zincline transport and also epithelial
cells differentiation in prostate
development this suggests that
differentiation of epithelial cells in
cancer
is a lot more active than in BPH
and
um the pathways that are enriched in BPH
versus cancer are all about apoptosis
and cell death and
um it can be viewed a bit differently
yeah it's not enriched in BBH but it
actually is inhibited in cancer and
that's something that we know already
that cancer cells have a huge problem
with apoptosis and Celta and that's why
that's why it's cancer basically
um this is the end of my presentation
the work isn't going so it's a bit
unfinished
but if you have any questions or
anything I'll be glad to answer that
thank you
thank you so much Dr Lisa I have a
question for you so when we talk about
single cell transcript problems it's a
field that is emerging and a lot of
people have a lot of questions right now
for this team so what do you think uh
what does it mean to researchers to
really adopt this technology a single
cell Technologies how it could be really
beneficial to them and how is it
different from transcriptomics
right so um I think it's extremely
beneficial actually
um the great thing about it is that we
can look at different cell types of um
the organs like in the prostate we can
actually look for differentiation the
differential expression between cell
types even we can even pick some sub
cell types and look specifically in them
this is something that we can't really
do with bulkarnate because we
technically can't pick the cells by our
hand to test that so it's a huge
um
advantage of single cell one of the
disadvantages is that it's uh it's not
an easy experiment to do and there are
technical diff uh diff difficulties one
of this is integration of data sets that
we spoke here that not all the
approaches that we used actually worked
for us and sometimes you have to go
through all the approaches that you have
to find the one that will work for your
data set
another thing is
cell type classification because it's
also tricky we um I did not add it here
but we actually tried
um three Gene sets for our cell
annotation the the
what you see here these cells cell types
that are classified this is also
something like state of art procedure
because
you not all the genes that are known to
be cell markers actually work in a
single cell because not all these genes
are the expression of these genes picked
up very well by this technology and not
all the gene markers that were found in
bulk RNA sequencing I'll also work for
single cell so you really have to also
play with it
uh yeah
okay and uh yeah thank you and for the
single cell data the ones who want to
explore the public reposit is really get
the data uh
can you share some databases that the
researchers can explore the students
basically who are in their graduation or
post graduation and don't have the
access to lab generated data right now
yeah sure um actually this data set that
we used here is also public data set uh
we took it from an article so you
basically go to ncbi look for articles
that you uh want all the latest
Publications they have to deposit their
data to Geo gene expression
um I do I don't remember what the last
uh legislation Omniverse
yes thank you so we found our data there
basically just check uh if it's the
experiment that you need the machine
that you need and the file format that
you need for single cell they're
basically two types of input data that
is that 10x genomics where you need to
have three files and there is another
type is when you just have one table
our platform works with both data inputs
so you can download them and try try it
out also
what we Implement here is Syrah Pipeline
with some additions but Sira is publicly
available you can try its code you can
try to upload the data from in CBI and
try to run this step by step the cell
annotation in Sarai is not perfect and
we use different approaches we use CS
type package which I like very much but
the rest can be run with survive as well
the original Surah
thank you
um we have a question by Dr raghav Dr
raghav cooking a new Jason
thank you sonalika and great talk please
are they I mean extremely insightful I I
just want you to comment on on cancer uh
biology uh I mean definitely from your
talk and also from other literature we
know that singles are
RNA seek is going to add up uh or
provide lot of information that is not
discovered or that is not displaced
earlier so can you also comment on
situations where bulb cell is going to
be enough for most of the investigations
and uh on what special cases do you want
the experiment or the investigation to
be upgraded to singles and Technology
well um I have to say that I'm not very
experienced in cancer uh research but
um
ball currently is it also has its own
advantages for example single cell
doesn't really give you a lot of uh data
it doesn't give you a lot of expression
per cell because there are some limits
but bulk RNA is a lot better and there
are actually approaches to combine those
two so we have bulk RNA we have single
sun and we can deconvolute
to enhance advantages of both but in my
opinion
um
there are a lot of uh I think that for a
lot of cancers if we
look at balcony we will still see
um differences in genes if we know what
genes we're looking for then we can make
targeted rna-seq and we don't really
need a single cell but when we have
specific cell type like in case of
prostate cancer when well at least the
article says that
the most differences happen in
epithelial cells and not in the rest of
the cells it's it's better to identify
those cells and separate them from
analysis
um in BPH for example uh research says
that
fibroblasts are of the most interest so
they tend to separate fibroblasts and
look into fibroblasts in more detail and
just remove the rest of the cells and in
BPH like on this slide we see that
actually fibroblasts they don't really
make up the majority of the cells so if
we are looking to find some differential
expression differences in fibroblasts
they can be lost in all other cells
because it's not the majority we're not
sure if we have targets we can overcome
this if we don't really have targets
it's better to
export well not export but separate
yourselves from the rest in my opinion
thank you thank you very much
thank you for having me
thank you Dr Raga uh so my next question
to you is what are the specific
challenges that needs to be considered
right and why analyzing the single cell
data
yeah
as I said
um well for me
um in my experience the hardest part are
integration and cell annotation because
this is this never works from the first
try and you really have to play with it
and you have to try to understand if it
actually makes sense biologically
um and yeah for um
with integration it's technically the
hard and with cell annotation you don't
always understand if it makes sense or
not and you have to try different Gene
sets from different literature
all right and uh what about in terms of
interpretation and application what
would be some of the challenges while
interpreting the results from the
analysis
um if you do everything well it's not so
hard to interpret it I mean um if if you
actually annotated everything correctly
and if you're not exactly looking for
differential expression between batches
but between actual biological uh
differences
then I think the hardest part here would
be to
um
combine this big chunk of data in
something you can actually look through
because in our case when we test for
differential expression we end up with
thousands of genes that you cannot
possibly check manually so you have to
come up with ways to
um
to group them like in our case we came
up with this pathway analysis it can be
different types of analysis that can be
used there or
yeah I think something like that for
interpretation
um it also depends on
what what you want uh what is actually
the difference that you're looking for
because you can look into
self-composition and how many of
different cell types are present or you
have to go into differential expression
or even expression in specific genes
only specific genes
I think something like that
and how this information that one gets
or how the knowledge that one gets from
the Single Cell study could be
implemented in terms of
drug Discovery or designing a better
therapeutic approach how could this be
useful
well
um I'm not sure about drug Discovery
since I don't really have any experience
in it but um in case well for many
diseases it's really to look for markers
early markers or at least 80 markers of
this disease in case of BPH
many
tests that are ran on people they give
false positives when testing for cancer
and these people go through radical
surgery and their prostate is removed
only to uh
then be declared that they don't really
have cancer they have BPH and BPH
doesn't require you to have your proceed
removed since it's not cancerous so this
is a real problem in medicine how to
avoid this
reticle surgery when it's not needed
and this happens basically because the
current testing systems are not
efficient enough or not good enough and
single cell can help you in identifying
markers Gene markers and signatures that
can be useful in differentiating
different uh medical conditions between
each other
all right yeah
uh that was very much informative thank
you so much for this wonderful talk and
also answering all the questions uh if
there are any questions uh amongst the
participants you can please unmute
yourself raise a hand put in the chat
this is
not a lot of researchers are currently
working on but they are really
interested to learn more about it
so I don't think we have more questions
uh all right with that thank you so much
and I think we can now move to our next
part is next week sorry so
we have amongst us Dr Laura Harris
yes
hi Dr Laura so before I pass on the
stage to you I would like to introduce
you Dr Laura has accomplished her
medical biology degree and she's an
award-winning educator with over 20
years of divorce experience with
expertise in infectious disease
Immunology neurology astrobiology and
oncology she earned her PhD in
biomedical informatics from Rutgers
State University of New Jersey and she
has two master's degrees certain
molecular biology and microbiology
um she did that after breast Rose in
microbiology in 2003 and
she did a bachelor's from Michigan State
University and she has a career in the
industry working as a research associate
and a medical writer at various stages
throughout the pre-clinical and clinical
drug development process in and
alongside pharmaceutical companies
including Pfizer she then settled into
Academia where she Rose to assistant
professor and scientist position working
at a laboratory coordinator at devonport
University before becoming the director
of training for the institute for cyber
enabled research at MSU we are pleased
to have you amongst us Dr Laura I would
not like to pass on the stage to you
foreign
thank you so much for the introduction
just give me a second to get my screen
going
we should be good now yes
yes I can see our screen okay so
um first off again thank you for the
introduction and the invitation to come
talk to you all today my name is Laura
Harris and I'm going to be talking to
you about a program that I've been
working on for the last few years uh
called bio Moma biological multi-ohmic
meta-analysis I've got my contact
information there my email and my
LinkedIn I'll go ahead and plot that
into the chat at the end of the lecture
and um I'll take questions at the end so
let's go ahead and get started
so really I started out working with
transcriptomic data and transcriptomic
data had its roots with the microarray
technology
a revolution so to speak
so microarray came about in the early
1990s by Stephen Forder and some of his
colleagues and they basically developed
a chip that you could then look at
chemically
um with photosensitivity to determine
the chemicals on the chip and what their
concentrations were
so at this early stage it's simply about
developing the chip not applying it to
anything biological
once we started getting into adding
nucleotides onto there we very quickly
started adapting that to everything
human medicine animal medicine
plant-based biology and you see
microarray and subsequently rna-seq used
in a wide variety of areas so it really
has been a major Revolution over the
last 20 or 30-ish years just based on a
little tiny chip
and so as I've mentioned we've looked as
uh
scientists and medical clinicians at
everything you know infectious disease
cancer Immunology neurological diseases
and then people have taken that
technology and expanded it into any sort
of biological question so you know what
are the environmental impacts on plants
for example
and then the use for the ship expanded
over time so instead of just putting DNA
on and looking at things like gene
expression profiling or single
nucleotide polymorphisms now we're
starting to see more sophisticated use
of that ship such that now we're looking
at you know epigenetic markers such as
chromatin modification on the chip ship
rather than an rna-seq or a microarray
chip
you can also look at genomic structural
variations looking at things like
variation and copy number for example so
it really has taken on a whole wide
range of uses which is very good for
generating data that we can analyze
and as our previous speaker just
mentioned the gene expression Omnibus
which I'll call Geo for here on out is a
major part of that so Geo is a public
repository for all sorts of microarray
ship-based data and this is just a
screenshot that I took probably about a
week ago of all of the Holdings within
Geo so you'll notice for example that
there's almost 200 000 publicly
available data sets that's what a series
is
those series are
profiled on platforms which are the
actual chips these chips are made by
like Illumina Alpha metrics Etc
and there's around uh 25
000 of those that are represented in the
knowledge base and pretty close to 5.5
million samples
and continuing to grow also so you know
a lot of power within the data housed in
Geo
and this is a little hard to see but
what you see here is that data is varied
based on what its application is so
there is a lot of transcriptomic data
either through the microarray itself or
through rna-seq but then you'll see you
know genomic variations genome binding
occupancy profiling methylation
profiling this is not a complete list so
if I had scrolled down I could see
things like non-coding RNA profiling
protein profiling by array Etc so this
is where we start to get into the idea
that you can do a multi-ohmic approach
not just looking at gene expression but
then incorporating the findings from
gene expression
two findings from other types of data
for example methylation profiling data
to get more of a wholesale view of
what's going on in a particular disease
or biological question
so then around that I started working
with transcriptomic data
and so bioma is the biological
meta-analysis not multi-ohmic yet
so I'm only dealing at this point with
one type of data primarily
transcriptomic data either microarray or
rna-seq or sometimes I'll discuss later
epigenomic as in DNA methylation or
proteomic which in protein profiling
one second
this is what I get for talking too much
and so bioma has successfully been
applied to compare differential gene
expression in various
ways so you know looking at antibiotic
resistance specifically in
staphylococcus aureus think MRSA if
you're a clinician kind of person we've
expanded that to pseudomonas and looking
at antibiotic resistance and E coli you
know various superbugs and then of
course stars came along so we applied
the methodology there I'll be talking
about some papers um that I've published
in that area we're expanding into cancer
and neurological disorders now
but um the idea here is that you
basically take transcriptomic data
and you're going to do differential gene
expression analysis
and then you're going to use that to be
able to look at pathway changes
and then if you do that across multiple
data sets you then can get a
meta-analysis and if the data sets all
start reporting the same genes or the
same Pathways then you know those are
potential uses that could be
examined in the laboratory or further
examined in the clinic so they could be
good for you know discovering new drugs
repurposing current drugs or just having
a general better understanding of what's
going on in a disease process
so with bioma we've got a probe
signature so this is going to be a list
of probes that's directly from the data
you get from either your laboratory or
from gene expression Omnibus so this is
a list of genes a list of methylation
sites lipids whatever
and we're going to rank those
I'll call them jeans for now just you
know for consistency here we're going to
rank those by phenotypic variation so
basically the difference in gene
expression between my diseased and my
control group
I'm going to represent that probe
signature by this line here where red is
going to represent over expression in my
diseased or experimental group I could
be dealing with plants you know that are
nutrient deficient or whatever
and then the blue end would be under
expressed
in the um
diseased versus the control
and in the middle is going to be
expression that is roughly equal between
the two groups and so I've got my data
up here in this case I've got enough
data because I'm using a bulk data set
to be able to differentiate between an
identification signature
second identification signature and a
third verification signature
and I can do this between my
experimental my control samples
I'm going to rank my jeans get my
signature and then I'm going to take the
top 10 or so percent of the genes in
those signatures and I'm going to use
them to define a query Gene set
I'm going to use Quarry Gene sets
defined by these signature Tails both
the over expressed and the under
expressed for the identification
signatures
and I'm going to use Gene set enrichment
analysis to basically cross compare them
between the two signatures
this will give me a set of Leading Edge
probes which if I find similarities
between the cross comparison I can use
them to define a panel
of genes so this basically will give you
a panel of overexpressed and a panel of
underexpressed
I can then use those panels against that
third verification signature use some
random modeling and see which of those
specific genes in the panel are also
represented strongly within the
verification signature
so that then gives me an idea of genes
that are associated with a particular
disease state
excuse me my voice is giving out
so for the example that I've got on the
prior slide down here this link goes to
the SARS paper where we did this type of
analysis so we were looking at SARS one
to Define our panels and verify our
panels
and this was SARS infected lung tissue
epithelial cells if you're real curious
and then we wanted to obviously compare
it to modern day covid SARS Cove 2. so
this is where the meta-analysis part
comes in
since I have panels of SARS one genes
that I'm confident because I was able to
verify them in non-overlapping data
I can then use those same panels and
compare them to signatures that were
defined from SARS to data so these are
new data sets again from Geo where
they're taking SARS to and infecting
epithelial lung cells
find the genes that are both over and
under expressed and then compare them
across each signature that I can get my
hands on in the study I'm referencing we
went across like seven or eight
different strains of covid and 30
different data sets
but that will then give you genes of
interest that are very relatable to the
laboratory so in the case of our SAR
study we found interferon genes we're
very highly over expressed and that
would be great for interferon therapy
for example
to get a wholesale approach we can then
look at it from a pathway level
and so we can then Define pathway
signatures where we list the pathways
which are basically Gene ontology
biological processes Gene sets that I
get from the molecular signature
database from broad Institute
and now I can rank those Gene sets by
their normalized enrichment score when I
compare those Gene sets individually to
the signatures that I just defined
I then can rank the pathways and that
will give me a pathway signature so this
is kind of shown at the top up here
where I started out with the same gene
signature that I had before now I'm
going to compare it to those Gene sets
that I just talked about from msigdb
rank them based on normalized enrichment
score I get a pathway signature the red
end are going to be Pathways with a
positive normalized enrichment score
these are up regulated in my disease
State compared to my control
and then the blue end would be down
regulated in disease State compared to
my control
do the same sort of cross analysis
between my pathway signature that is
identifying from one set and another set
and I can Define pathway panels from the
leading edges of those Gene set
enrichment analyzes
these pathway panels can be compared
then to Pathways signatures from
independent data sets use some random
modeling and figure out which pathways
are consistent
do the same type of meta-analysis
approach you get pathway level view of
the cell
so this has all been done with one type
of data set in the case of SARS and my
antibiotic resistant work it was
transcriptomic
but as you notice from Geo at the
beginning of the talk there's a lot of
different data sets you can get your
hands on or that you could generate in
your lab
so here I'm showing example of a
methylation profiling data that would
give you information of the epigenomic
level of the cell you could incorporate
single nucleotide polymorphism or copy
number variation you know genome
variation profiling data this could give
you more of a genomic look at the cell
you can do transcriptomic like we've
been talking about that looks at
messenger RNA production
you could then incorporate non-coding
RNA profiling data so this could give
you a look at the gene silencing that's
going on inside the cell
and then profiling for proteins could
give you a proteomic approach
and of course if we combine all of these
different types of data
particularly from the pathway signature
level in addition to the probe signature
level we then can get functional
genomics where we're literally taking
more of a whole cell view of what's
going on in the system
and so the check marks you see here is
what we've been working on uh to develop
this bio Moma uh approach um and in this
case we're using cancer so we have paper
and review right now with cancer
informatics
um we've been accepted but we've got
some edits to do and that's looking at
the methylation profiling level again
doing this type of meta-analysis across
you know 40 different signatures and
several different data sets I think we
had like 12 different cancer types in
that study
we have just completed the level of
transcriptomic and now we're
incorporating the proteomic and the
transcriptomic 4 non-coding RNA
so what's been interesting now is to try
to figure out what it all means
so there are some genes that we see that
will be over expressed or Pathways that
are up regulated at the methylation
level that are under expressed or down
regulated at the transcriptomic level
the messenger RNA level
there are some genes and Pathways that
don't really change or that change in
one but not the other
and so now I really have to dig into the
biology and finding um you know my
colleagues that work more in the biology
side and ask them hey you know here's
what we're seeing at these various
levels how might you interpret this
whole cell picture
and so that's been pretty exciting to do
and we haven't quite gotten into the
genomic variation part of it yet we're
hoping to but that's going to be the
next series of papers and cancer is to
show this whole model working and it'll
be a fun summer
so then just to conclude briefly we
started just looking at one type of data
so by Ma is finding molecular changes
that are associated with a phenotypic
variation of some type of ohmic data
and then using a meta-analysis approach
to find genes or Pathways associated
with that variation that disease
it's been used successfully across the
different types of diseases we're now
applying it to plants which is kind of
cool we're also looking at how space
affects different uh tissue types and
animals and plants so that's you know a
lot of applications for this kind of
approach and again it helps to identify
new drugs repurpose current drugs and
just get a better understanding
oh and then expanding into the
multi-ohmic part of this
integrating the findings across the
different types gives you a multi-ohmic
approach and then gives you more of a
wholesale view of what's going on
physiologically
so again I'll go ahead and plop this
information into the chat you know feel
free to reach out to me if you're
interested in learning more about it or
working with this process you know I'm
happy to help or you know offer what
assistance I can and I'll take any
questions
thank you
thank you so much Dr Harris let me
quickly share my screen and we do have
couple of queries in the chat that I
wish to share with you
so of course um one of the queries that
we have is what are some unanswered
questions that you think can be answered
with multiomics that could not be
answered with a single type of permits
data
well what I really get excited about now
is this idea of a digital twin
that we could potentially take a cell or
even an organism like a bacteria or
ideally a human
and replicate it in a virtual
environment so then that way if you
monkey with the digital twin you can
then begin to predict how your actual
twin would respond and I think that's
where we can really get into some good
areas in
individualized medicine
thank you so much
and then the next question is how can
data visualization and data integration
techniques used to facilitate
multi-ohomisha meta-analysis and work
publicly available tools are available
um well as far as the what publicly
available tools are available there's
Google for that and those are constantly
changing they're constantly updating and
revamping so you know Google is your
friend uh in that regard if you would
repeat the first question that would be
terrific
uh so how can data visualization and
data integration techniques used to
facilitate multi-ohomics in Atlanta
well I mean people are tend to be visual
creatures so anytime that you can put
your data into something that is
visually
pleasing and easy to understand you're
more likely to get people to buy in
um and to understand and use slash adapt
your your methodology
um so definitely visualization and
integration you know is a huge part of
it
um but I wouldn't necessarily say that
it's weighted any heavier than say
predictive accuracy or the ability to
you know
learn something biologically from your
system
thank you so much and then we have a
another pretty all right uh it looks
like Dr raghav has raised his hand
uh doctor
yeah hello Dr Lara great talk uh you've
compared your methodology with the G set
enrichment analysis and also spoke a
little bit about the panel uh uh uh
generation can you please elaborate on
that what uh excess or extra information
your methodology adds then simply uh
performing a gene set enrichment and
handles and identifying Partners
associated with that okay
um so first off let me clarify something
uh the methodology uses Gene set
enrichment analysis uh so the same
limitations that apply to Gene set
enrichment analysis inherently do and
apply to this technology now where most
people use geneset enrichment analysis
is basically to take a gene set that
represents a pathway and apply it to a
Gene's signature to just basically say
is this pathway over or sorry up or down
regulated in my data what this does is
it takes a whole pathway approach so
rather than just looking at selected
Pathways from Gene set enrichment
analysis you're effectively looking at
all of the pathways at once and I have
seen people recently start to do that in
their papers as kind of like a shotgun
method which is awesome but rather than
just using it as a shot gun method the
biomoma actually uses another data set
as query in order to find which pathways
are most associated with your disease
State and then further uses Gene set
analysis for verification and random
modeling
excuse me again my throat's giving me
trouble
um but anyway I I hope that helped
answer your question yes
yes perfectly perfect I mean if I may
also then you add a layer of resolution
that is uh not being covered by Gene set
and digital analysis and standard
approach am I correcting that with them
correct and that's just from the one
level once you start going multi-ohmic
you're in a whole new ballpark
of course because thank you very much
for the time yeah you're welcome great
question
all right and I can see that Don Moy has
raised
in Dunmore could you please ask your
query
yes ma'am I was just asking that as a
student of uh
as a student of medical biotechnology I
want to ask you that what is the purpose
can we use it in a clinical stage
because
initially the bacterias grow very less
and when we put it into the wet lab and
culture it does not gives us any result
but within our two weeks it is it makes
a huge amount of
infection stages it raises the infection
but so how can we control this using
bioinformatics
um well
here it would be a lot easier for me to
discuss it based on an actual example
in the clinic I haven't had too much
problem in terms of comparing different
states so for example one data set that
I was looking at uh was comparing HIV
positive and negative well one data set
was adults the second data set was
children but regardless they were
positive and negative HIV people and
then some of them had active
tuberculosis some of them had latent
tuberculosis and then some had you know
normal
belongs I I don't want to say normal
tuberculosis but you understand non
non-tb
um and so there it was kind of like a
Time course clinically because the
latent TB is likely going to be like the
remission of a prior infection with TB
that could re-emerge later and so we
were trying to find you know which
Pathways or what cellular mechanisms
were keeping the TB kind of dormant from
a human biology standpoint so from that
side clinically we haven't had too much
of a problem
um I will acknowledge that this
technology this idea is not great with
single cell so you do need bulk but you
know a minimum of three flats or three
test tubes or three petri dishes per
condition is enough to give you a
standard t-test and once you have a
standard t-score you can rank your genes
and make your pathway signatures and go
on from usual and you know the
antibiotic resistance with MRSA and
pseudomonas were all based on you know n
of three per group so smaller sample
sizes don't really seem to affect it the
quality of the data will though you do
need good RNA extraction
I hope I answered that question
yes ma'am and one thing is that when we
grow TV culture TV culture takes a lot
of time to grow it takes sometimes it
can takes weeks so oh yeah that is one
problem
in uh when we are doing diagnosis
because the time lost in growing that
culture can sometimes be fatal
oh yeah yeah I'm not going to argue that
there's not much anything can be done to
speed that up
I'd kind of be concerned if there was
okay thank you for answering that part
okay
thank you so much so much for asking and
there are some more queries for you that
is a commercial acting
um are there any meta-analysis done on
Parkinson's
[Music]
um I mean
have I done it a little bit
um I unfortunately cannot share that
data because it's part of a partnership
with a Pharma company
um but we have used it for Parkinson's
for Alzheimer's for um Rhett syndrome
for you know some neurological disorders
like that so can it be done yes
um I find that when you're dealing with
the neurological disorders the biggest
challenge there's two challenges one is
these clearly defining what condition
you're talking about
Alzheimer's is probably the worst
because when you have a diagnosis of
Alzheimer's you really don't know what
its root cause is you just understand
that this is you know a type of dementia
so the data kind of gets scattered and
it's hard then to tease out you know
certain genes or Pathways because you
know you could have someone that's
getting Alzheimer's because of a prion
disease or someone that's got
Alzheimer's because of a plaque buildup
or you know various things tend to
contribute to alzheimer's it's a
phenotype not a mechanism
so in that case it's a problem the other
challenge has been part of the brain
so if you're taking samples from you
know the cerebellum versus The frontal
cortex obviously your Gene transcription
is going to be different and a lot of
data sets just put brain
and you're stuck with this well where is
it in the brain and then you get the
noise from different parts of the brain
when you're trying to do the
meta-analysis so those kind of things
are considerations that if you can
design your experiment you know if you
have access to clinic or the lab and can
design an experiment where you're
consistently taking the same part of the
brain or the same tissue type that's
definitely helpful going into any
bioinformatic analysis
thank you so much and I have received
the follow-up on the previous question
that I've asked how can data vision and
data integration what available tools
are there uh I believe the participants
is asking are there any specific tools
that you would recommend
I could go on forever it really depends
on what you need to do
perhaps you could just give few examples
what are they doing
I have no information on that yeah
all the cancer
well again like what are you doing are
you doing protein modeling are you
trying to find copy number variation are
you annotating a genome you know there's
so many tools out there that the first
thing you need to ask yourself is what
do I want to get out of this data and is
this the right data that I should be
using to answer the question a lot of
times I'll get data look at it and be
like yeah well I'm not going to be able
to answer that question so I either need
to find better data or I change my
question depends on what I need to be
able to do with the project
um so yeah I mean I can get this where
you know maybe biomoma predicts some
genes but some of those are hypothetical
proteins now I need to start going into
protein modeling things like fire two I
would have said 3D ligand site but for
some reason they're having trouble
recently
um
Sybil or any sort of you know protein
modeling docking program Stitch string
Etc not usually what I deal with but you
know if I need to they're there so
really depends on what you're doing
and then we have one query on how can
machine learning algorithms be
integrated with the multi-atomics
methana
uh trade secrets are fun
um basically what I would like to do in
the future
is to actually incorporate deep learning
because what you're seeing here is
already considered machine learning
artificial intelligence
but we can make it more sophisticated so
adding things like a deep neural network
to analyze the signatures instead of
geneset enrichment analysis could give a
better outcome or a different outcome
um and has yet to be done it's something
you know as I said kind of working on
that sort of thing but there are
challenges associated with that
um gsea is already well established it's
well documented you don't have that
whole Black Box part of a deep neural
network
um or sorry you yeah you don't have that
black box with gsea that you do with the
Deep neural network so yeah there's a
lot of room to expand this
all right thank you so much Dr Harris
but I want to film the presentation now
we would like to move on to the next
part of today's Symposium which is price
distribution for the poster presentation
so the prices will be awarded in the
category Beck Technical and research
project on a competitive topic promising
research direction for future potential
and most Innovative approach in an
established domain so with that let me
first invite uh the first president who
has won the third guy which is a
chimasha Indonesia from Edinburgh Napier
University Sri Lanka
could you please unmute yourself and let
us know
what are your thoughts
are you there
yes congratulations yes
and I would like to thank the entire
omics logic and find biotic team for
giving us this opportunity to present
the um
research and a special Thanks goes out
to um
generous support and guidance given to
me throughout the program thank you
everyone
please stay in the meeting I would like
to ask you a few more queries before you
leave let me announce the next uh second
second prize winner for the poster
presentation competition which is
who is a medical biotechnology student
from Kolkata congratulations
yes thank you for this opportunity so it
was a nice learning curve for me and for
every
things in the medical community I had
this question for so long now at least I
know how to solve the problem it's just
the tip of the iceberg and thank you for
Dr raghav and you all guys you have
given me lots of help
from discovering data and have Disturbed
you a lot during this session
so it's very nice to be a part of this
and I'm very happy
to get something that I have worked on
for six months and some and it's become
a very good thing now I don't know
congratulations so
um please stay in the meeting I'll like
to follow up on some of the queries that
I have for you so now finally the first
prize for the poster presentation
competition is won by Ariana F Rahman
from Beatrice Chandler High School uh
Arizona
so
Ariana are you there with that yes I'm
here
all right could you please uh I've made
you co-host uh will you be able to turn
on your camera
I'm sure I'm actually at a
Symposium right now but I can do my best
um I'd like to thank everyone for the
opportunity to be at at the present at
your Symposium and thank you so much for
everything that you all have done the
poster presentation and everything was
so well done and I'm very happy that I
was able to do this research and I thank
everyone from The omics Institute would
not from and pine bio I would not be
able to do this without you so thank you
so much
thank you so much Ariana I believe that
you have to leave the meeting very
quickly since you have to yeah yeah all
right thank you so much Ariana
so let me quickly get back to uh other
participants
so up first uh let me ask chimasha
jamasha are you there
yes
all right uh can you let me know what uh
is a preparation that you went along
with during the part of the poster
presentation because there might be
students who might be interested to uh
uh do their poster work as a part of
symposite in the upcoming film do you
have any tips or tricks that you would
like to share
um
yeah I think uh you mean a specifically
for poster presentation or the um
generally for the research
the poster president
oh yeah I I think I went online and got
some tips and I actually I refer them
graduate posters and from there I got a
lot of tips
all right and what was your motivation
behind the research topic that you were
trying to work
um this is something I've been um the
literature review I've been doing since
my undergraduate I always wanted to do
something like this but
um only after graduating I could do this
so because um I think yesterday was
um yesterday also um this was mentioned
um even though it's all I like
it I mean it's very or all the
bioinformatics stuff is open source and
you can really learn online but the
navigation is what uh we sort of it is
the part I felt most difficult and this
is
um where I got a lot of help for that
thing if you have what I want to tell is
if you have a research question
um that you're really interested then
it's very easy to navigate and even a
little bit of guidance
you will have you will can you will be
able to um
do the research if you have first thing
is to have a research question I guess
okay thank you so much and I believe
there are participants with that in this
important who could not join here today
so could you please uh quickly give a
overview about the topic that you have
done as well as what do you plan on
doing with your project afterwards now
that you have finished with your project
are you there with us or do you get
disconnected
hello SRI gauri can you please repeat
the question
sure so uh we have with us in the
Symposium participants who were not able
to attend yesterday's poster competition
so could you please give a brief
overview about the project that you have
done and tell us about how do you plan
on continuing with your project is it
that you plan on publishing or whatever
Yeah so basically what I did
it's a two differential expression
analysis and Genesect of enrichment
analysis um on circular RNA profiles and
inexposition profiles from Parkinson's
disease and um
what I've found was
um
even though it's from two different data
sets I found um
a subset of genes that are significantly
enriched in um
bbmc in Parkinson's which also encoding
for circularities so um then on there
after that I
um did all the gene set enrichment
analysis and
um find out the most significantly
enriched Pathways and I am currently
repeating this analysis for many
different data sets to increase the
statistical significance and confidence
and I'm also excited to see the results
the
I what I found most challenging was to
find the on-coding genes for a set of
circarnas
secularities
um because
um even though um there are many
circular RNA databases based
um mostly um there are four cancer for
Parkinson's I found it very difficult to
find those databases
um but other than that it's pretty much
exciting and I'm hoping to finish the
analysis soon
thank you so much and do you plan on are
you planning to apply for your higher
studies and showcase your project
what is your plan
yeah I'm hoping to start my Graduate
Studies in this autumn
so yeah I don't know so I'm I'm hoping
to do um PhD in Immunology so yeah this
will be the um
Parkinson's this uh these are the
studies that I always wanted to do I'm
particularly interested in the
inactivation of dlr4 mediated neural
inflammation in Parkinson's disease that
is the topic I've always
thinking about and this is a sort of a
result of that I really wanted to
sort of see the question in different
angles
um yeah so that's the plan for now
thank you so much
and we have with us uh the mentor who
guided you for your project so
um Dr nagar when sonalika do you have
any uh reviews that you would like to
share
all right it looks like they are not in
the meeting at the moment
would you like to go first
every congratulations uh to matcha
[Music]
it's punctual
okay thank you so much
and now let me move on to the next
participant
[Music]
are you there with us
yes yes so first of all uh can you
please introduce yourself uh to the
particle your educational background
yeah I I am
done my bachelors in medical laboratory
technology from West Bengal University
of Health Sciences so actually this was
the uh actually this was not my
questions it was the Curiosity of our
interns that were in the batteryology
lab
so actually the Curiosity was developed
by somebody else and ancestors were
found by me so
actually the thing is when we work with
microbes and when we do the wet lab
we don't get the results and the results
that I'm seeing here are totally much
more different from what results that we
expect
so when we are dealing with fermented
that we generally we will think about
everything would come down to
lactobacillus and bacterias
lactobacillus types but when I went to
the research conducted those plot
makeups
then I found that lactobacillus was
never present it was present in two
samples and that also was below one
percent zero point one percent sometimes
so now now I get a picture that it's not
everybody is bad sometimes clostridia
which is referred as every go if you go
to Every microbiologist and they had
clostridia they would say a big Mafia
bringing out guns and killing everything
in the intestine so it's not that
clostridia has some good
functions as well so it helped me
understand the basics of the
microbiology for me also
so also get a knowledge about where I
was wrong in the wet lab how dry lab can
intervene and solve the problems so it's
not about every every term that every
micro Suite classified this is the bad
and this is good that's not the case it
depends upon the situation how they
interact with the body it's about
opportunistics to be
please you have those peoples have to be
present at the right place at the right
time so it's a great learning curve for
me and this thing can be implemented in
this is a huge potential it can
revolutionize the healthcare field
forever we can save time money resource
everything can be saved if we combine
these two together it will be a very
nice thing
thank you so much and thank you for you
all guys Dr raghav specially helped me
developing the concepts and all under
making me understand every small bit of
it
hey thank you so much Sunray can you
also um let us know what was the
preparation that you went through to
prepare your poster do you have any tips
or tricks that you would like to share
with the upcoming basically basically
the thing is
you have to get your Concepts right from
the base your Concepts if your concepts
are right then you can
clear up much more it's not about the
poster it's about clearing your thought
process and getting much more knowledge
and Gathering the knowledge that you
develop from this person this poster is
just a tiny part that I have the
knowledge that I have gathered so this
is just a small reparatory actually the
data present in that poster is not
significant because the whole analysis
was very large and it contains very much
number this is just a small part that I
put in there
right and what do you plan on uh doing
after completing your project now that
it is completed some students publish it
some students like she is trying to uh
showcase it as part of a higher study
what about Europe
actually I have a second round of
interview of a startup so I'm just
starting the clinical clinical round of
that I am writing a
uh paper that they have given so I'm
just doing that and hopefully I'm
can clear that round and I can be part
of them so it's it was a great learning
this learning helped me in this clinical
and uh this previous round of interview
and this all helped me to clear it quite
easily so I would be hopeful that clear
this round also
presentation and I wish you guys all the
very best to including Ariana as well
although she's not here with us right
now but once again congratulations and
we look forward to seeing you all Bloom
and Bloom in your feet
thank you so much
and with that now I would like to pass
on the stage to sonalika to invite uh
the next speaker over to you tonight
speaker
uh
all right I guess uh sonalika is having
some issues so let me just quickly share
my screen and
introduce him all right so last time we
could not catch up with you Mr Emmanuel
but uh this time we are glad to have you
back so let me quickly give you an
introduction to uh the next speaker Mr
Emmanuel he's a research fellow with uh
Helix Biogen Institute Nigeria a
research organization focused on
accelerating research in life through
in-depth technical skills training and
capacity building in bioinformatics and
genomic Emmanuel Emmanuel graduated with
a bachelor's degree in medical uh
in medical uh by laboratory science from
prestigious laroque University of
Technology
and he is currently a member of the
education and internship Committee of
the international Society for
computational biology student account he
is also a fellow of the open Life
Science mentorship Program where he is
defining a bioinismatic Outreach for
University students and high schoolers
in Nigeria so and today he'll be talking
about biant marriage capacity building
opportunities for students and young
professionals with health expiration
Institute Associated so with that brief
introduction the stage is all yours
oh um good day everyone I don't know if
you could hear me it's
um it's evening in Nigeria
uh can anyone hear me so I know I'm
communicating well
hello
yeah yeah okay okay so
um first I I would say
um
coming
uh I I would say
um this is going to be a brief
discussion and I'm going to be starting
with my story
of medical laboratory science
um yeah so
I'm today I'll be talking about
opportunities for for young people you
know capacity building which my
organization
Elizabeth Biogen you know is involved
so uh
I'm coming
yes I know you're perfectly audible uh
if you have slides could you please
share your screen yes okay so uh can you
see my slide so this is at least biology
and um we are research biomedical or
research Hub improving its care person
development and Diagnostics to
diagnostic kids development
um biologics through artificial
intelligence and machine learning to
prevent and control outbreaks of
infectious disease and our Research
Institute is located in Obama show
or your State Nigeria that is the South
Western part of Nigeria
and um it has been a wonderful platform
for young people like myself
and other young people out there you
know to get themselves equipped with
knowledge and excuse in bioinformatics
however when I finished school in 2019
when I before I went for my one year
compulsory internship
at the hospital because of my background
as a healthcare professional I met my
mentor who is the executive director and
principal investigator for This research
institutizing the person of Dr Elijah
and he got me interested in
bioinformatics though I was I was
introduced to bioinformatics in my
fourth year because my my discipline
like my course mother graduate degree
was a five-year course so he I were
introduced to by 4matics and molecular
biology but it was looking abstract and
we never knew what in what way
bioinformatics could be applied in
I don't really want to go back because I
I know would have been told about how
the you know the fields in by 4matics
then it got me interested you know he
got me very interested in this field and
I remember I volunteered
in um I organized in the planning
committee for the first by 4matic
conference in Nigeria and from there
that sparked a flame for me in
bioinformatics
and I'm really excited about the journey
it has been
uh it has been adventurous it has been
you know it has come with a lot of
opportunity and I want every younger
person out there that perfomatics is a
feud
that you can get yourself
um get yourself into so we've been
trusted by World leading companies and
our vision is to be the best leading
translational Research Institute in
biomedical Sciences providing high level
of training capacity building to give
inspiration and to encourage innovation
so um
in Africa we I I have my final group of
young and ironic group of young
researchers we conducted the research
three years ago and we found that with
the high level of awareness or will I
say the without uh or going out level of
awareness of or bioinformatics education
in Africa we are still
um African has not gotten to that point
of having a good number
and that is a cause of unsigned Greek we
could see how tools of genomics and
bioinformatics came being in developing
vaccines so
um I really want to appreciate what omis
logic is doing like we could see and
appreciate your work in Africa I also
want to appreciate almost logic also
partnering with us in some of our some
of our trainings
uh yet you don't need to be you don't
you don't need to have it all when I may
have it or you don't necessarily need to
have an advanced skill before you start
your career journey in by 4matics
you could pick up internship programs
you could keep you could pick up online
courses and you find yourself in that
journey and Mathematics is not abstract
even though it's an interdisciplinary
field which includes statistics which
includes um um biology which also
includes you know you know you know
computer science when you talk about
computer programming but you can always
find your your your stay your fifth in
bioinformatics like my background is
more of medical Sciences
um uh I I never I I never had that
um thorough
thorough education in computer
programming but bioinformatics as
exposed me to things like machine
learning and computer programming and um
I'm bringing it out here to see the
works that we as at least biology are
done we've done couple of trainings that
we have you know upcoming trainings like
the Intensive Workshop
on ML vaccine design what we do for our
organization and What Makes Us quite
different from other organizations is
that we are there to a group students
young Professionals in being involved in
translational research I'm of the
opinion of
science for Africa by Africans
the truth of the matter is um
as Africans I'm speaking to Africans
down this space and also other people
from low medium income countries
the West will not always solve our
problems
the West we know we solve our problems
but we can be hope in our games to solve
our problems
we know
our our challenge we know our challenges
we know what we face
and we could we are the best people to
provide Solutions and that's why I'm
calling on every young person over here
I want you to shoot your shots at taking
an interest in bioinformatics I know I
enjoyed this Symposium is because you
want to get engaged and all this logic
itself as an organization is a good
platform you can start your interest in
bioinformatics
and because of the men because of the
mentorship had gotten from Ellie's
biology
I've been able to be able to take part
in you know teaching in you know in in
teaching some online courses for young
people you know just a young boy like me
less than 30 I'll be able to you know
taking some courses even without a
master pass and this has been a platform
and privilege currently we have over 450
students or they are going internship in
our lab
I don't know last week we had some of
them
in last one month we've had some of them
work on designing vaccines for some
infectious disease that are really
battle in Africa
like negative tropical disease if you go
through our LinkedIn uh LinkedIn or
Twitter at our Twitter account you would
see some of these beautiful things that
you you would you teach someone to
benefit that young people do papers that
we've published
you know adding value to the community
of science
[Music]
I I are you still with me
hello
yes we can hear you
okay
um
currently we are pushing out a project
with open life science
I don't know how many of us know about I
don't know how many of us know about
open life science if you know about
applying science you could just put it
in your chat box open life science open
life science it's um it's a 16-week
mentorship program
for young people young professionals and
students
you know to develop interests of open
Life Science in open science and also to
contribute to contribute to the body of
science currently and a team of of three
people are currently working on
um biomatics university Outreach
where we could reach out to you know
University students and get them
equipped with skills in bioinformatics
I know by 4matics and um and genomics
I'm going to be sending a slide to the
organizer so they can share with us so I
can put all these things in here because
I'm having issues with you know my slide
at the moment and um secondly as a young
person
you could join societies which are by
mathematics centered we have societies
like the international Society for
computational biology we also have a
society called African society called
bioinformatics and computer biology from
there what this Society is do for you is
to provide you platform for personal and
professional development currently I
belong to the student council of the
international Society for computer
computational biology yes you don't need
to have all your skills as a
bioinformatician because bioinformatics
is a growing space but you could add
value you could contribute you know to
development of bioinformatics in your
country in your look your location So
currently I serve
on the educational education and
internship committee
of the student council of the
international Society of computational
biology and currently we are developing
you know we are working with sister
organizations to
you know build platforms to create
platforms that young people could get
interested in by 4matics you can't talk
about any field both in physical
sciences in life sciences in
agricultural scientists that you
they're going to apply bioinformatics
even to physics you can apply
bioinformatics in physics you can apply
bioinformatics in chemistry you can
apply bioinformatics in agriculture you
can you can apply bioinformatics as a
tool as a field as a discipline also in
medicine and there is a need for Africa
I also want to plead with only logic
um we want you know you as an
organization to invest more in Africa we
have a lot as a challenge for us in
Africa one is the infrastructure to you
know the infrastructure in um in in
getting you know getting ourselves
rooted in bioinformatics one of the
infrastructure is in Africa we have
unstable internet facilities
internet subscription is quite expensive
and when you want to run you know
genomic data you know how much you know
data you're going to get you know
internet subscription you're going to
get to in analyzing you could analyze a
genomic data for over for a couple of
days anyway and another issue we have is
um low power supply you know some of our
communities don't have access
electricity these are things that are
standing in our challenges to us in
Africa also the economic the economic um
situation of Africa is very poor there's
a need for uh I don't know how many of
us here are representing organizations
and I want to plead when you're creating
programs training programs for Africans
please put in the economic the economic
the economic uh uh putting economic
factor of what Africans are facing like
Nigeria we have 90 percent of Nigerians
Nigeria being the most populated
um you know the most populous black
nation in in in the world in Africa we
have 90 percent of us living you know 90
of us living be you living at that
property line so some of us won't be
able to you know afford trainings of
let's say 250 dollars even fifty dollars
that they need for us to you know
inculcate open science that's the need
of us bringing in programs training
programs that no one whether in Africa
whether another low medium middle um low
medium income countries or low-income
countries no one is being prevented in
partaking in this training and that's
what we've been in here at least biology
we've organized free of free programs
that you know students uh students can
easily assess this training
yeah sometimes we say Okay paying for
the training is going to make such
people committed but many of us can't
really afford this many of us cannot
really afford this so there's a little
of us putting up scholarships in helping
you know young people students getting
involved
in in by you know in bioinformatics in
Nigeria as are today we have all we have
over 200 universities in Nigeria
and
up to 80 of these universities students
in these universities even
academic staff in these universities
that have not come in contact with
bioinformatics
so there is a need for us to create you
know that true training and also
mentorship there's a place where
mentorship currently I mean
young researchers we are planning we are
working on conducting a research
to assess the level of awareness
knowledge and practice of bioinformatics
among
you know undergraduate students and
postgraduate students in Nigeria
we've known that many people get
equipped with bioinformatics but in
Nigeria as are today
that
create a platform
where even when we train young people
young people students they can easily
apply these skills they can easily apply
these skills but I want to say that
Africa is a good market for us to get
people equipped with bioinformatics
Africa is always loaded if you're
talking about medicine Africa is loaded
with a couple of edge challenges
ranging from infectious disease to
non-communicable diseases like cancer we
have we are still battling with malaria
currently like malaria
passing candidates
malaria
zero to five
um yet of you know children between zero
to five years die of malaria millions of
students die of malaria there's a need
of both developing vaccines and this is
where we could you know get young
researchers
involved that's the need of us putting
out attitudes to get and I appreciate
what homies logic is doing getting high
school students involved in
bioinformatics I want to play with romis
logic you could step down such program
for high school I was really excited to
see those who won you know you know you
know who won prizes for you know the
Symposium we could step down trainings
for high school
for high school students for high school
students is high time we get to
introduce you know high school students
to buy a phone you know to buy
informatics when I was in
15 years ago when I was in high school
it was just it was just like a form of
peer pressure my my colleagues were
choosing medicine uh medicine
engineering we didn't know what wanted
to use the profession you know this this
career Pursuits this career you know
this disciplines fall but when we come
in to introduce you know high school
students to bioinformatics as an early
stage it's going to help them create
that interest we need to build
innovators we need to build we need to
build a team of people who can think at
early stage to provide solution
to provide solution and that's why I
want to plead with
that's why I want to plead with um I
every organization represented here let
us invest in bioinformatics let's invest
in bioinformatics at least biology is
doing well I don't say
um I I really love the interest the
enthusiasm of you know students and
young professionals to buy informatics
but we are we have limited Research
Institute we have limited you know you
know training outfits that can provide
this
reinformatics you know you know training
I think as organizations we also need to
invest also in um in you know train the
trainer courses training trainer courses
you know we could develop research clubs
mathematics research clubs in advance
universities you know to get people you
know to get people aware about
bioinformatics these are things we need
to look in these are things we need to
look at and I look forward when we are
done with our research so as a you know
to assess the level of awareness or
bioinformatics educational
students and graduate students we're
going to be able to share with ourselves
we're gonna come in you know supposedly
to provide you know Solutions which are
evidence-based and how to be able and
how to make it evidence basis when we
get in data
is anyone there
hi
I'm able to hear you
yeah
[Music]
maybe you can change your position
what do you say
your voice is breaking I think for like
30 seconds we go
30 seconds ago okay I said
I I
okay I said I I I said um if there are
questions let's feel free to ask
questions so I can I I can reply if
there any questions I'm here to answer
questions but I promise to get a slide
so we could go through you know some
links you could you know get across to
us yeah over to you moderator
yeah is anybody here
hello is anyone there
yes
[Music]
okay
okay you you could feel free to ask what
thank you very much Emmanuel for the uh
insightful talk so if anyone from the
participants are uh you know having any
kind of queries or something
they can please unmute themselves and
they can ask the speaker directly
be free to ask any kind of question
[Music]
okay till then I have received a few
queries from the participant so the
first query Emmanuel uh is what
essential suggestions can be proposed
aspiring researchers pursuing a career
in bioinformatics and seeking to join
Helix biogen's team in Africa
[Music]
essential suggestions I would say uh one
of
um we have omis logic here and I really
appreciate what Thomas logic is doing
and
um only logic as I know uh provides
intensive virtual internship research
Fellowship you could really gain skills
there take up online courses and buy
4matics
um you could take up courses in um
online courses then I also advise you
could also seek him you know
um
and so on like how would I put it you
could seek in internships like Ellie's
Biogen you know gives him internship
both online internship and physical and
in-person internship so I'm going to be
sharing in when I will share my slide
I'm going to be putting in you could
just get into our website at least
biology could just browse it out
um
you could see options to join
internships logic also provides such
internships so you could you could get
in another Beauty another beautiful
thing I would say is
um
and I I see that you know Miss logic I
know it's Biogen they have Community you
could belong to community no
aspiring researchers or Professionals in
bioinformatics please joining those
communities in those communities maybe
join their you know their social media
Pages join platforms that this community
is built on like WhatsApp
um they could share you know in you'll
find out in those communities you find
you know opportunities shared you could
find Opportunities to you know to to
collaborate to network with other
inspiring you know
um
Young Folks Professionals in
bioinformatics then thirdly get a mentor
get the mentor I know we've been all
here today you know listening to since
yesterday we'll be listening to you know
you know Wonderful speakers they've
shared in their LinkedIn profiles
connect with them
connect with them connect with them you
know they conventor you they could
Mentor you so um currently at least
biology
Institute runs a campus aboard
stewardship program which we are going
to be opening again this year George
um follow us on our social media
platforms
I'm going to be sharing that with us
here so when do such a campus about the
ship or um training is out
um on our on our social media spaces you
could you could join you could join you
could join
I think I've answered this question I
have a community
join a community of you know or a
bioinformatics community have a good
Mentor Patrick in trainings not just
getting yourself trained go for and son
get yourself involved in projects
there's a base of you seeking in
knowledge and as a place of applying
those Knowledge and Skills and that is
what I love about omis logic that's what
I love about Ellis biology we put in the
skills we will help you put in the
skills you've learned in by formatting
because if you don't apply by
informatics looks abstract if you're not
finding yourself if you're not finding
if you don't find yourself using those
skills you've got things
you find yourself not being productive
you could forget those things you've
learned so go for go for trainings that
will put you on projects
thank you
okay uh yeah uh so yeah uh Emmanuel well
said so there's one more question uh
from one of our participants and the
question is what are the different
strategic research initiatives
that would help address challenges
associated with computational Biology in
Africa so I'll repeat the question once
again uh what are the different
strategic research initiatives that
would help address challenges associated
with computational Biology in Africa
hello uh can you hear me Manuel
so could you please tell us some
different strategies like a research
initiative strategies which may be Helix
Biogen is using so as to spread more
about computational biology involve as
many people who are interested in
bioinformatics or data science and uh to
get start with their research or get
start with their career in this
particular field so any strategy which
comes into your mind and you would like
to share with the participant here in
symposium
okay I I missed I missed that question
could you could you go my network went
off okay no problem I'll just repeat
once again
so the question is what are the
different strategic research initiatives
that would help address
challenges associated with computational
Biology in Africa
so I guess the participant wants to ask
like are there any research initiative
or are there any kind of strategy which
Helix Biogen as an Institute is
following uh so as to address as many
challenges which uh like a African
participant or a student might face so
as to get uh you know kick start with
the career in bioinformatics or data
science or any other domain
okay what comes into my mind
um one
of the things that is biology is doing
to to help you know young young
professionals and students start up a
kind by 4matics currently we we are
affiliated with
um and a with a university in Nigeria
called precious Cornerstone where we
offer diploma program because currently
in Nigeria and even Africa as as a
continent we just have few universities
that offer bioinformatics at
undergraduate undergraduate level we
have you know a couple of few War files
it's that um
um also at Masters level so what we do
at this stage we we run into internship
we also run postgraduate diplomas
where
um where we you know with Affiliated
um you know
um um what would I call it Affiliated
universities to provide these trainings
for you know students and young people
then another thing again is um history
bionet facial bio net which is a top I
don't know many of us know about this is
the top um bioinformatics capacity
building platform in Africa and is
resided in University of Cape Town
uh we also the what atrial bionic does
is to host you know
periodically trainings in bioinformatics
so we also um they give room to
collaborate with with research
Institutes
to serve as classrooms
towards this training this train needs
to go in an average span of time of um
three to four months so we run those
trainings and it's free and it's free
then organizations like almost logic we
also partner with homies logic to also
get through you know the African
populates but when it comes to uh I
think what we need to do is to um for
Africans I mean Research Institute is
for us to Advocate and make awareness
for bioinformatics maybe we should well
I I would suggest if we have other
African organizations on the call we
need to you know sit up and make propose
us
for you know universities to buy into
their idea to run by informatics as uh
as an undergraduate degree but even
providing even running by informatics as
another graduate degree how many
trainers do we have
how many people have you know their
Advanced degrees in bioinformatics so
there's a need for us to you know push
push you know push
um push that advocacy that our cases to
help many institutions run by
informatics you know training both out
on a graduate and postgraduates I know I
have a university here in Nigeria I
don't know if I'm many of us know
Covenant University it is a faith-based
university and
um they run by informatics at Masters
and PhD and they're giving scholarship
so you could check Covenant University
uh the bioinformatics research lab you
run you know uh master's degree programs
for uh uh for for bioinformatics and
this comes with scholarship
also University of Cape Town does that
too you could you could you could do you
could you know get involved in that but
first you could build your skills
without having this Advance you could
build that knowledge and excuse in by
informatics without even having an
advanced skill yeah that's what I have
to say thank you
thank you Emmanuel
and
if you have any more questions you can
please put in the chat so that the man
with an address
and I would now like to welcome Dr Gus
kasovich
Dr Gus good morning good morning so
uh before you start with your talk I
would like to introduce you Dr casulas
is a professor of biology and by
technology in the department of
pathopiological Sciences and he's the
director of the division of
biotechnology and molecular medicine
he's the director of NIH funded Center
in experimental infectious disease
research I'm the director of the NIH
funded Louisiana biomedical research
Network for molecular and cell biology
has extensively utilized viral vectors
for vaccine development and cancer
treatment his other research interests
lie in the structure and function of
proteins and glycoproteins we use our
virus-like particles for drug delivery
bioinformatics and the development of
new drugs to combat infectious diseases
we are pleased to have you amongst us
over to you
okay great uh let me share my screen
um
let's see where are we here
it's probably this one
can you see my slides
yes we can see we can slides uh we can
see our computer
screen let me see now
how about now
yeah we can see okay all right uh so
hello everybody
um I guess depending where you are
morning or afternoon or evening
um as uh indicated
um the director of
um the
um divisional biotechnology molecular
medicine department head here there is
your school of learning medicine and I'm
also the principal investigator of the
Louisiana biomedical research Network
which is funded by uh NIH the National
Institute General Medical Sciences has a
priority and mandatory priority to
promote data science and bioinformatics
in the state of Louisiana
so I'm just gonna touch
um a few topics here
um just more of descriptive I'm not
going to go into high-end uh data
science in bioinformatics that's
probably a different talk but I will
discuss uh some of the initiatives that
NIH has started relating to data Science
and Mathematics and then tell you how
the uh nepi which is a national uh
Association of idea principal
investigators that represents um
23 States in Puerto Rico that have
similar programs there is a one of those
major grants per state with a mandatory
focus on data science and bipomatics and
we all work together and we do have
Regional meetings there are four
Regional meetings the southeastern
regional meeting is in Charleston South
Carolina uh September 14-17 and the
original meetings in three other areas
of the states uh the southeastern
regional meeting in college in
Charleston South Carolina
will be also the regional data science
and bioinformatics conference for the
seven states that represented Puerto
Rico Louisiana Arkansas Mississippi West
Virginia and South Carolina so we're
going to be there in September and it
will be a two-day data science about
Advantage conference in addition to what
are we doing for the national meeting
December 12th through 14 we had the
national uh idea uh Symposium for
biomedical Excellence with 1500 people
attending uh there was a remote virtual
conference across the entire network of
24 States uh and there was a lot that um
information that was transmitted from
NIH as well as other
researchers from undergraduates to
graduates to principal investigators to
clinical translational people a lot of
that having to do with data management
and bioinformatics so let me begin then
by
um uh obviously uh I think we live in an
era where data science and
bioinformatics are extremely important
and it is exponentially the need for
bioinformaticians that understand also
biology is acute and is exponentially
growing for currently as well as in the
future so that really created it's a
bioinformatics on demand
having a need to train high school
students undergraduates and Beyond in
understanding data Science and
Mathematics principles so obviously
because of the genome Human Genome
Project there was the Optics Revolution
that everybody's familiar and that
includes genomes proteomes
transcriptomes epigenetics Comics
whatever omics we're not talking about
metabolomics and
in addition to transcriptomics and
proteomics epigenome epigenetics
carbohydrate databases as well as
metabolomics now and all of those are
really deposited in huge databases and
all the big
issue right now is that we don't have
people that are knowledgeable how to
access that those databases and even to
compare the databases for instance if
you have a database that relates to
genomes for cancer and I had a database
for people that are involved in diabetes
or you know any other issue how could
you could cross-mind those databases
to uh produce uh in in Silicon results
of what may be co-morbidity parameters
and things like that so we live in an
evolution in a uh very interesting era
where bioinformatics is essential
um the challenge is to have a proper
genomia notation uh sequence assemblies
physical mapping there's a lot that's
been done now with protein structure and
function uh as you know Alpha fold is a
major program out there that now uh
fairly accurately predicts the structure
of specific proteins based on the amino
acid sequence and pre-existing
information on databases that allows you
then to
um model how proteins interact with each
other supportive interactions to find
binding motifs to look in the
transcriptional and postal exceptional
regulation histal modification
methylation and ultimately helping a
drug Discovery so bioinformatics depends
on a lot of databases some of the be
more classical the bases you see here
genbank ebl blast and then all
algorithms for height through throughout
data analysis have been created so one
of the most important things right now
is this this
um uh fact that we have uh at tremendous
amount of information trillions of buys
of information into specific databases
and those would be generalized that
include DNA protein couple hair
structure 3D structures and so on as
well as specialized databases that
relate to Estes SDS snps RNA genomes
protein families Pathways microwave data
so the bigger challenge right now is how
do we train our people
to access those data work with them find
things of interest to their specific
project or interest and then how do you
cross check or cross-utilize platforms
and databases together uh to come up
with a potential uh biomarkers of any
kind relating to a disease specific
disease aspect in fact DNA is
recognizing this just opened an
opportunity for people to get major
grants R1 grants not necessarily doing
anything else but really combining
databases and querying them for specific
outcomes so no wet lab work no
laboratory really if you're really good
at it you're a computer person and
you'll be able to look at databases you
could actually get a major in ice Grant
so um in terms of over your databases uh
database indexing specification Search
terms becomes important archiving uh the
uh all this data that are generated by
uh next-gen sequencies facilities and
getaways to archives exist now as you
know with ncbi Andre PubMed Xbox C Swiss
prod a lot of them that all of us on a
daily basis were using to query or other
um uh DNA
um and protein or structures even no
proteins themselves
so um among these generalized DNA
protein carbohydrate databases for
examples we have the embl uh with the
nuclear sequence the genbank that
everybody's familiar with and the the
ddbj the DNA data back in Japan and
there are a bunch of other ones in
Europe as well as in Japan and elsewhere
and uh this is an example the ncbi for
the national Center of mathematical
information everybody hopefully is
familiar with this it's free to
everybody regardless whether where you
are in the world and it was established
in 1988 and is a it's a public database
and it's very tremendous store for
computational biology and they're also
developing software tools for analyzing
genome data and disseminating biomedical
information uh all that for the goal for
a better understanding of molecular
processes affecting human health and
disease uh Xboxes and other uh expert
protein analysis system that's available
and widely used
um uh by a lot of the researchers and of
course the generalized DNA protein
carbohydrate databases
um there's only just a sample of what
exists out there so if you actually
Google for databases for bioinformatics
you can see a lot of them you can also
go to the central Disease Control they
have a lot of clinical and other
databases as well as the NCI National
Cancer Institute or nyad allergic
infectious diseases and they will point
you to databases of information they
have for viruses bacteria cancer
parameters and so on
so um again for carbohydratabases cloud
bank is an example 3D structures so you
have the pdb protein Data Bank here bar
CSP in the US the ab MSD uh the UK the
NDB which is uh driver's University as
well as others so the question is you
have this now trillion of informational
bytes and we have all these huge
databases and if you really look at the
number of databases that include cancer
data obesity data diabetes data
um all sorts of disparities data the
bigger issue is you know how do we
harness all this information to our to
be able to understand uh how disease
progresses and ultimately how do we use
and harness this information to go from
omics to system biology and then from
bench to bedside to be able to really
come up with new methodologies and
approaches to three disease uh from data
really to knowledge
um and ultimately this would lead to
computational system biology which is an
acute need whatever we call
translational mathematics and bio
knowledge engineering to be able to
really engineer Things based on
information that you could Garner in
silico uh where that would be modeling
3D structures or proteins so working on
more sophisticated algorithms
to make sense of signaling Pathways you
know when it starts and what is first
second third then how does the cell
response to specific uh stimuli so um
where is that going I'll give you an
example of that and we had in our recent
bioinformatics conference uh I guess
actually it was last year we had
um the opportunity to have Michael
Snyder who is the chair of the
Department of genetics at Stanford
Medical School and he's the founder of
qbio and this is just a picture of the
cube bio and the vision for cubaio is to
uh um to be able to generate new ways to
diagnose and ultimately treat disease
and what they're doing in essence uh you
know I'll show a couple slides on that
is really combining the plethora of
clinical data Imaging data MRI for
instance
with uh genomic transcriptional polyamic
metabolomic data and the goal is to
establish a digital twin of you
um in fact I'm hoping to get down there
and do my own scan at some point uh it
cost about three thousand dollars to do
it right now I think it's going to get
cheaper in the long run so basically by
developing a digital twin you can
combine all these huge data that are
really personal to you uh use artificial
intelligence then to come up with an
understanding of what's your clinical
status
um potentially predict the age of your
specific organs point to potential
problems that may arise that would in
essence lead into a prevention strategy
for you know develop specific diseases
that you may be at risk so um this is
another uh picture of their website
um they're doing uh a physical of the
future which is basically a combination
of Imaging MRI and all of that to be
able to build a comprehensive picture of
the health and how it's changing over
time and that includes all the clinical
samples whether it would be blood
samples urine clinical data that you
have uh which is already done at their
labs in addition to Imaging and also the
genomics transcriptomics and everything
else beyond that and the ultimate plan
is to create the uh a genomic twin a a
digital twin
of any patient and this is a really a
primary example of how big data that
have been collected and now personalized
because all these data refer to Big
databases or risk factors identifying
specific genes of interest and so on so
it's actually the artificial
intelligence is looking at those
databases comparing your data and
predicting what may or may not be wrong
with a specific patient or what may be a
ways things that need to be watched As
you move forward you know in life
so I want to announce shift gears uh I
just wanted to just give you a sort of a
sense of this importance of personalized
health and how these big databases and
really
um sort of what uh underlying this need
for understanding how to access
databases uh user databases compare
these databases work with cloud
computing to be able to understand and
deliver for specific biomarkers and
ultimately new therapies so I want to
also explain the idea program from
National Health so the institutional
development award idea was established
in 1993 from NIH to broaden the
geographic distribution of a nice
funding for biomedical behavioral
research the major observation was that
practically 80 percent of all the United
funding was going to three or four
states so NIH wanted to try to incur
it's people from states that were not as
competitive with those three or four top
states to be able to promote biomedical
research so the uh a program Fosters
health related research and enhances the
competitiveness of investigators of
Institutions located in States in which
the aggregate success rate Publications
and IH has historically been known and
the program also serves unique
populations such as Rural and medically
and reserved communities in these states
so
um this is an older Slide the 2022 it
was a location of NH is about
410 million
um and uh is approximately or close to
one percent of the total NIH budget and
through our non-profit organization
we're trying to uh help NIH decide to
increase this uh figure even more
um ultimately reaching at least uh 1.5
percent of the NH budget
so um this is this funding that goes in
comparison to the total Finance funding
to different states you can see here uh
in Louisiana for instance that there
were 24 million dollars of idea Awards
out of a total Awards of uh 209 uh
Million by the next seven other states
as you can see for instance North Dakota
the major funding for them easily comes
through the idea program and it's kind
of very important because this uh
funding that comes from this program is
actually a crucial factor in generating
more income and more competitive funding
because of funding of the graduation
from these funding to people that are
independently funded and can compete
with traditional NIH funding
so uh these are the five idea funding
programs the centers of Biometrics is
excellence and these are funds for new
faculty hiring and flexibility for
research project leaders uh the
graduation from here is obtaining an R1
an independent Awards the Embry uh is uh
24 active Awards 24 States 23 Puerto
Rico I'm the Pio one of these Awards
Embry award here in Louisiana and one of
the most important things that's
developed right now in Ephesus in Hebrew
is to really promote cloud computing
training uh through Google and Amazon
through specific arrangements with
Google and Amazon we also have the idea
ctrs that are what we call Mini ctsas
Clinica translational research centers
and those
um fund basic science and translational
science uh trying to train Physicians
and others to be able to do biomedical
research but ultimately Translating that
to their bedside
we also part of this program is
co-funding so if you really have an R1
and R15 understand
application for equipment you could
receive co-funding even if you're not
within the funding range of the
categorical Institute there are also
Regional technology transfer
accelerators all of them and those
really are now co-funded by the SBI CTL
program through all the categorical
institutes and has pilot programs for
teaching business fundamentals for
technology core directors as well as
also sitting
other projects that relate to the
development of patented Technologies and
so on
so um they also collaboration is a
participation in ihy initiative so the
nngms program is now co-funded um up to
um 50 million or so from other
categorical institutes and that relates
to
um having supplements to the Embrace to
and to Foster collaborations between
Cobra ctrs and now there are one funded
investigators collaborations with
non-idnh programs and this is some of
the examples here with the maternity
maternal infant mortality research uh
the covid-19 patient registry and of
course the cloud computing for medical
research which is the NIH initiative
it's called strides that involves Google
Amazon cloud computing there's also
competing in nice viruses including the
active trials for covid-19 Therapeutics
and vaccines and the rapid acceleration
of diagnostics for undeserved
populations the Radix Up Programs so
these all the categorical institutes are
really involved now you in managing and
supporting the idea program beyond the
funds that the idea program really has
available
so I just want to touch based on some of
the efforts and i8s relating to cloud
computing this is the strides program
for cloud computing Partnerships so
um this part of this uh Google cloud and
Amazon there's a free Cloud credit for
research there's a diagnostic
development initiative and eligibility
investigators from any uh part of the
idea program can apply and resolve an
application
um uh that trained a number of people
last year there's some of the examples
of participation from idea programs we
had
participants from Louisiana State
University and they worked in remote
training or Cloud platform users at the
media level more advanced people
Advanced developers and also the
infrastructure developers so these
people up to 500 students have already
enrolled in these three programs for
Idea Idea states to learn how how to do
cloud computing and use databases so
um The Embers themselves are Statewide
networks for research intensive
institutions and we actually help
primarily undergraduate institutions
community colleges and traveling control
colleges to provide them with research
opportunities so
um we have a developmental core we have
a very robust summer program uh here in
Louisiana which is co-founded by the
Regina Board of Regents this is the
administrative core and we have a data
science called a molecular cell
biological that we have here in the
brain I'll explain about that but really
the intense need right now is to teach
undergraduates in data science and
bioinformatics and we have a number of
initiatives where we started and we have
a very robust summer program that will
bring over 100 people here in Belarus to
actually learn on some of the basis of
high performance Computing access to
cloud computing as well as also
brain in molecular cell biology as part
of the molecular cell biology core that
our program has so um enabling cloud
computing at the institutions through
Embrace a uh specific directive of these
programs so cloud computing can provide
students investigators access to high
performance Computing and modern data
science tools without heavy Capital
Investments by institutions so it's a
very inexpensive especially for the idea
Network so the embryo where these are
collaborating with an ngms the office of
data science and the lead the way to
expand access to data science tools and
skill sets the idea is to provide basic
cloud computing training develop Cloud
tools for self-learning and demonstrate
the benefits of using the cloud
and a part of this interactive training
on cloud fundamentals they were 48
classes on 2021 and I think an equal
number in 2022 through more than 60
sessions by Google or Amazon
um and we've had a beginner the
intermediate and the advanced sessions
and these are the number of students
that participated with many Embry
investigators students and faculty
participating
so um they also uh nigms is through
these programs develops building
cloud-based learning modules and I
suspect those modules would be free to
everybody I haven't checked uh whether
you need the password I think most
likely uh right now the energy MSI will
be available for everybody so the idea
is to get curriculum developed by the
idea apis uh then transfer them to
Engineers to a three-month Professional
Service engagement and convert these
training materials into cloud-based
workflows so there's an outside call now
for developing this curricula tools to
be able to use create instructional
videos interactive demos and practice
exercises but the idea is to train the
trainer so the General Medical Sciences
energy MS support investigators can gain
program skills ultimately develop
cloud-based training materials to teach
others
so this is the energy Ms sandbox this is
an earlier slide I think some of these
boxes now have been filled so they have
developed by an edge strides Basics
cloud computing Google Amazon which is
available Mass Spec data analysis from
Universal articles Medical Center uh
which is the original Center rna-seq
analysis from University of Maine and my
DBL and of course a bunch of other
things including some of the modules and
trainings that we actually have
available here that are facilitated by
um the pine about tech
modules and also the pineapple tech
software analysis that we have in place
here as part of our magazine sequencing
core
so these are some of the uh modules that
are available and all these modules at
some point will be uploaded
um or linked to our nippy website that
I'll tell you later but it's
fundamentals of bioinformatics uh you
can see
um a more specialized ones uh or biofilm
microbiome composition
biomarket Discovery proteomics and these
are really modules that will be
available on cloud and will be access
accessible for people to be able to work
their data through them
I also wanted to mention I'm not sure
how many people hear from
um uh you know smaller universities here
in the US but um one of the programs has
been developed is the er16 or sure
program and that allows for for uh you
know uh any campus that serves
underrepresented or social
socio-economic kind of students who
apply for Grants and the only
requirement is that they have 25 percent
or or more of Pell Grants which is
really the financial support grants how
much time do I have who is my guess my
administrator here I'm not sure what was
the time allocated for this anyway so
let me go forward to tell you a bit
about nappy nappy is the National
Association of idea principal
investigators a non-profit group
representing the 24 States part of the
program actually the Navy website is
operated by Pine biotech right now and
the idea is through nappy to really make
all these resources available free of
charge to at least the idea Network and
so we have an active call for people
that have developed algorithms or
software or lectures to be uploaded and
be able to be available to an every
website and this is the uh the idea
Network you see the states that are part
of the energy Ms idea Network that
started off in 2000 by the national
Center for research resources and then
ultimately moved to the National
Institute of General Medical Sciences
is the nappy leadership I I just
departed as a president but I'm part of
the executive committee as a past
president and then Scott Seville is now
the new president of nappy and we're in
the process of assigning a couple more
officers uh hopefully by the end of next
month
so that's the neighbor's mission to
provide leadership communication we want
to force the interaction with my idea
programs we want to share resources
enhance the visibility of these 24
States
develop consensus or priorities in the
directions and to identify disseminate
best practices and to identify
opportunities develop strategies to
achieve the common goals like again all
the Embry Network at least and is
focusing a lot now through energy Ms or
cloud computing data science and
bioinformatics uh and this is the nebi
website uh netbeat.org that you're
welcome to look into this and see if you
uh
um can uh find more information or you
can share information for us to be able
to upload it
and through nappy we were able to uh
sponsor uh different omic Symposium this
back in 2021 uh we actually have a bunch
of other activities that were sponsored
through nebi that was facilitated
through pionba Tech and the AmEx lexic
issue we're also very fortunate to get a
uh uh support from the Tober foundation
and we provided uh cash Awards to our
nisbee national meeting and we also
cover some expenses uh going into the 24
and 26 meetings they need to be the
national meeting will be in Washington
DC most likely likely in Washington
Hilton in 2024-26 is organized by LSU
I'm the Episcopal investigator of that
conference and typically you know over a
thousand people that come into
Washington DC from this 24 states to
share the results and their experiences
so I wanted to move very quickly to
Louisiana and this is the Louisiana
biomedical research Network website
you're welcome to visit here there's a
lot of information including training as
well as the omics training that we
provide together with plan about tech in
this particular website uh so it's ldrn
if you Google lbrm you'll be able to
find it and then a couple highlights we
have for instance this cell brn religion
Optical Network initiative scientific
Computing bootcamp we're going to be
expanding it this summer we hope to have
up to 100 people
um coming into Baton Rouge from
undergraduate institutions to be trained
in Computing as part of this boot camp
as well as other boot camps that we'll
be sponsoring and this is uh the flyer
that we had with Michael Snyder as a
keynote speaker we have Christopher
Mason who also uses this combination of
data to understand the biology and
health of astronauts very similar to
what Michael science and I do but as
well as able to write from Southeast
Louisiana University which is in part of
biological sciences but as a
computational biologist and a few others
of notable speakers
so Obama's classic is the other activity
that we promote uh through Pineville
Tech and through biomedaging lab we have
over 50 students enrolled right now uh
taking these virtual courses and what we
hope to do is develop courses in every
Pui campus 2627 institutions in
Louisiana that have their own course
which is enriched by some of the modules
that we provide and support through lbrn
so uh for instance this year the Albion
lecture series of molecular structure
and functional proteins this is
available through our bioinformatics
score and it has an introduction to
computers introduction to microbial
community and this is free could be
tapped into and listened to
um through that in addition to the
modules that the AmEx platform provides
so with that
um I'm not sure how much time was
allocated uh but um this is the LSU main
campus with a football stadium and uh if
anybody of you are around here welcome
to visit with us and learn more about
our programs and I will leave it at that
and I'll return to um to our moderator
thank you so much Dr Gus
so
uh you discussed about the programs that
students can leverage from I just wanted
to know like where can they find the
research and the internship or the job
opportunities and buy our information
data science after taking up these
programs because that is one of the
major concerns of students
yeah well you know it depends where you
are right the U.S there's a lot of
opportunities for advanced study and a
lot of opportunities
for actual job if I understand your
question correctly you're looking for
job opportunities
yes yeah so basically
um part of the Navy we intend to post
um you know job opportunities it hasn't
happened yet but I think it will happen
uh quite soon and then
um if you really contact all these
programs in those 24 States all of them
have opportunities for you know
undergraduates graduate students um
potentially other people from outside
that may want to come in uh to get
trained but uh because it's academic
programs we're focusing on people that
are enrolled in undergraduate
institutions
um here in the US we have an expanded
program internationally
um but a lot of the content that we
create uh through NIH or through nappy
or through the individual Embry programs
in state is actually available for
people uh free of charge in most
instances the actual training to come
here
for instance the the proteomics center
in Arkansas receives probably over 50
students uh per year that they train
them for Mass Spec and proteomic
Analysis and that's by application
acceptance and then you go over there
for like the summer a couple months to
get trained
um so there are a lot of opportunities
even for Internationals at NIH and all
those centers but we don't have a single
Source where all these job opportunities
are available
that was very helpful thank you Dr
casserness and do we have any questions
from the participants you can put them
in the chat or maybe a new desktop and
ask
all right if not then I would extend my
uh thanks to Dr casula's for taking out
his time for uh The Talk today and uh
with that I would like to now proceed
ahead with our next speaker
so our next speaker is Dr Jamie and Dr
Jamie are you here with us
hi
all right so before passing on the stage
to Dr Jamie I would like to introduce
him uh Dr Jaime is the next Generation
sequencing coordinator for the center of
excellence in emerging animal and
genotic diseases and uh the center on
emerging in genotic infectious diseases
at Kansas State University he is an
expert in genomics and previously
coordinated the SARS scope of genomic
surveillance efforts of Sao Paulo state
to develop and apply ngs-based tools for
the detection and the study of emerging
animals and generic viruses as well as
their interaction with natural host
vectors and animal models along his
career Dr NATO has secured around dollar
1.7 million in competitive grants and
authored over 35 peer-reviewed
Publications including articles in
finance nature
microbiology science and journal of
medical biology you're pleased to have
you with us Dr James
hey thank you very much
um let me see how to share my screen
here
can you all see my uh screen yes we can
thank you excellent
okay so um can you hear me well if not
please just uh let me know in the chat
I guess we can all looks good so thank
you very much for uh the invitation to
be here this uh early afternoon with you
talking to you about
the research in the application and how
we use net generation sequencing uh in
our
um uh NGS core here at uh the veterinary
school at Kansas State University so
thank you very much it's an honor to be
here and I hope you can have like
fruitful discussions uh after that
so um
okay
just a brief overview of what I'm going
to be addressing
um uh today so the focus of our Center
is on uh we have two centers here I'm
going to be focusing on the especially
on the service that is provided through
our uh Cobra Center NIH Cobra Center
that we call the center of on emerging
and zoonotic uh infectious diseases but
I'm going to give you an overview brief
overview on uh on on the applications on
emerging in uh animal ends on Arch
infectious diseases and then how uh you
can use NGS for epidemiology and
research and the NGS initiatives and
service that are provided through the
core in examples two examples of
research that uh we develop here in that
leverage on the NGS service that we can
provide so I'm going to be talking in
the end about source code 2 uh research
and also afghan's fine fever virus
research here
foreign
so uh starting with uh a mix of animal
diseases and uh zoonotic animal diseases
uh the importance of studying these
diseases I mean is this especially
nowadays uh with uh sarskov chew
emerging from animal to humans it has
become a very uh clear
um uh uh the link between all this uh
this ecosystem but um of course we know
that uh we have diseases that are
particular to animals this is that
affects a livestock for example that uh
our problem uh to to food production for
example and uh but also know and these
are animal diseases but then we also
consider you have to consider the
possibility of diseases that can jump
from one animal to another and then some
species of any Mouse can act as
intermediates or amplifier after of
those pathogens and those pathogens they
can eventually jump from those animals
to humans and cause disease in humans so
this is what we called
sonoric diseases disease that can uh
jump from animals to humans for example
and cause this cause disease uh in uh in
in humans so we focus uh here at Kansas
State University in our centers in both
animal diseases and uh zoonotic uh
disease so this is very important for
livestock food production for example
animal biosecurity and also diseases
that can uh jump from animal to humans
and that humans animals can be for
example reservoir for those issues that
can affect humans so
um and I'm gonna show you how we can
leverage on NGS to better understand
diseases and also to create uh generate
tools to to monitor or to better study
those pathogens uh and just exemplify
here also that some of those diseases
can also be uh
transmitted not only by direct contact
between uh animals and humans but also
by uh Vector species
so just to give an idea more than half
or roughly 70 percent of all uh the
infections uh that people can get are
zoonotic or they can spread between
animals and any people so this is very
concerning because uh we are in contact
with animals all the time
so
um how can we use NGS in this case uh to
get us better prepared and uh ahead of
time uh for an early response because
that's what we want ultimately to be
prepared to provide an early response in
the case of an outbreak or uh of the
episode of an emerging pathogen so uh
the idea here is that we can use Next
Generation sequencing uh
workflows and data to promote uh for
example syndromic surveillance we can uh
survey different parts of the world and
in in material and and and
species for the for for pathogen
discover or to the surveillance of
non-pathogens and we can use that uh to
see what's happening and uh and what are
the pathogens that are circulating or
are emerging and then from that you can
go if you know those patches you can go
from there to a local surveillance
standpoint and then you can see in
different niches in different species in
different Ambience and uh
in different compartments uh the
presence of those virus or the uh the
rise of of emerging virus so you can
check the environment Wildlife for
example uh those domestic animals uh
Sentinel populations in patients for
those uh for for those uh Target uh
pathogens and with that develop uh right
rapid response actions uh to to to fight
or to mitigate the spread of such
diseases so this is a very interesting
model where we can use Next Generation
sequence to uh to fight or to better
understand the spread the transmission
Dynamic of such diseases but in order to
implement that besides many uh uh
complex factors uh some of them that we
that we still have to work and and to
improve our the tools that we currently
have for sequencing and when I say two I
say sequencers portable sequencers uh
optimization optimization of protocol
costs
um
workflows and viewinformatic uh
pipelines for example and through put if
you're talking about preparedness
surveillance we think of this as a
global uh or a large scale activity and
then most of times these actives are
limited by the throughput of the
currently available
techniques so I should include also
portability here
so I'm gonna give you uh from now an
overview on the potential MGS
applications in a Veterinary health
research some of them that we do here or
we have the potential to do here
so for example we can use them for
pathogen characterization and genomic
surveillance as I mentioned before to
study the uh
discovery of the emergence of a new
pathogens uh
to work to discover or to monitor
natural Reservoir reservoirs to infer
about uh uh you know investigate these
pullovers when the the virus for example
uh spills from animals to humans or
spill bags when you have transmission
back from humans into animals and also
choose this information at the
characterization of pathogens in the
genome level to improve diagnostic
diagnostic tools that we currently have
or are developing
other applications that can leverage uh
Next Generation sequencing of course
our host Vector pathogen interactions so
you can use that for studying host
responses viral hose adaptations and so
many others like uh
therapeutic Target identification virus
genome Evolution and characterization
and of animal models
um classic utilization in the veterinary
health and research is not one of the
the main folks we have here which is a
population genomics for improvement of
livestock genetic genetics uh
identification of genomic uh signatures
and also uh foreign
livestock uh for example uh production
um and also wanting for another
important a very important component uh
it's been gaining lots of attention and
momentum nowadays with uh with uh uh
especially with food security and uh
antimicrobial resistance is the study of
microbial genomics where you can
investigate
a specific bacteria or microorganisms or
or the the the animal microbiome uh
meant to understand better understand a
microbial resistant or that is very
common uh to monitor what you call the
the resistor more uh the bacteria the
code the collection of bacteria they're
resistance to antibiotics in that resign
of those animals for example and also
but not only that but also and uh it
studies on animal metabolism immune
response Cincinnati malnutrition
so
um
so those are some of the applications in
Veterinary Health here in our core
we are in shape to contribute to that
research
through uh uh complete or diverse
repertoire of
um of an ngs-based techniques so
basically the most common ones
that we have implemented and offer and
and and and use for uh for service and
research here uh and they go from whole
genome sequencing
um viral metagenomics uh targeted
amplification
Target amplicon sequencing
rna-c gene expression and both a bulk
whole transcript atomics and also on a
single cell level in 16s uh microbial
genomics and not only in the
implementation of available techniques
related to this but also in uh we are
very open and and look forward to the
development of new workflows new
techniques and devices that can leverage
again to achieve our goal of uh studying
those pathogens or to developing tools
to Monitor and get uh early response
preparedness and every early response
foreign
just to give you an idea of the
portfolio of sequencers that we could
have currently have available uh to our
poor facility
so they go from my seek Illumina my seek
in next seek
and uh Oxford nanopore minion
and those are in-house equipment that we
use uh mice especially for small genomes
uh targeted whole genome sequencing 16s
microbiome and viral
metagenomics we also use a lot next seek
for larger genomes targeted hogenom
sequencing some studies involving rna-6
not in the Single Cell level of course
um
Oxford nanopore is a very versatile uh
equipment especially uh because it
produce long reads and also but one of
the greatest versatility of these
equipment is to be portable so we can
take this uh equipment actually to
biosafe level three Laboratories and
work with virus that cannot be be whose
DNA or RNA for example the play gas
cannot uh be brought out of uh
containment so this is a very uh
convenient and uh and valuable
invaluable to develop protocols for
those viruses uh we also work uh in uh
with uh bio here which is
um especially for a single cell and
larger genomes and implementing it now
for uh this uh protocols and uh
potential for epigenomics so this is
available through our core through our
partner uh Veterinary diagnosis
laboratory and uh
other components our core is the Chrome
and controller which give us ability to
produce libraries for single cell
sequencing
and uh besides the the sequencing
facility is one of the greatest assets
and uh that an advantage of the
Manhattan campus here if we have in our
Center here is that uh um of the the
biocontainment facilities that we have
here which allow us to
um
work as far as work with the virus and
experimentally affected animals and to
reproduce for example clinical aspects
of both subnautic and animal diseases so
we can uh this is a this is a really uh
a great because then we can use NGS for
example to study the evolution of a
virus for example or uh in those animals
in uh in reproducing uh actually the
disease and those animals
so
um with that facility I'd like to show
you some of the viruses that we
currently or in the past we have been
able to work or that we work with so uh
we uh work those are uh high in
containment uh some of DSL tour uh just
say sivs and uh aged ehdv or bsl2 the
other are bsl3 so we have for example
with Valentine referrals starts off to
uh High pathogenic highly pathogenic
Avian Influenza virus they studied that
swine influence Japanese colitis virus
stomatitis virus Africans fine fever
virus and cryptozotic hemorrhagic this
is virus and these are the animal models
that we can use and we currently use to
study uh uh
those diseases both from the the host
pathogen interaction point but also for
the development of Therapies
for of for those diseases
and more recently we have included
monkeypox virus to the portfolio of uh
of pathogens in our in our Center
so today uh I'm gonna show you two
examples of brief examples of uh
research that we do here with uh sarskov
and also with African swine fever virus
so uh the impact of starscope 2 this is
one of the interests of of our Center
here to understand the impact of
sarskov2 in animals use animal models
also to test new therapies against
cyroscope 2 but also to understand the
interaction
uh with the host and the potential of uh
of of of of animals through through
against reservoirs for that so we know
that uh
has jumped from Bots to intermediate
hosts until we reached humans and then
in humans it establishes uh uh even to
human transmission
psycho but we also know in about events
of spielback when the virus jumps from
human back to animals both to domestic
and to Wildlife
and and some of those species can
support uh sustained transmission
between them and and and also
to a low for secondary uh spillovers
into humans and this has a very
important impact especially
um
on vast vaccine efficacy because some of
the mutations that the virus acquire in
these animals can interfere the
functioning of vaccines against them if
humans are infected with those viruses
so it's important from one Health uh
point of view to understand the
inter-special transmission
and also identification and the
understanding and surveillance of those
species as reservoirs
if I show you the an example of research
we're doing here with uh we did here
with uh Fairways fairs are good animal
models for respiratory infections this
isn't also for the development of
therapies so we infected ferrets with a
combination of two
sarskov-2 strains one of the W A ones
that Washington's training is the
ancestral lineage gate virus canal and
together with the California derived
or uh Alpha virus from California so
um and then we observed what happened uh
with those viruses when they were uh
uh uh inoculated uh in in uh
inference so the idea was to observe
transmission is train competition and
not adaptative mutations I'm going to
show you what we have here on Rosary
competition and it's very interesting
when you look at those uh principle
infected animals and we used Next
Generation sequencing to to to to see
which uh variant has infected the animal
and here in ferrets this is our inoculum
where we had about 40 percent uh
Washington and 60 percent
um California is trained as soon as one
day uh
after uh both challenge
California which is an alpha variant
takes out completely out completes
the Washington is trained as soon as one
day and this is the same pattern that we
see on the upcoming days uh after uh
infection so this is this is uh can be
used with any other this approach that
we do here can be used with any other
histrain combination and animal models
that are uh susceptible to uh Cyrus
Cyrus coffee too
and one of the great interests of the
group now to leverage uh NGS whole
genome sequencing of Cyrus Golf 2 is to
understand the genomic landscape of
mutations because we have so many
different animal models and different
strains so we can leverage that to
understand what are the mutations that
the virus is losing or acquiring uh when
it's uh it infects those animals so just
to give an example of what we can do is
to
for example those are the virus that
were in the cell culture from passage
one for passage two uh
so uh this is when we look at the
mutations in the Enviro genome compared
to the reference Genome of Wuhan and
then we see this is the landscape of uh
on passage one and then we see that some
of the mutations start to increase in
passage two and now
uh what we're doing uh uh and we have
done this experiment already where
different groups of uh of ferrets have
been infected with the California
uh Alpha uh uh
strain so not what we're doing is to
track those animals or these animals we
have collect swabs uh oral for Angel
swabs and also
um nasal swabs for example and also
tissues have those after those animals
are necropsis so now what we're doing is
to evaluate uh the viral
adapted imputations in tissue trapezium
of uh of of SARS structure in in those
animals
so um from Cyrus I'd like to switch
gears quickly to show you an example of
uh on our development of uh whole genome
sequencing protocols when workflows in
uh for African swine fever virus
so
um the virus is uh in this case it's a
very large DNA virus a double trended
DNA virus whose genome is around 170 109
kilobases and encodes about 115 165
proteins of this virus from the asphaly
that families are severe is the only
virus of uh actually of this family
and had 24 original times since the only
no DNA carbo virus so it's uh in fact
primarily domestic and wild uh swine
species so they are susceptible but in
the wild they can also infect uh they
can find
in whitehogs Bush pigs even though they
do not develop clinical disease but
they're important as reservoirs but uh
they do cause uh
um can cause acute disease in in
domestic Peaks and this is a huge
problem for uh for the production uh for
production in in the affected countries
and it can also be transmitted by uh
sophistic uh only tolerance
so
um another break of Africans fine fever
can result in large economic losses due
to high mortality and trade Transit
restrictions and granted there's no
available commercial vaccine or
treatment and the diseases risk is
reportable uh to the world uh
organization of animal health and its
consider ausda select agent so just
through the records there's no uh of
concerned fee performance in the United
States currently
so
um this is a distribution so of the
disease in the world it has a spread
all the way from Africa in the early
days to Europe and
um
and to uh southeast Asia and more
recently the disease has reached
the Caribbean Haiti and the Dominican
Republic so it's just knocking on the
door of uh of the United States right
now
um so I'm gonna show you how to use the
Next Generation sequence in here we use
actually two uh identify and isolate
from Mongolia
okay and uh with that we use my seek for
that we use a direct sequencing approach
and the noble assembly in this case and
then using that we were able to assign
this um
this isolate both the inoculum the
original stock that came from tissue and
then the inoculum and you confirmed
there was a genotype to African swine
flu virus uh the problem of using this
approach right now the challenge of
direct sequencing is is a metagenomic
approach so we have most of times lots
of host DNA so host DNA is the majority
of the genome that is going to be
sequenced and then we only get a low
coverage after sequencing so this really
a challenge when you're using uh sample
uh uh your aiming to sequence the virus
that came that comes out of tissue uh or
animal carcasses and so this is an
example of the coverage that we obtain
right now using direct sequencing
and based on that then we started to
develop a protocol for uh uh targeted uh
sequencing of Africa's fine fever virus
so initially we developed a set of 19
primer sets uh each uh set would produce
a 10 KB or 11 10 to 11 KB of the
covering the full Genome of African
spine fever virus of course it's a pain
it should work with 19 different PCR
reactions before you can go uh and then
perform sequencing so uh but even though
working with independent pools we could
get a full coverage of the genome with
an average coverage of 6000 x which is
uh pretty reasonable but then we started
to
optimize uh this uh protocol in order to
reduce the number of the reactions so
what I'm gonna show you now is uh is an
overview of uh several pools that we
developed ultimately we we ended up with
this combination so right now we have uh
four pools of primers that work in
independent reactions and then with that
we can
using minion because we're thinking
about portability here as well
so with the different uh pools like for
example for a
4B red 4C
in yellow and 4D in uh in green we can
we also have 4E uh uh but I don't have
the data to show you right now but if
the combination of this uh one two three
four and now the fifth reaction with 4E
we are able to
cover the whole genome of African swine
fever virus through next Generation
sequencing
and uh with uh
an average coverage now of 6 000 packs
so this is uh running pretty well within
ion and we are also uh working on the
adaptation to
um to Illumina and also to backpack
so uh with this I just would like to
finish with talking about a few of
future directions or future interests
interests that we have so we have a
great interest on Long reads on
developing or other uh protocols uh for
uh long reads whole genome sequencing
and we have good relationships with some
Partnerships already with tech bio and
uh Universal sequencing we as a protocol
for whole genome or for for uh uh
producing
long reads in in Illumina so the idea is
to develop a strong uh Veterinary
health genomics program
and also
uh with the development of portable
Deployable fast Deployable NGS device
and workflows so we're working with this
was important uh University industry
partnership here with novelist and uh
and one of the main things that uh we uh
we we have intention to develop also uh
it's a custom bioinformatic pipelines
and I see a lot also lots of
opportunities for for cooperation and
Partnerships here especially for
pathogen detection direct detection of
both mono and polymicrobial infections
and for viral's uh Evolution and
understandables in pathogens uh
interactions
so with that I would like to thank uh Dr
Reed who is the director of the core and
all the rigged lab especially uh Chester
madal Conor code that are uh Asia there
are mostly involved with the work that I
presented and and with the sequencing
our centers here the school beer eye
biosecro Research Institute USDA their
Partners there and and and other
collaborators that have been uh
important to make this work to help to
happen so uh thank you very much again
for the opportunity and uh I'll be happy
to take questions if you have today
foreign
it was really insightful presentation
from your side uh I have some questions
for you in the chat so uh the first
question is could you share briefly how
you arrived at this topic for your
research
I'm sorry can you repeat the question
I'll try to
yeah could you share briefly how you
arrived at this topic for your research
at this topic of my research well this
is a very interesting question uh my
background is on
vector-borne infectious diseases
so that's how I started about 20-ish
years ago as a as an undergrad in grad
student so my whole uh part of my
academic career was studying that Vector
pathogen interactions then I started
using
um genomics
transcriptomics for example to
understand how factors how pathogens
respond to it to each other and that put
me in close cooperation and also envirus
Discovery emerging virus and that put me
close cooperation with colleagues from
the Manhattan Community like Dr Rick
then that's how I came to K-State here
and then I started uh working on high
consequence biocontainment research and
then I was able to bring my uh Next
Generation sequencing
um expertise to complement uh the
expertise of the group so now I'm using
the next relationship sequencing
cooperation with them to study those
pathogens so that's how uh I ended up uh
doing uh this right now
all right and what challenges did you
and your team face on this project while
going through the procedures for SARS
Kobe 2 and sequencing so are there any
uh difficulties faced by your team
um yes I I can list uh I mean the
greatest challenge is when you don't
have a restaurant a reference genome for
example that is available or when you
don't have uh whole genomic sequencing
protocol in place or a targeted uh whole
genomic sequencing protocol in place and
that in those case you have to develop
everything uh from scratch so if it's
for example novel pathogen or if it's a
non-pathogen but with uh with no
workflow already developed so then you
have to start as we're showing here uh
as the Africans find the fever virus uh
for example and also uh the
bioinformatics uh pipelines you know
because I mean in the laboratory if
you're talking about
um research you can spend time doing the
proper time reasonable time doing the
analysis and with high capacity computer
grids and Etc but if you're talking
about deploy appointment portable
sequencers and response to outbreaks
then those approaches have to be timely
you can't rely on two weeks three weeks
or even two days one day analysis so I
guess the challenge is to develop a
strong reliable and fast bioinformatic
pipelines that can be used to complement
the NGS workflows that we're developing
as well
all right so I guess we have Dr Rich and
Dr Casillas and you from the nepi and I
have one question for like three of you
so what is the central role of a
bioinformatician in the present
biological research and development area
so this is open for all like any one of
you can answer this
I'll get my friend uh Jurgen to take a
first shot at this
thank you Gus
headaches uh we cannot analyze the data
so without bioinformatics we are dead in
the water period
did that answer your question yeah yeah
it's actually
um I think the uh as I try to allude
into uh my presentation is that
ultimately
um
data science and bioinformatics is
extremely important and
um we're really going into the direction
of probably in silico experiments
because part of the idea is you do a lot
of background work and understand a lot
of things before you try to go into an
animal so because you don't want to you
know overuse animals you have to
understand what's going on so
um and I think even with pathogens is
the pathogen host interaction so it's a
two body problem so we don't only need
to understand
um the pathogens but also the hosts and
how the genetics of the host actually
play into this because ultimately
combined data and looking at that would
make sense in the longer run especially
for algebraid species like humans where
basically you don't have the exact same
exact value and I know Dr Rick is
involved in trying to generate resistant
um potential species looking uh to
combine the pathogen cost interaction to
ultimately create maybe new pigs or
whatever would be that would be
resistant to those being edited Gene
edited like she's editing yeah and
that's neat because you need to
understand the interaction before you
could do the gene editing because you
need to know whether you knock out a
receptor or you're doing something very
specific and how the causative response
and I might add gas answer in five
sentences what I needed one for just so
right guys what I might add if we need
very specific bioinformatic approaches
we have collaborators for example we
work on
um bottleneck Transmission bottlenecks
in sasco V2 from what is the bottleneck
in cats what is the bottlenecks neck in
Deer and we work with Jesse Bloom who is
one of the specialists in this country
at the hutch what is Hutch um out in
Seattle Fred Hutch Council Center in
Seattle so if we really need to address
very specific questions which we need
really Specialists we look around and
work that's what's the beauty about
science you don't have to know
everything you have you have to know
your area obviously pretty well but if
you really need to answer very specific
questions and you don't have the
knowledge and in most cases we don't
you go out and collaborate and then you
look for people who have the knowledge
have the algorithms and have to
experience and and that's how we do it
and that's how we work in my Center
which is called says it
all right so like how can one use hybrid
learning for personal development both
conceptually and practical practically
after this breakdown of SARS what we do
uh maybe Dr Jimmy you can answer this
so I will just repeat the question yeah
yeah so how one can use the hybrid
learning for like personal development
both conceptually and practically after
this breakdown of sarskovitu
how can you use the learning that we
have yeah I mean I think one thing that
is clear to us is that uh you have to be
uh uh I I would say this word
preparedness preparedness
you have to know what's circulating and
has the potential to emerge
in order to develop uh mitigation tools
like vaccines like Diagnostics like uh
Therapies in order to control them
so
um from from now from our hour and now
next Generation sequence sequencing for
example whole genome whole genomic
surveillance for example genomic
surveillance you can use that now for uh
to to to file Discovery for example or
agnostic nowadays very common uh it's
emerging important our agnostic uh
threat uh Discovery so where you without
a Target you can uh identify uh multiple
pathogens and start working on them uh
before they they become a threat so
that's uh
I would say
among many of them is one of uh
the lessons that we can take from the
SARS computer pandemic if I gotta write
your question
yeah so uh like I just wanted to know
one more thing like nappy is also
um like outraging the data science and
biomedical research study to the
undergraduate and postgraduate students
so what are the more facilities which
Snappy is providing to the students and
researchers out there to learn
biomedical research and learn more
skills to develop bioinformatics
students
and which can be utilized in your labs
um uh Dr Rick we would like to take this
one
you're here
okay can you please repeat sorry I was
distracted
yeah so I just wanted to ask like uh
nepes also uh like like enhancing the
study of biomedical research and they
need more students undergrads and
postgraduates or students for their labs
to conduct bioinformatics uh studies so
what are the major steps which your lab
is taking apart from what a nappy is
doing
so we are but we are mainly doing
sonatic research so we are in the animal
human interface
we we use Next Generation sequencing and
bioinformatics as tools
for our research so I personally or we I
personally do not have an undergraduate
graduate student in that
Topic in that uh bioinformatic topic but
we work with people within the
university we have a bioinformatics
center in the University which is the in
bioinformatics and of the Kansas Embry
and so we work with these people and
they educate undergraduates and graduate
students
okay all right
so I guess with this uh we are now
uh good too and this Symposium and I
would like to thank all three of you
took like attend this Symposium and give
a talk to our students who are in The
Learning phase and by your talk they
might be more uh motivational like they
might have taken more motivation to
study and go in your universities and
work along with you in both Kansas and
LSU with
sure
I just need to tell you that I'm an
outside advisor to case is you so I was
there spending three wonderful days with
these few these guys they're doing
absolute amazing job there so anybody
who's interested in animal research KCU
is the place just talk to Dr Rick
yeah so it has an NIH it's very critical
everybody heard about one Health and
sonoric diseases Sasuke V2 is a
obviously a prototype of that so we work
in that
space
sonaric diseases
and they obviously include animals
thank you Gus we love to have you here
and uh and that was a good experience I
hope I'm glad it was a good experience
for you coming to this little apple
Manhattan is called the little apple
it's a little
Big Apple it's a little Big Apple
because of Caesar than Dr Rick
thank you Gus okay guys take care okay
thank you
so
first right there
uh yes obviously
so I guess it was very insightful as the
last one loving panel discussion uh if I
compare with any other
so uh and with this we would like to
come to the end of a two days or mixed
research Symposium themed around
computational biology data science and
other specialized Fields like infectious
diseases and many more we would like to
extend our gratitude to all the guest
speakers who took out the time to share
their experiences with the young
researchers and clarify their doubts
also thanks to all the participants who
have joined our lovely audience
and we would like to inform those
participants who have enrolled for the
two-day Symposium we will be mailing
them their certificates by next week
so goodbye have a nice day ahead and
take care
thank you
sorry can I ask something
yeah yeah sure yeah yeah all right
please is it possible to have a
recording of the of the four words
yes definitely so we will be sharing the
recording of uh these sessions like we
will be uh posting out on our YouTube
channel as well publishing it out on our
YouTube channel as well as on our social
media platforms and we will also mail
you all with the session recordings
obviously after doing a bit of editing
and other stuff so we'll do share the
session recordings with each and every
participant and oh just we has shared
the live recording of day two the link
of the YouTube uh so you can copy paste
it and you can uh view it again
for sharing okay thank you very much
you're welcome if anyone is having any
more questions
yes yes
um Abdul I guess uh like I cannot hear
you properly because you are speaking
from
a little bit far uh if if it's possible
can you please uh type down in the chat
box and I'll be able to answer your
query I was asking if one could make the
attendance yesterday
will someone be able to wear this
certificate also
I I didn't stay long before
yes so uh talking about the certificate
uh Abdul name and everyone else
uh there is a specific fee for this
certification part and it is being
divided into three different categories
student then a faculty and then people
from industry or just we can share the
page Link in the chat box you can go
through with the
a page and you can see if it suits you
the resources which we are giving and
you can you know proceed with the
enrollment part and we'll be sharing uh
if if anyone has missed out yesterday's
session we'll be sharing the session
recording as well they can take a look
at that particular time and they'll also
receive certificate if they'll enroll
now as well so there's a specific fee
for this two-day omish research
Symposium and it's a very minimal fee
has shared the link in the chat box you
can uh like you can copy paste this link
and take a look
I hope I answered your question
perfect anyone else is having any uh
doubt or any query please feel free to
unmute and ask or maybe type here in the
chat yeah welcome Abdul
okay I guess there are no more questions
then we are good to end this two days
only day two training
um sorry could you please repeat
the link for the YouTube or um watch is
it for the day two training alone yes
and the language of Joseph has shared in
the chat it's the live recording of this
day two of research Symposium so you can
you can view yeah you can see and you
can listen all the talks once again
okay well for this day one maybe later
that one will be sent yes yes for day
one uh we'll be sharing it uh next week
as no one can find it on your YouTube
channel
yes we'll be sharing it with you by
Monday
okay thank you very much day one yeah
Day One recording we will be sharing
uh will be shared with you by Monday and
uh here if you want to search uh like
where is day one research Symposium
recording you can search on our YouTube
channel and oh just we has a shared the
link here in the chat itself so you can
go and uh
take a look if you want to find where
the link is but we'll be definitely
providing you with the session recording
by Monday or Tuesday next week
any other question or doubt
okay I guess there are no more questions
and then we are good to go thank you
everyone again for joining and uh for
interacting and brainstorming with the
guest speakers and we will be meeting
you again uh
in our next omics research Symposium
which will be I guess in August or so so
thanks everyone thanks to the organizing
team take care have a nice day ahead
goodbye